a
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
o
oh
[Music]
I
[Laughter]
[Music]
I up
[Laughter]
[Music]
and
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
a
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
o
oh
[Music]
have a lot of interesting presentations
Keynotes and panels to present to you
all today but before we start I know
it's a slow start it's say three we are
halfway through some of us have been
ready to a couple of parties I get it
that's good or maybe not or just you
know like chilling getting a massage
every day just a bit of
housekeeping if you don't have access to
your D Connect app app it's an app it's
an app it's a password and go check it
out there you can see all the schedule
for the next two days and you can ask
questions to the presenters as well if
we scroll down you join the Q&A through
the mircat app and you can already start
submitting your questions also we will
be live streaming all the sessions not
only from the main stage but also from
the other five stages spread out
throughout this venue so if you want to
send to someone you know a link so hey
I'm in this presentation looks pretty
nice go check it out I would highly
advise you to do so and like I said
today it's definitely not about me and I
would love to start introducing your
first presenter for the day so today
here you've been hearing a lot of um for
the past two days you be hearing since
cryptography to ital culture fromal main
ads to also l2s and today we're going to
start with usability on how crypto and
how blockchain can be useful and used in
real life and I'm very very happy to
bring a fellow Portuguese here to
present this very first session we have
Pedro Gomes that's going to present
smart accounts need smart sessions
you're going to cover about how wallet
connect is introducing smart sessions
and also on walkr on other eeran
standards for the day so everyone give a
warm welcome to Pedro
GES thank
you thank you thank you and thanks to my
fellow Portuguese for pronouncing my
name correctly for the first time in a
conference so as you heard my name is
Pedro Gom I'm the founder and director
of the wall connect foundation and I'm
really thrilled to be talking to you
more about the future of wallets how
we're going to change the experience for
users and most important L how we're
going to have Smart accounts use Smart
sessions and why why do they even need
smart sessions obviously I don't expect
people to know what smart accounts are
or what smart sessions are and I feel
like we need to kind of go on a journey
why wallets work in the way they are so
let's start with breaking down the lingo
like when you think about wallets you
might think about the leather wallets in
your pockets or you might think about
the digital wallet in your phone and you
might even think about metamask rainbow
zarion trust wallet all of these
blockchain wallets but what makes them
so different as a blockchain wallet it
really comes down to this experience of
before we used to log in into
applications and now we connect but it's
not just a change of the word itself it
really changes the infrastructure and
the technology behind it that completely
revolutionized what is going to be the
future of the internet and all of these
applications so you see all of these
terms throwing around like dabs and
wallets and smart sessions but it all
comes down to authentication like
authentication means it's the process of
proving who you are and what you own and
in a short word when you user sees
authentication it just means that you
want to get in like let me in I want to
get into the application that I don't
really care and if you don't really care
you really want to make sure that you do
as less clicks as possible like less
clicks is more this is our mission for
building a great better user experience
a wallet is better the less you have to
click around but a wallet is also a
little bit more insecure if you don't
approve everything and that's where the
tricky part of balancing convenience and
security so why is web3 different like
we talked that there are physical
leather wallets uh there are digital
wallets in your phone
why are web three wallets or blockchain
wallets any different I like to always
bring probably one of my oldest diagrams
I've been presenting this diagram for
more than 5 years and this kind of
explains uh very simply how the
infrastructure had changed from web 2 to
web 3 before we had a server that was
powering your application but these
servers um inside have this module
that's called Authentication um some
people even call it identity but this is
basically what your login looks like
your login lives in the server and
blockchain obviously does not have a
server and you can't just put login in
there so it was cleverly designed that
we put the wallet on the user side so as
you can see the wallet sits on the
bottom no longer in the blockchain and
that means that now the wallet is your
authentication which is separate from
the app but it has also created the
inconvenience of now every time you use
an app you need a second app which you
know it does have its advantages but it
also adds more clicks which is against
our mission here so when you think about
the wallet it kind of comes down to like
credential signing in account and I kind
of try to break down here what it looks
for different wallets it really doesn't
matter like if you have a mobile wallet
a browser wallet a hardware device or
even if you use a cloud or NPC like they
all come down to like something you know
something that you are and something
that you have and it basically breaks
down into credentials signing in
accounts and you can see here that one
thing that they all have in common is
this concept of an external account
which is going to be important for you
to remember that no matter what wue you
have they all have an external account
but before we get into that um I did say
that connecting is this new verb that we
moved away from the login but we did try
to recreate log in uh with blockchain
and basically didn't work really well
until someone came with a standard which
is called sign in with etherium and
signing with theerum actually is just
this uh it's a text message it's
actually very simple like when you think
about it it just says this website wants
to access your account and then we added
some parameters that says like you can
access this chain for this amount of
period and so on and so forth and even
throw in some terms and conditions to
make it look very familiar but this is
actually more familiar because if you do
Google login it's the same thing but
we're so early into blockchain that we
don't have this beautiful UI on the
right we have a text message so wallets
are slowly adopting sign of ethereum to
not just be a text message and to
actually be like a concise and compact
display that allows you to connect and
eventually you might even have this like
you actually have
AUM here I just model ified literally
the Google one and I put like some
ethereum stuff but it in concept it's
the same thing it's the exact same thing
that sign tries to achieve with the
difference that you still have to
connect to then sign which doesn't feel
very great like it's like a twostep to
do something that was before a one step
so I'm part of this uh Community called
The Chain agnostic Improvement proposals
the and we proposed this wallet
authenticate which basic basically tries
to bring back uh the login experience
and basically that meant that we what if
we just don't connect anymore we just
like go straight to the signature so if
you could just do sign with ethereum
like you could actually get this like
Google login experience with your wallet
and it would be even more secure because
when you're signing your wallet and
connecting at the same time you're
actually verifying ownership of your
wallet so this was actually pretty cool
and this gots us like you know like like
less clicks is more but is that enough
like because at the end of the day most
wallets are used for transaction
purposes and loging in is just one part
of it so yes we reduced connect and sign
into a single step but after you log in
or you connect with your wallet you
still need to perform some transactions
and this looks as you know switching to
the wallet and everything approving
transactions and when you think about
signing transactions there's a lot of
new on here like the beautiful thing
about ethereum is that it's a smart
contract blockchain which means you can
do everything the disadvantage of being
able to do everything is that these
transactions can be incredibly complex
and understanding what these
transactions look like um can be a
little daunting and at the end of the
day people just like close their eyes
and they just like a proof you know
let's be honest with ourselves like if
it's not transferring a token most
people are are not actually looking into
this and the reason for that is because
there's applications out there that we
don't know about it so but we also don't
want to scare people away and this kind
of balancing convenience and security is
kind of hard right that's kind of like
the magic of building a great wallet
where you have to allow people to
explore every application that exists
and at the same time make sure they're
secure and I'm not saying that we
haven't done a good job but
we still have to continue to focus on
doing less clicks is more and at the
same time we actually have to give
people security and I think this is
where we go back to the definition of a
wallet that I mentioned it's credentials
signing and an account and all wallets
today have external accounts so that's
why we then have the concept of smart
accounts technically speaking they're
not called smart accounts uh neither are
external accounts they're called
externally owned accounts most commonly
referred as EAS and then we have Smart
contract accounts uh or SC csas but no
honestly like when I have conversation
with people we just call it external
account and smart account like that's
kind of like the easy way so most
wallets today like 95 or 99% of the time
are external accounts and we're in this
process of making the experience better
by turning them into smart accounts
which means that they're going to be
more programmable but it also me means
that like you now have to deploy a smart
contract so if you have to deploy a
smart contract you're no longer thinking
of your wallet as just one key that is
managed by your secret recovery phrase
you actually have a smart contract and
that is like the account that your
wallet manages but if you don't have an
a key you don't have a signature so how
am I actually going to sign like the
whole purpose of this was to sign so
what is actually controlling your smart
account so there was a standard that was
created which is how can we actually
validate ownership over contracts
because while with signing with the T it
was very simple you signed this text
message and now I can just verify that
the signature matches your address but
with a smart contract I don't really
know how to validate it so ERC 1271
created like a very simple interface
that says is valid signature it like you
know sometimes people think like this
code things are very complic ated but
this is literally the whole spec like
it's like very long to read but then
it's is valid signature is the whole
code like and this basically takes a
signature and throws a true or false so
it basically it's a binary that says yes
it is a valid signature so your smart
contract is basically saying that this
signature was done by someone who was
authorized to control my account so now
we have to get a little on the nitty G
actually break down what it means to
have an account so the same way a wallet
is credential signing an account an
account then is defined by who is the
signer who is the payer and what kind of
cryptography is involved um in an
external account it's pretty
straightforward like you have the same
signer you have the same payer and you
have the cryptography which on ethereum
is scsp 256 K1 and that's it like you
don't have an option this is what an
external account is on ethereum and this
is what your external account is going
to do with a smart account actually this
is a little bit more flexible now we
have a smart contract where we can
encode logic that allows you to have
more programmability this
programmability can be many things but
at the core of smart accounts it means
that you can have multiple signers
multiple signers does not necessarily
mean that's a multisig the reason I try
to not call it a multisig because
there's a preconception about multisig
being multiparty and that means oh you
have multiple people signing for the
smart account therefore this is like a
business account no it's not a business
account you would have a multiple
signatures by using your account in a
mobile phone and a desktop that in
itself already provides you with like a
good reason why you need a smart account
because you don't want to move your keys
around with different devices or you
might even want to do something more
complex where you have a secret recover
recy phrase that you own in a piece of
paper for security and then you have
like one in your device and one in the
desktop and you use like two Factor
authentication so this idea of
programmability makes for more security
and convenience at the same time so we
really find the balance here with smart
accounts another convenience feature is
that we now detached ourselves from the
signer always have to pay and what does
that mean you know everyone understands
here that blockchains have fees and
these fees are called gas and in order
for you to pay for that gas you have to
be both the signature and the payer but
what if you could actually have another
account pay or maybe even you pay but
with a different token with smart
accounts you can actually program that
information so smart accounts not only
allows you to have flexibility of having
multiple signers but then it also means
that you can have a different payer than
the signer and maybe even you don't pay
someone else pays and finally the
cryptography like the actual
cryptographic curves can be infinite
well infinite not so much because the
more contract logic that you add into
your smart contract the higher the gas
cost but you get the picture it's way
more flexible and if it's more flexible
it means that we can actually get a
little more creative like I don't know
how much you know about cryptography but
256 K1 the curve of ethereum is actually
not that popular that's how we like to
reinvent the wheel kind kind of thing we
kind of like to use things that nobody
else uses but all of your phones
actually use uh other cryptographic
curves like for example one that's
called
p256 uh which most people now know today
as the curve that's used for Pas keys so
what if you could actually use pass keys
to control your smart account now we're
getting really convenient because now I
can have pass keys in different devices
they all control the SM the same smart
account and I don't even need to pay for
the gas this is getting a little too
good to be true
uh but at the end of the day you could
imagine that like you would have like
multiple wallets and you would interact
with multiple apps but they're all under
the same blockchain but what if you
could just have like one smart account
everywhere it just kind of like covered
everything that you would touch because
you have multiple devices with like
multiple signers and you share the gas
and you can use pasis if you want it
really would become this like truly
Universal account which smart accounts
really enable that experience and this
is where the terminology account
obstruction comes in like account
obstruction in a way it's like a mindset
it's a framework for you to think about
how can we detach As Much from the
limitations of the blockchain such that
my account can be more programmable more
convenient and still secure and this all
started about two or three years ago
with 4237 um which basically its title
says account obstruction using alt mempo
which I don't think we really really
need to get into that but in the diagram
what it means that before remember we
had the triangle of the app wallet and
blockchain uh things are starting to get
more complicated now right because I
told you now we have multiple signers so
now the signer doesn't necessarily need
to be in the wallet so it's its own
component and you also are not a payer
so now in account obstruction we
introduced the concept of a pay master
so the pay Master is now the payer the
signer is the one who actually does the
transaction and the wallet is you know
the thing that you actually control so
now we have two extra components uh we
made the experience much better but we
also made everything more complex and in
the title you saw that it said the
account obstruction using an Alman pool
uh that essentially means that there's a
pool of transactions that are ready to
go into the blockchain and that's reason
it's called alternative is because it
has to go through a bundler you can no
longer send transactions directly to the
block
chain anyway it this gets really
complicated but I promise you that we're
working really hard and bringing
standardization and we're going to go
through this journey of how smart
sessions are going to fix that so the
first thing you might think is like how
do you actually detect uh if a wallet
supports smart accounts because your
application now has to consider that
your wallet doesn't work like most
wallets you don't have an external
account how do you actually provide that
uh identification uh there's this
concept of wallet calling apis it's a
new standard of how we actually going to
start interfacing applications with
wallets differently and it basically
composes into four new methods um the
most important of these methods I would
say is this one the wallet send calls
and this basically changes how we
actually think about the wallet sending
transactions uh we no longer think about
telling the wallet send me an ethereum
transaction I'm telling you I want to
take these actions and here's the
multiple actions and I want you to
actually execute them and you as a
wallet whether you're a smart account or
not you should just be able to do so and
this comes with this idea of the
introduction of capabilities and this is
how you discover if a wallet actually
can support smart accounts so the wallet
get capabilities actually allows you to
detect that oh on this different chains
this wallet has the capability of pay
Mas or session Keys like you can add
multiple features in there that allow
your wallet to say to the application
you can actually behave in a more
convenient way for your user if you use
these features so this is actually quite
useful because now we notied that the
triangle of the wallet blockchain and
app broke down into multiple pieces and
the application now has the ability to
detect but one thing I did not tell you
and I did not show you the spec of the
4337 is that the despite the spec being
a very very long and complicated spec is
actually missing a lot of stuff like
it's not telling you um how the wallet
supports and which pay Master supports
and what is the interface of pay masters
and we basically kind of just decided
you know the community will figure out
one day and that was kind of okay at the
beginning like if you go back to 2022
2023 people were building pay masters
and sponsoring transactions for everyone
but this was also an opportunity for
fragmentation where everyone had their
own pay master and everyone done
something a little different so in 2024
we realized guys we need to stop this uh
we need to all agree to do pay masters
in the same way and we wrote the
standard
7677 which created this part is not
really that interesting um I just kind
of wanted to give you a picture how a
few lines of code can make a big
difference of how we can make this world
a little bit better by not having pay
masters uh capture value of locking
users into their pay master and can have
all pay masters working the same way it
was a very small thing but it made a big
difference another thing we didn't talk
is about the actual smart contract
design you know like I mentioned before
ethereum allows you to do pretty much
everything like so what would change
because in external accounts every
account work the same but with smart
contracts that kind of gives a little
bit too much flexib ability and if every
wallet Works slightly different then
we're going to have to start having
problems we standardize how account
abstraction framework works we
standardize how the pay Master works but
what about your actual smart contract
what can I do with your smart contract
account so this is where 7579 came in
and it provided a very minimal framework
for how to create modules and in these
modules you can essentially think that
we can use the basic like make smart
contract codes that we all agree is the
consensus of what a smart contract
account is and then we can all install
modules so you can think of these like
almost as plugins for your account
adding new functionality and becoming
this more vibrant ecosystem where
everyone adds new features these
features could be uh for example
recovery like you want to do recovery in
interesting ways like where you include
uh your family and friends or can
include a third party it could also be
features like you know proving different
credentials in your modules it could be
some features around how you define
policies of how you actually manage your
account under certain conditions and for
me personally the one that I got a
little bit more curious about was hm if
I can control how my account is used
under some policies I'm essentially
giving the ability for the smart
contract account to manage itself
because I say I don't want you to be
able to spend this amount of tokens
within this window of time and if I can
do that I'm starting to think what if we
actually had the app actually sign the
actual operations on my behalf then if
that's going to be the case then we're
going to start thinking wait if the app
signs on my behalf I no longer have to
return to my wallet to approve every
transaction and this would create the
best picture because now I've told you
at the beginning that we were able to
create sign with ethereum in a single
click by removing the connect but now
I'm telling you that the app itself
would be able to sign on my behalf
because I have a smart contract account
and this is essentially what would be
the end goal where you log in once and
then you actually have the app do all of
the work but it gets a little
complicated because um I as I told you
like the app doesn't really have this
concept of how to actually create the
transactions for your smart contract
account because you might have installed
certain modules and those modules have
to actually operate very differently uh
so we're currently working and the
reason it says XXX because it's is
really work in progress uh this new API
that actually allows you to delegate to
the application to prepare the calls and
actually generate the signatures
independently so we we come almost to
the end where now we have Smart sessions
so you now have a smart account you've
been able to log in in a single click
you have a pay master that subsidizes
your gas and now the application using
the previous standard or wallet prepar
calls has the ability of signing
signatures on your behalf uh because
using this API they know exactly how to
operate independently uh we basically
reduce less clicks is more now the only
thing we need to tell to this
application is what can you do with this
uh smart session and this is where the
final standard comes in which is Grant
permissions from wallets so the
application is able to request
permissions the user approves those
permissions and those permissions can be
encoded as we saw with the Google login
as part of the sign with ethereum and
then once you return that context to the
application the application can send it
directly to the bundler so now we don't
even need to have the wallet in the loop
and the application is able to use the
smart session to operate your uh wallet
because you basically said you can only
do this much for this amount of time
with this amount of tokens and you
basically created the rules for the
bundler to understand that this app can
sign on your behalf with a smart account
but there's some concerns about you know
if the app actually has control of a
signer that controls your wallet uh it
can cause some problems I don't know how
much you guys know about web security
but browsers are not very secure so this
is where I also wanted to bring back the
concept of pass keys because now your
app can generate a pass key for your
smart account and control it under the
certain permissions that you give and
this then looks like you know these pass
keys and then your wallet essentially
becomes a pass key for that specific app
under certain permissions so the only
thing that we need to do now is actually
upgrade the evm because one thing that
the evm has a problem is actually with
Computing different crypto curves so if
we add the actual curve for pass Cas
into the blockchain then we actually
would have an even cheaper gas for
everyone however this is actually
something that's been in progress with
some rollups but not necessarily for the
etherum Mania so you might think that
I'm from wall connect if the app does
everything for the wall what is actually
being connected realistically you've
essentially logged in into your app and
you've passed on the wallet inside your
app it's almost like you have the
concept of a mini wallet so we basically
have almost like what we had in web 2
but now the authentication lives on the
app under certain condition so you might
be thinking are we done is this the end
game we fixed everything um not really
because one thing that I didn't explain
is that this only works in the same
blockchain and we currently have I
forgot the number like 500 rollups or
something like it gets really
complicated so what if smart sessions
could actually function across all
chains so I'm going to bring some new
lingo into the table and we're going to
talk about chain abstraction I'm joking
we're not going to talk about chain
abstraction but this is the next game
right we basically have wallets moving
to Smart accounts we now as part of
wallet connect we have the ability to
introduce smart sessions to make the
user experience better and chain
abstraction is the next game where
bringing interruptable tokens magic
spend uh 7702 and like Bridges and
solvers and bundlers we can really have
the chain abstraction uh improve the
experience and then you might think what
is the future of wallets like before you
just had like apps and wallets talking
through wall connect and now you have
like sessions and signs and pay Master
most importantly we want to work on
redefining what is the wallet experience
for web 3 and making it as convenient
and secure as possible but most
importantly we want to make sure that
less clicks is more and people have the
time to really enjoy the benefits of
these
applications thank
[Applause]
you thank you so much Pedro we already
have a couple of questions here not sure
if we will be able to cover all of them
but let's going to start with the most
voted here ped is it already possible to
use a same account abstraction account
oh sorry across all your twoos if not
when do you think it will be possible so
it is possible to some extent but as you
saw smart accounts are deployed
contracts so you actually have to deploy
the contract in every L2 that exists so
if you have to deploy the smart contract
in every L2 that exist that means that
you have to manage multiple accounts and
it gets really really inconvenient
people are working on how you can manage
account across multiple chains and I
think chain abstraction is the next
level I think of chain abstraction as
almost like cross-chain smart accounts
So eventually very
soon another question
here wouldn't giving a session to the DB
Mak scammer DB life so much easier well
obviously that's a topic for discussion
like smart sessions is about 9 months
old uh we have done some experimentation
how much permission should you have to
give to the app that it's convenient for
you but it still makes you secure like
The Current Designs currently focus on
spending policies and that has been most
of the conversation but in my opinion it
should not make it easier uh because you
can actually have more control because
of smart accounts give you
programmability is smart sessions a
smart account so smart if smart CH is
our smart contract is another topic of
discussion if you go to the spec of 7715
there's two versions uh there's one
that's called session key smart sessions
and there's one that's called session
account smart session so there's a
little bit of a difference of how people
think about it
um but yes I guess you could say the
easy answer is
yes and then one last question do you
think of sessions as longl lasting or
shortlived
um look when you think about login uh
login actually is on average people log
in into a website and those sessions are
7even days but what web2 has
successfully done is that they can renew
those sessions so essentially at every
every 7even days you have the ability to
renew the smart session so we don't have
this capability of automatically
renewing smart sessions today but that's
how we envision us kind of inheriting
that design from web 2 where smart
sessions would be one week old and then
you would just renew it automatically
without you having to log in every
time ped thank you so much that was a
great presentation thank you so much
everyone adding so many
questions for yeah definitely today I
learned a little more about account
obstruction and also wallets for the
next session uh I came with a lot of
curiosity especially because they
speaker I don't know if it was to save
time or to leave everyone you know
curious about it we're going to talk
about applied
cryptography and why is it worthed to
attend and to be at this uh at this conf
at this talk today another um to remind
you can also submit the questions
throughout the app the QR code will be
right next to it as you can start
submitting your questions and so on and
also you can write notes and
collaborative notes and then everyone
can know what you think about the
session and things that will be useful
so I'd love to invite on stage Barry
that's going to talk
about applied cryptography why is it
worth it and with the name of the
session is IO welcome
[Music]
Barry okay thank you everybody is this
good can you hear me okay so today I'm
going to talk about IO so this talk
starts with like an inciting incident so
in 2013 or 2023 I took a trip to
Marseilles and I got really bad food
poisoning I was I was very sick and I
had these kind of like hallucinations
that ordinarily you need to pay like a
lot of money to get so it was either
this or it was this but I don't know
which which one was the culprit um but
like so people think that like your your
stomach is actually like a part of your
brain that like the the bacteria in your
stomach uh it digests food in a certain
way and it communicates with your brain
which like affects the way that you
actually think and after I had the food
poisoning it really it kind of changed
my life a lot uh here are some of the
changes that happened so I started
living alone I live I moved to a new
city to live with friends I I stopped
being a digital Nomad and I had a a home
for the first time in like five or six
years uh I started to focus on health I
found like peace in my life that I
didn't know was possible to have I also
quit my job um and all of this
was like precipitated by me having food
poisoning but I think that it was more
like another contributing factor is that
like I just always want more from life
like the things that the things that I
have or the things that we have is is
like never satisfying for me you know so
I I'm always like searching for more um
so like so now I'm going to talk about
like some of the things that we
currently have that I think are not
enough uh one of them is the like the
whole programmable cryptography tool of
like proof of validity like this is a
useful tool but like we've been using it
for years and it seems that like we've
we've we're getting close to the limits
of applications like I'm very excited
that we have ZK EVMS and we have ZK
rollups and that we have this like whole
proof of validity uh uh ecosystem that's
that's growing but I don't think that
this has transformed the way the world
in the way that I was hoping that
programmable cryptography would change
the world another thing that I'm
concerned about is like ZK so I spent a
lot of time thinking about like well why
was the first blockchain thing a
currency rather than a reputation system
uh because I thought that like well a
reputation system is going to be much
more like free and open but the reason I
think is that like reputation systems
are inherently about like excluding
people and it seems that like this is a
difficult thing to like build as like a
it it seems as less empowered R than a
currency system which is like like free
for anyone to use basically um so like
I'm less excited about doing like
private identity stuff and because it's
inherently about like excluding
people uh so like last year I spent a
lot of time thinking about like what
else could we have you know like what
was the future what was a better future
for us so this time last year I gave a
talk about it's called 2pc is for Lovers
and it talks about how we can use FHA
and NPC to have this like multiple Pary
hallucinated server where you have this
like encrypted computer that like you do
all of the operations inside the
computer and nobody knows what's going
on inside and like the talk is
interesting and it digs into this idea
and proposes some sample
applications uh but one of the big
problems with this whole direction of
work is that it required interaction so
like with MPC you need it to be online
to in order to execute the server and I
was I think like I'm currently most
excited about like having servers with
many many people uh Computing together
and if you wanted to have a server with
like a million people you just can't do
that right because a million people
would have to be online at the same time
and Computing together at the same time
which seems to me just to be completely
impractical because like someone is
going to lose their password or
someone's going to lose their phone and
you just won't be able to see the final
result or you won't be able to finish
the
computation but the thing that uh that
so so in order to overcome this the tool
that we need to uses IO which which is
stands for indistinguishable OBS fation
which basically takes away the
interactivity uh that we that we need to
have for hallucinated servers up until
now um so if you want to do something
new you have to do things differently so
the rest of my talk I'm going to talk
about like the the different things that
we're doing uh so why don't we have it
already so it's hard uh like in theal
alisation has been an open problem for a
long time recently in 2022 the first
practic or the first scheme from
standard assumptions was proposed and
this was a big deal in the io world
because it was the first time that it
was like even theoretically possible to
do this but unfortunately the scheme is
Not Practical it would take millions of
years to like execute to to do a full uh
execution of IO an IO circuit um but
this is from standard assumptions so in
cryptography we're we we always try to
base what we're doing upon standard
assumptions uh but like actually in the
cryptocurrency world we won't really do
this so much uh in the cryptocurrency
world we we use a bunch of non-standard
assumptions that like the regular
cryptography Community would be very
concerned about and like two examples
are like the snack friendly hash
functions they use this very like crazy
kind of assumption that like we like the
rest of cryptography doesn't really
think about and also grinding is right
is another non-standard
assumption so like well the question is
like like another question ask is like
why do we even need to assume anything
in the first place and the reason for
this is that like when like P equals NP
question mark is like this big open
problem in computer science it's like
this kind of like million Millennium
prize if you're able to prove like P is
not equal to NP is basically says that
like some things are easy and some
things are hard and like all of the easy
things all of the hard things are not
actually just secret secretly easy
things uh so because we can't prove that
something is hard or something is easy
easy we're not able to prove that like
no sorry because we're not able to prove
that anything is hired and or anything
is easy we're not able to prove that
like specific things are hired or easy
because of that we're not able to to say
that like well this problem is hard it's
hard to solve this it's hard to decrypt
this unless you have the private key so
what are current assumptions we
currently use well we currently use a
bunch of assumptions that are based upon
prime numbers so elliptic elliptic
curves is like a prime number based
assumption and this assumption has been
chosen because it's been like an open
problem for hundreds of years for
hundreds of years number theory has been
trying to figure out to understand more
about about prime numbers and about like
their distribution or whatever and this
is the assumption that like most of our
cryptography is based upon because it's
just really hard like it's been open for
a long time but like the problem is that
there's a lot of there's a lot of
complexity here there's a lot of
complexity I want to go back yeah
there's a lot of complexity here in
Prime not because it's just like this
kind of security by obscurity thing it's
this problem we've been trying to solve
for years and years and years and like
no one has made any progress on it so
therefore we think it's hard but like
I'm not like there's been like recently
more people have been trying to come up
with like simpler assumptions that are
ALS that are also like we think hard and
like lisis is an example of this uh okay
now I want to go to the next slide
okay so like the lus assumption is that
much simpler than the prime prime number
based assumptions and they seem like
much more it intuitively it seems to me
like much harder but it's not like but
we can't prove it like we can't prove
that anything is hard so we just have to
base everything on these
assumptions um it seem yeah so like one
EXA so what does it take for like an
assumption to become like a standard
assumption so it took about 10 years for
the lce based assumptions become like
standard although like many people in
the cryptography Community are still
very skeptical about lates for example
Daniel Bernstein is just like does not
is not confident in in lattice based uh
cryptography
um yeah so like this slide I don't know
if I have time to go deeply into it but
it's basically claiming that like AI is
more dangerous than quantum computers
because for cryptography because
like if AI seems to be a tool to like
teach people and that seems to me like
inherently more powerful than a tool
that's like able to do comp compute so
like I feel that like this like I make a
prediction here that like well in the
next 20 years AI is going to make break
more stuff than quantum computers will
um I think this is a good this is a good
bet um but like it means that like the
the assumptions that we that we
previously had uh we need to be more
careful about right because like we're
we're going into a world where where the
like old this has been hired for a very
long time might might not CH might not
be remain being the case as okay so
right so so like basically I become open
to to using like non-standard
assumptions to build IO and the hope is
that like we will be able to here's a
list of papers uh and and and basically
the way it works is the top uh from top
to bottom is from like standard
assumptions to like more exotic
assumptions um yeah and here are
implementations of the various schemes
but this is in no particular order I
should have ordered this
better uh yeah so like basically our
goal is to like Implement these schemes
and to like break them or or try to find
and then to build tools to build things
on top of the schemes so like we have a
we have a bunch so so we're announcing
this bounty where we've implemented the
first paper or the last paper on the
list the most like
uh extreme assumption on the list before
it's called local mixing and basically
you can take a circuit with 1,000 Gates
and OB fiscated which basically means
that you add like Randomness to the
Circuit until the circuit becomes
230,000 Gates and then basically the
challenge is to take the 230,000 gate
circuit and reverse it to the 104 Gates
circuit right so be able to remove all
of the noise while maintaining the
functionality of the circuit and we
claim that this is really really hard
and if this is really hard it's it's
basically like indistinguishable
location we can build a bunch of cool
stuff so this is a a boundy that we're
just announcing today and so the the
price is $10,000 for someone who's able
to do this and this is a a collaboration
between these three groups phandom Zone
ZX Park and the etherum
foundation uh yeah so well what would it
mean if we were able to do IO um we
would basically finish cryptography and
the reason like okay so here's how to
think about this so basically you can
model IO as like a trusted third party
that you can actually trust so Z you can
Al you can model zero knowledge proof
like this but the parity is more limited
so if you have a trusted third party
that like does some compute and verifies
the compute for you then that's like
that's like what a zero knowledge proof
is but with with I with with like once
you get to IO you have a transy that's
able to do basically everything they're
able to verify computation they're able
to they're able to like do multi-party
computation stuff they're able to
maintain secrets and only use the secret
under certain conditions
um so IO is basically very close to the
end of what we of what we would need uh
or is close to the end of programmable
cryptography uh and like I don't know
what I'm like I I feel like this is like
the last big Quest it's kind of like you
know that in history there was a time
when people thought that there was there
was just more land that people didn't
know like people were like exploring the
world and there was just more places to
go you could always like go further west
but then at one point you just got like
to the end of the world and then it was
like what do you do like what do those
people do like imagine that you're like
you're like yeah I want to live a life
of adventure and then you get to the
west coast of the US and you're just
like done like what
next I don't know but I feel like no
matter what I will not be happy
because nobody wants to finish
programmable cryptography less than I
do okay so uh while you're in Thailand
there's all these opportunities to have
these like life-changing experiences so
go to the night market and and don't be
too
careful
uh so there's two more there's a couple
more talks about this um um there's 2m
on stage six today Jay is going to talk
more about the Bounty he's going to dig
into like how local mixing works and a
bunch of and and like a bunch of things
about like the the scheme itself like
the we don't have any tools yet that
people can like build applications on
top of um at the moment we're still like
we just made the simplest possible
circuit but it's reasonably practical
the the the thing the thing that takes
the most time time is actually doing the
obfuscation to run the circuit it's just
like a 2,000 260,000 gate circuit that
you execute so like the performance is
pretty good but like that said it is a
very extreme assumption that we're
building on I think that like our plan
is to imp sorry let me go back and show
the show the other
papers so we already did local mixing
but our plan is to sort of work up from
like most extreme assumption and most
practical or least and most practical to
to less extreme and least practical and
hopefully somewhere along the way we'll
find we'll find something that's that
like is in The Sweet Spot uh I'm
confident that we'll be able to find
something that works uh from standard
assumptions but I think that like it's
important to start and like our goal is
to like have a bounty for a bunch of
these different schemes and always have
one that's not being broken or like
always have two that's not being broken
and just like continue this effort
because like the the the lattice based
assumptions uh it took like 10 years to
go from being like kind of crazy
assumption to more useful or like more
more accepted so we're hoping that like
we'll be able to like navigate a similar
trajectory
here
okay okay yeah so there's more talks I
think on uh Tomorrow there's a bunch of
talks about IO that would be interesting
for people to check out um
yeah I have a little bit extra time I
can take some questions or I can talk
some more if I remember some other stuff
I wanted to
say thank you so much Barry thank
you this presentation was very complex
for my non technical brain but actually
the audience here here have added very
cool questions and the first one here
that I wanted to ask was you know like a
definition what is an what's IO and uh
pretty much an explanation if you could
do like an explain like M five that
would be helpful sure uh so iio stands
for indistinguishable
obfuscation and it basically means like
encrypting a program such that you can
execute the program and you can get a an
output that you can that is not
encrypted so like no one is able to see
what the program is doing but what you
get out is something that you can
understand so basically it's like FHA
but in a non-interactive
way like another way to think about it
is I can give like the formal definition
but maybe we should go to the other the
next question let's take the next
question another question here what does
IO replace
ZK ah so IO kind of includes ZK so
there's ways that you can use IO to to
well it like it depends what you mean by
ZK because people abuse the term to mean
a whole bunch of things and like I used
to do that too well I don't know if I
did used to do that too but yeah okay so
if you mean zero knowledge proofs as
just like a proof that a computation was
done correctly then then it's like yeah
you can do you can you can do that with
IO but IO is much more than ZK it's it's
more powerful because like another way
to think about this is ZK is like a
single player thing can prove about
things that I know I can show people
things that I know and other people show
me things that they know but there's no
way to do like a collaborative proof
there's no way to do a multiplayer
things right and like iio basically lets
you do like multiplayer stuff so you can
do like all these interesting Co
coordination
things well you got here some love from
your PSC colleagues and I have another
question for you so Quantum machine
learning will break more things than AI
or Quantum each alone sorry Quantum
machine learning will break more things
than AI or quanton by
themsel you break more AI or Break It on
its own uh I think that like AI by
itself will break more than than than
quantum computers by
itself does IO not rely on any
assumption yeah yeah yeah it does I
relies on a bunch of of different
assumptions like all all cryptography
lies on assumptions except for one time
pad which doesn't rely on any
assumptions is there any physical hard
limit to how fast cryptography ZK Etc
can get uh yes it can like ZK cannot get
faster than the than the thing you're
trying to prove you at least have to
like calculate the
witness um or you need to be able to
like do the
computation um
ZK has that limit and so does everything
I guess I suppose that like you at least
need to understand what you're trying to
do I need to think more about like the
io case to have like a more coherent
answer when will I you happen one year
five years how would you define
prediction market for this H yeah that
sounds good uh an IO prediction Market I
think that like we like it like I think
the key thing to ask in that question is
from like what kind of assumptions that
like we historically we've had a whole
bunch of IO schemes that have been from
like standard from non-standard
assumptions but they've all been broken
um so I think it's just a matter of time
on like so so like that's the important
thing to include if you're thinking
about when you're asking this question
so from like non-standard assumptions I
think pretty soon like it's already the
case that there's practical IO schemes
from non-standard assumptions but we
don't know if they'll be broken or not
so like that's another interesting thing
we could do prediction Market of whether
a particular assumption will be broken
that could be really fun um yeah do we
need Deton if IO works yeah yeah I think
I think that there's still these things
kind of like add together uh so there's
a couple of things that IO is not able
to do one of them is like data proof of
publication or data availability uh
cryptography as far as we know is not
able to make sure that you have
published something because that's like
a it's it's like an objective reality to
be confident something that's been
published is not possible to do with
just compute you need to have some
consensus so ethereum is still useful
for
this what are you personally excited to
work on almost the end of cryptography
research is reached I don't
know I don't know yeah
I don't know I I feel like I'm just
secretly going to try and sabotage our
efforts yeah there is a lot of questions
here but I do wanted to find one maybe
like one last
question if you can compare IO with food
what would
be
[Music]
um I don't know
probably the hardest question you've got
in this I see it seems to be some kind
of like food that consumes all of the
food so like
atoms yeah okay yeah yeah okay carbon
that's a good that's a good closing for
your present bar thank you so much was
very cool to learn more about IO
everyone give it up for
[Applause]
Barry so have a short break now we'll be
back at 11: so 9 minutes so make sure to
grab your coffee and then come back to
hear from Zach Williamson from
[Music]
Aztec
e e
[Music]
[Laughter]
for
[Music]
e
e for
[Music]
for
and and we are
back how's everyone
doing good good good oh that's becoming
crowded that's good good good
good all right so this next
session before getting started the
session um there's something that I love
about thean Community because we do have
the same Mission we do see the same
vision
but all of us we might walk in different
directions which is great because
everything will lead to something better
and something good not only for the
ecosystem the ecosystem but hopefully
for the world some of us may care more
about UI and ux some of us may care more
about cryptography usability and some of
us and I could see a lot of us care
about privacy
which is such an important thing and has
been around for very long but it seems
that lately us dayon the blockchain
community overall has been pushing this
forward so I'm very very excited to
introduce on the stage today Zack
Williamson from Aztec we chat about
makon cyber bank again why we need
privacy welcome Zach thank you
[Applause]
thanks you everybody um hello good
morning uh so um for those who don't
know I am Zack I am the CEO of Aztec we
are a layer 2 building on top of the
ethereum network uh with privacy by
default privacy is a first class
primitive and so here I'm want to talk a
little bit about uh about privacy why
it's important why I think that not only
is it uh necessary for blockchain to
thrive why it is an essential missing
component uh that will decide the future
of our industry um
so
cck there we go
um I think that the information age so
the the the rise of the internet the
rise of uh this Mass peer-to-peer
communication Network and the rise of AI
agents operating within it has massively
increased um like the overall human um
Prosperity uh it is it has done
wonderful things for the world but it
has had a very dark undertone which is
that it is eroding these trust
foundations that our society is built
upon um before uh the proliferation of
online networks when we our social
spaces were still uniquely physical
spaces um it was very easy to to forge
bonds of trust between individuals and
hold people accountable and nowadays a
lot of our social spaces have moved into
the online space where uh you don't know
who you're interacting with what
algorithms are attempting to manipulate
you what uh corporations are attempting
to monetize you um and as a result we
don't trust each other uh and I think
the technologies that we are all
developing here today uh these
information networks they are going to
be uh the Keystone that brings a lot of
this
back uh so I'm not sure this is going to
play this is a little momentum from 1998
so privacy has been around privacy of
technology has been around for a long
time this is halin uh one of the OG uh
Bitcoin Pioneers talking about um
creating zero knowledge proofs uh to
prove hidden hidden statements all the
way back in 1998 oh it does play hang on
is it playing no never mind um uh back
then it took 120 Minutes to prove
knowledge of a of a basic shahash uh
things have improved along a long uh
since then but we are the inheritors of
a great legacy this has been a long time
coming so I want to talk a little bit
about why
is uh what are we even doing here um
what even is a blockchain useful for why
blockchain why decentralization and I'm
going to do this by talking about uh
this concept of information networks and
communication complexity how a society's
ability to be um consensus driven to be
to be equ
is in my opinion largely a function of
uh its communication complexity which
itself is a function of technology and
I'm going to do this by talking about uh
everybody's favorite topic or at least
certain people um uh the the Roman
Empire um so hands up who here has
recently thought about the Roman
Empire be honest be
honest okay well you're all thinking
about it now so congratulations um so
um okay I'm actually going to go a bit
further back than R I'm going to talk
about ancient Greece uh I would say that
uh the the concept of like the the the
the the Classical Greece Democratic city
state is the the foundation of our
existing consensus driven societies of
Western democracy um you know it was
very flawed um people used fetishized it
a lot it had its problems but ultimately
it was the first unit social
organization that extended towards an
entire city that we know of where it's
uh you had a concept of um uh consensus
people uh people would decide amongst
themselves collectively what their City
should be doing instead of an autocrat
or an oligarch um uh and here's a
question why didn't it scale why did it
remain as a city state why didn't you
have Greece as a democracy in the
ancient world or or any larger entity
and I use because of communication
complexity that was a world back then
when if you had an idea and you wanted
to share it
uh you don't have a printing press you
know you could write a leaflet but if
you want to distribute that to 100
people you're writing 100 pamphlets and
most people can't read um the way that
you shared ideas was you talked about
them peer-to-peer with individuals and
that was this is a world where
information traveled at the speed of a
horse and generally the information that
traveled along these information
networks roads was the contents of a
human brain uh this is hugely limiting
um and it created a culture and a and
Society where individ ual felt uh very
strong bonds towards the people that
they knew within their cities within
their polities um and so uh any kind of
inter inter city Co coordination
collaboration was always very short-term
because the individuals within those
city states would always favor their
city state over like at the expense of
other city states if they
could
um and so what's the kind of the next
Revolution that enabl something a bit
better than than than a city-state
democracy I would argue it was the
printing press because with the printing
press now your information network uh
the road um its data bandwidth has
massively expanded now because if you
have an idea you can print a book or a
pamplet and you can share it with
thousands of people tens of thousands of
people um you know if this was one of
the foundational liberating moments in
in our society where uh you you could
acquire some kind of consensus around um
shared ideas shared values I would argue
that the concept of a nationhood
nationalism is intrinsically tied up
with the printing press because it
allows for story
to be shared and disseminated uh to
create a culture where you have people
separated by relatively large Geographic
distances that all basically subscribe
to the same myths the same Legends
around who they are and where they've
come from um and so I would call the
printing press and and the associated
mass media that generated around it
newspaper print broadcast print even
radio and television broadcasting it's
all the same thing it's basically a one
to many style communication if I have an
idea I can share it with all of you it's
very hard for of you to share an idea
with me um and I need resources and
influence to be able to to share my idea
I need to be published I need to be
distributed um and
so
uh I would argue that since you
mentioned the printing press um
communication Styles is basically being
this one and many um mode until the rise
of the internet the internet is really
the First Technology we have where we we
we possess a many too many Star
communication any random person can um
share an idea disseminate it and gain
traction with their peers uh and this is
hugely liberating it's also hugely
disruptive in the same way that the
invention of the printing press directly
led to the 30 Years War which um uh in
some parts of Europe uh kill 70% of all
of all human beings uh so good and bad
um and so why am I talking about this uh
because blockchain is the new
information Network that extends part
the internet the internet has a problem
you cannot differentiate signal from
noise everybody has an opinion to share
not only that but now we have uh
algorithms and AI agents pretending to
be humans sharing their opinions and we
don't know what's real and what's not
real what's valuable what's not valuable
blockchain is important because it
allows individuals to coordinate amongst
each other how to pool allocate and
distribute assets
money that can't be faked with an AI
agent um uh you know it's it's a
foundational expression of human agency
um what you spend your resources on and
this is what a blockchain can achieve
this is why in my opinion it's so such a
radical
technology um and I would argue for it
to really fulfill its potential it needs
privacy technology because right now
blockchain
doesn't uh reach particularly into the
real world the cipher Punk visions of
2015 and 20 2018 haven't really come to
fruition I'll talk about a little bit um
so I was going to go on a little bit of
a segue about uh information networks
and cavemen um I'm afraid I I didn't tie
myself very well so I'm going to have to
say this for another time uh it's a good
story though but another time
um why is privacy important why does why
do I why does this new information
Network that allows for the coordination
of assets and need privacy
technology first of all I want to talk
about that what is privacy technology
because privacy extends far beyond um
hiding like how many assets you have or
what you're spending your money on
privacy check is all
about at a low level proving a statement
is true without revealing underlying
information required to derive that
statement for example um having a UK
passport e signature without revealing
the name of the person or the age uh
proving I I've received an email from
from Facebook um without uh leaking um
the contents of that email it's an
privacy is information as symmetry I
know something you do not know you know
something I do not know and information
symmetries are fundamentally important
um in our everyday interactions uh they
are not nefarious they are completely
benign um for example when you vote in
an election uh uh everybody will um uh
like your vote gets counted everybody
like will know in aggregate that your
vot has affected the outcome but nobody
knows how you voted you know how you
voted that's an information asymmetry
they're important um and they are used
to create things like identity
Technologies um proving that I possess a
passport from a certain Nation proving I
possess a bank card from a certain Bank
even something as simple as proving I
have a Twitter account with that's over
three years old with over a thousand
followers that can be used to prove not
prove but like give strong indication
I'm not a bot what this is is trust
infrastructure um Pro technology is not
about trustless it's not about not
having to trust each other it's about
creating Technologies and mechanisms
that allow individuals to more easily
trust each other um by reducing the
surface of what they need to rely
on
so here's a
question here's an elevant of the room
that's been bugging me for seven years
um where's the fundamental value from in
web
3 uh right now all of the value in
blockchain all of the billions of
dollars is sourced from I would argue
only three locations
you have the value that people place on
the consensus of a distributed Network
think of think Bitcoin how much are
people willing to pay to get a a unique
record of
events you have the value in dollar back
stable coins and you have the value in
stories entertainment media basic things
think like um nft art things like that
uh what's missing from that well what's
missing is anything where the value is
derived from from something in the
physical real world we don't have real
world assets on chain we don't have
asset like the ownership of physical
items um or even something as simple as
like intellectual property or or or
anything ephemeral that's derived from a
real world quantity doesn't exist
onchain in any meaningful form right now
and so whilst you know we're all here
because blockchain is a big industry you
know there's there's there's enormous
amount of money in it relative to the
Global Financial system the value of
blockchain is a drop in the ocean and we
cannot become mainstream we cannot make
sure that our technology reaches into
individuals lives in a meaningful way uh
without that I would argue that this is
DP Cipher
Punk uh
because because of what this enables and
how how we're going to do this um
composability is
a foundationally important value
proposition of blockchain uh it is the
value proposition if you exist in a
traditional industry and you want your
organization to become more efficient
the canonical solution is vertical
integration you bring your supply chain
in house you bring your third party
dependes in house so that you have fewer
middleman to pay and you can more more
easily efficiently optimize and refine
for use cases um this gives large
centralized organizations um uh a strong
Competitive Edge over smaller companies
smaller competitors um which I would
argue is is not good um composability in
web 3 inverts this Paradigm because in a
distributed Network like ethereum uh any
piece of software any library that you
deploy any application any dap that you
deploy to the network can be used
permissionless by every other entity in
that Network every node adds value to
every other node um and so what this
means is you can take a uh the the the
the technological stack of of a large
vertically integrated organization and
you can break it apart and make and and
have individual smaller actors providing
each individual service on a blockchain
platform um while still benefiting from
the the efficiencies of of a vertic of
vertical integration um uh composability
is why blockchain has become a big thing
if you had to ask for permission from
the ethereum foundation to deploy a
smart contract ethereum would not exist
if you had to ask permission from the
Unis Foundation to use Unis in your
application like Unis would not exist um
and right now private composability is
something which is badly badly missing
and that's which is required privacy
Tech is starting to become more widely
available um and people are more aware
of it uh things like being able to prove
the existence like prove that you have
received an email from a certain domain
uh without revealing any more
information things like that but all of
these privacy Solutions are very bespoke
if I use a if I write a Dap that
contains um a z email or Z TLS or some
kind of privacy preserving aspect um I'm
not composable anymore not easily
because if another application wants to
use my uh my smart contract my software
they have a lot of Downstream complexity
that they need to incorporate into their
application it's not as simple as just
calling a Unis swap smart contract uh
and without composability blockchain is
nothing without composability Prive
technology is uh is just kind of like
Niche and nice to have that interests
people but with composability it changes
blockchain it changes the world I'll
give some examples that are starting to
emerge today
uh you know I've mentioned ZK email ZK
passport is a brilliant technology that
uh where you can verify um an e passport
digital signature prove that you possess
a passport from a certain Nation without
revealing anything else ZK TLS enables
relatively trustless um attestations
from web two applications you can prove
you've received information from a
website U from a web server um and share
that with other individuals uh and these
are going to form the the foundation of
um uh composability in the future um uh
because these Technologies enable
something which is quite powerful which
I talk about a little bit which is
basically making web 2 composable taking
data fortresses that exist within the
web 2 ecosystem and allowing entities to
siphon data from them permissionless but
before getting on that I want to talk a
bit about decentralization and how
privacy is not only aligned with
decentralization um like the two are
deeply deeply intertwined I'll give some
examples here so if you're building a
Dap it touches the real world or it
touches web2 there's a very good chance
you're going to need some kind of
identity um uh standard uh kind of
proving who you are in some way um who
here is uh excited about adding identity
um standardization
in3 I'm I'm grateful there's more hands
than I thought um this is this is this
is this is the this is foundationally
important if you cannot link a
cryptocurrency account to a real world
identity then your blockchain can't talk
to the real world without a data
custodian in the mix and I want you to
to consider that so let's say I'm doing
I'm doing real world assets on chain and
I'm doing that by having some
centralized data custodian who is
attesting to like the validity of
certain cryptocurrency accounts saying
okay yes you can hold this ass you can
hold this asset if I build a Dap that
utilizes that technology I am not
composable anymore because if if another
third party wants to use my technology
so let's say I'm doing I'm doing an
exchange for rebl assets um and I want
to talk to and I want to like interact
with a smart contract that originates
real world assets well if I need to
integrate with their data custodian uh
what if they say no I need to ask for
permission again I need to have a a
relationship with another entity which
is which is completely unlike what
happens on chain today where everything
is completely permissionless any random
person can just turn up and um like add
some value to the ecosystem data
custodians break composability and you
can only get rid of those data
custodians whilst touching the real
world with strong privacy technology the
zero knowledge cryptography that can
allow for trustless attestations about
what's happening in the real world once
you have that then you can build
decentralized protocols defi type
systems that can still have some kind of
understanding on who you are as an
individual without leaking that
information um you can create
non-custodial
um applications cryptocurrency wallets
that still interact with assets and
value originated in the real world
um and in my opinion that is quite wild
I mean the idea of a non a non-custodial
wallet is radical you know um people
outside of blockchain still struggle to
wrap their heads around that and that's
for wallets that hold what are
ultimately uh largely like synthetic
assets uh like Dogecoin um extending
that to a world where you know you are
interacting peer-to-peer with a smart
contract proving who you are to that
smart contract to an algorithm and
nobody else and then using that to to be
authorized to trade and trans hold real
world assets um that is absolutely
revolutionary and it's going to
happen if not this year next year or
then a year after eventually so
um why is privacy going to make eum
Cipher Punk again uh this concept of a
ZK Transformer is one of the mo is is is
a like one of the most um radical things
you can do with ZK today basically the
whole entirety of web three is based
around these mon ation models of
monetizing your data the social media
networks will have information about who
you are that they control in data
Fortress that they used to monetize and
I just want to just highlight like how
strange this is this is your data your
data about you it should be yours but
it's not it's it's is owned by a company
that's and it's used to Le it's
leveraged at your expense largely um to
generate Revenue uh and the and zero
knowledge cryptography technology can be
used to basically crack open these data
silos because if a third part
application wants for example
information about Facebook uh for
example forcaster wants to import their
user profiles from Facebook well
Facebook's not going to cooporate and
you can't trust the user because they're
going to lie but the user can send you a
zero knowledge proof that they received
uh information from Facebook using Z
email using Z TS things like that uh and
it basically allows for a level of
composability between applications that
do not want to be composable now I wish
I had time for this but I've got 6
seconds so I'll will move to my
conclusions um
uh maybe run over 10 seconds ethereum
will be Cypher bucket G with these
strong privacy preserving Technologies
you add privacy identity standards
private composability into ethereum and
you create an Information Network that
has teeth where individuals can
coordinate and communicate how to
distribute and disseminate their assets
um in in all contexts uh it allows for
um a radical new way of um of of living
um of of organizing one oneself uh that
doesn't exist in the world today it
makes the many to many communication
style created by the internet um uh
understandable and digestible and
composable um humancentric networks that
are governed by human beings instead of
AI agents that where we use our own data
however we down well please without
having to ask for permission from
entities that are accustomed to owning
information like who we are um and we
can distinguish ourselves and what we do
through trustless attestations we can
distinguish our creative work Works our
desires our hopes our fears from uh the
the uh the ocean of um statistically
generated AI generated noise that is
saturating our existing information
networks um so yep uh that's how we're
going to make ethereum cyer again thank
you for
listening Zach thank you so much we have
time for a couple of questions here and
i' like to start with one Legacy go
somewhat tolerate transparent Chains
would they tolerate the private
ones will they it's a very good question
I think the the the solution to this is
is the the um uh to be slightly factious
deliver shareholder value demonstrate
value uh basically you can create
alternative Financial models in web 3 um
uh that use strong privacy technologies
that are just simply better than what we
have at the moment um so Financial
encumbers like the US well it's going to
be a tough sell um for privacy
Technologies but for countries that
aren't the US that still have large
Financial Industries perhaps like the UK
that are looking for comparative
advantage fostering a technology that
allows for much lower barriers to entry
much greater competition more efficiency
is unbelievably attractive there is a
giant pot of money on the table waiting
for a government uh that is willing to
embrace uh not just blockchain
technology but privacy preserving
technology in a big way it'll it'll
it'll turbocharge their
economy another question here doesn't
onchain ID posst censorship risks yes
not going to deny it so imagine if
you're using passport signatures to
validate who you are and well you get
you get dezen well you're you're in
trouble so it's a
spectrum um I think if you have a
universal identity standard that poses
much greater censorship risks than a
holistic identity standard what I would
like to see happen is um like a con who
somebody is is coming from a large
diverse set of sources so not just
things like passport signatures or I I
could prove I possess uh like a UK
government account I used to pay taxes
or I could do things like prove I
possess a bank card Pro prove I have an
email from a utilities provider for a
physical address in the UK prove I have
a Twitter account with a lot of
followers prove I have a LinkedIn
account that's been active for 5 years
basically you build you have all these
little at stations about who you are
that you build up into a concrete mass
that provides overwhelming proof um and
that kind of system is much more sensor
of resistant than than relying on a
single source of
truth how we reconcile the need for
tracing and indexing to provide useful
uiu with the offis cating encryption
required from onchain privacy a very
good question so um we have some
solutions at the moment in Aztec uh so
like how do you um handle shed state
ofation with uiux uh well in atic the
way we handle it is we have this thing
called pixie private execution
environment um runs locally in a user's
device uh that could be queried like a
blockchain node um for information um
longer term this will be a solved
problem through um uh F basically um P
private information retrieval uh you can
basically you can store your data
encrypted on a third party server make
queries about that data get a return to
you um uh and the third party server has
no no understanding of what's happened
um but they can still handle your
request it's a few years out but that's
going to be the
future can you debunk the age of if you
have nothing to R you have nothing to
fear how many people here are
comfortable yelling out their yearly
salary yeah not that many people right
um yeah you have something to hide uh
everybody has something to hide Like We
Are Who what is a human being uh we are
the difference between the mask that we
present to The Outsiders and and our
internal selves full of contradictions
insecurities hopes and dreams and fears
and Petty vanities uh we are all a
miserable pile of secrets um and we need
to embrace
that one last question what are the main
limitations of smart contracts on ZK
chains um you mean privacy preserving
chains what are the limitations uh well
I mean the main one is they barely exist
right now in the real world I mean you
have Alo um that have launched uh ASC
will be launching next year um I would
argue that uh there is there there are
there are some user experience issues
where you know you have to generate
zerge pro client side that can take some
time
um but ultimately uh I would argue that
um uh it's a uh like
foundationally I don't think there will
be any user issues I think like the
technology will lag lag behind the
transparent world but eventually it'll
it'll it's it's always going to be pain
catch up but you can expect the same end
end status as the transparent chain when
it comes to
uiux Zach thank you so much thank you
thank you
thanks everyone for
joining we'll be back in a few minutes
with Robert Rost from the aan foundation
to talk about a Manifesto on
coordination ECC we'll be back in a
couple of minutes you'll have time to
grab a coffee to run to another session
we just stay here for the next session
thanks
everyone e
[Music]
for
e e
[Music]
and we are back
it's been
crazy motivating and beautiful past two
days here at Devcon I don't know about
you folks but every time I'm walking or
sometimes running from one stage to
another I can't help you know meeting
new friends old friends and almost cry a
little bit with the intensity and how
beautiful this conference has been don't
know if it's it's your first your second
your third maybe like your fifth Devon
but the energy it gets better and better
every year and I'm so glad to be here
sharing with you all this energy and for
this talk like I said you folks probably
know my brain and my work it's a bit
more known technical so I'm very very
excited for this talk as a person who
work in communities at.org I'm very very
excited to hear from Bert from the aan
foundation on a Manifesto on
coordination ACCC so everyone please
give a warm welcome to
Robert hi there I am Robert um and I uh
work at igen
Foundation um just uh let's see
everybody okay looks like everybody
settled in so let me get right started
so there's three ideas that I want to go
over in this talk um two of them are
just giving some background which are
pretty important for open technology I
think a lot of times when we're sort of
seeing the evolution of things it feels
like it's a glacial Pace but the glacier
does eventually grind down mountains and
the grinding of mountains I want to look
at the patterns that we see from that
and especially because the latest and
greatest uh version of open Technologies
has been crypto and uh I think what i'
i' like to form in this talk is the kind
of underpinning of what kind of openness
results and what we can expect to see in
another 5 or 10 years uh based on these
two together so um giving the background
on open um I thought a good way to do
this would be to just kind of show
people how much has been accomplished
for going from proprietary to open
Technologies uh the top one there
networking um this is kind of predating
all of us but there is like 20 years or
so of proprieter networks if you could
believe it there were like 25 different
networking standards and it's shocking
now to just hear but like tcpip was
completely the Renegade kit on the Block
when it came out everybody thought it
was such a crappy protocol all these
other protocols were so fine tuned they
did all these specialized things and it
all went away I mean this is the same
era where you know you had proprietary
uh uh uh character formats ASI was
created to kind of get away from that
and so forth and uh so that was sort of
one of the biggest uh first moves into
um uh openness we had a couple other
that uh a bunch of us have experienced
maybe not the internet but the mobile
phone Revolution where we basically got
the entire internet carrying with us all
the time not value necessarily but at
least the information sharing and
information
downloading um and probably one of the
biggest ones that I would say in general
for all of us open source I mean open
source literally was called by Bill
Gates a cancer
um that destroyed value for everybody in
the industry and Hardware public clouds
I'm going to actually say a few things
about those in a second post blockchain
um I put approximate tipping D points
down on the top um before last week I
actually still had Bitcoin and question
marks but now I'm tentatively saying
2025 may actually be the Tipping Point
Tipping Point means when it's so
prevalent that it's just all over the
world you know like the mobile phone
going from before to after it's an
entirely different transition we haven't
had that yet but maybe next year in
Bitcoin the rest of them uh you know
going to defi eth money crypto Keys
identity um wal Garden data and public
clouds we haven't hit the Tipping Point
on those that's some of the most
exciting parts that we can expect coming
with that transition to open tech
meeting uh crypto and crypto settlement
so um let me just jump through a couple
here so hardware and software tech
meeting the cloud this is a really
important one how many people in the
room are Dev V
opers okay a lot of us and we all
develop on the cloud but it is really
interesting to see that you know for
about 30 years in Computing it was all
so proprietary everything on the left
side you had to buy you had to manage it
had all sorts of different standards you
were doing different apis for everything
all the time and over time people
figured out that there's a much better
model uh virtualization other software
allowed you to abstract and you had
infrastructure as a service uh platform
as a service and then software as a
service Serv and progressively they
unlocked some of the greatest software
innovations that we've ever seen um open
one in the end um however winning on one
level doesn't you mean you win on all
levels so the cloud itself was open but
the cloud platforms quickly became
pretty centralized with the top three
controlling like 70 80% of the whole
Market result of that which has been um
an interesting problem as a side effect
that I think blockchain is going to help
us solve a lot is that before clouds
open source had this great model where
you built open source and then you made
a product based on it and you actually
got the value from it um in the web to
public Cloud that stopped happening
because now what would happen is that
your open source software because it's
open would be used by Cloud vendors and
so if you look at a chart like this
where Google cloud has all of this SAS
and platform as a service and so forth
they're just wrapping somebody else's
work and putting it out there so not
fair in my opinion um but the crypto
Cloud this is one of the most exciting
parts that we're all going to experience
we've seen it already blockchain you
write open source software token a
protocol and the team that built it is
making money again hasn't extended down
to the public Cloud yet deepin and other
things are bringing in that direction
the beautiful part with that and I'll
talk about it in terms of like how
settlement is uh going to really enable
this this means now that we don't have a
central Cloud pler anymore we have a
whole bunch of different infrastructure
uh providers tens are hundreds or what
have you and so none of them are going
to go ahead and actually dominate the
field in the way that you saw with the
big public Cloud vendors so open will
win um okay and then one last point I
wanted to just say on those is that
sometimes when I say this slide
afterwards people come to me and they
say but this doesn't quite make sense
web2 public clouds are quite
decentralized but as we saw with the
internet the internet launched in the
mid 90s by mid 2000s this open
technology Reading Writing data became
entirely owned by a couple of big social
networks advertising networks and so
forth so you took a decentralized
technology and owned it and in the cloud
case the Billing System the
accessibility to put in your hardware
and most importantly having the rights
to get the revenue from all of that was
centralized um and so the unlock or the
openness in this case is being able to
participate in the value generation and
the value revenue and uh that's a big
theme obviously with crypto and
extending into a technology like public
clouds is quite
valuable so um okay that's sort of a
background intro I have one slide where
I just like to go through the why of
open Tech because it's not always
obvious like when you look at open
Innovation um it it looks immediately
like maybe open Innovation doesn't win
shortterm closed systems can scale
really fast people are able to develop
on them there's less coordination
friction they're able to take the
revenue reinvest it really quickly but
the reason this causes a problem is
eventually the closed systems when they
start winning a market they slow down
they don't have a big motivation to uh
innovate the way they did they're just
protecting their Monopoly longer term
open Innovation moves ahead uh bringing
in a lot more people to it we've seen
that all over the blockchain space we
all use each other's protocols we
literally compo compose applications out
of each other's daps at this point and
the feature velocity increases over time
because as you kind of settle ethereum
is settling its uh aify its its layer
and it's kind of like uh um accreting
itself to something solid and then
people will build more and they'll build
more and so forth and the last one which
I think has been a really dominant one
is you know how many times do you find
out there's actually no diversity in the
thinking the values the knowledge I mean
it's kind of nuts when you think about a
big Network like Facebook being you know
really not localized and instead having
this one projection of sort of values
and one projection of the system all
around the world um that doesn't really
seem like what you would expect uh would
be a good way for humans to
interact okay so now let's get okay and
it's Unstoppable for us I just like to
say I use that phrase tipping points
before and the Tipping Point's really
important for a long time it's like the
Buddha story if you have a read that is
very inflexible it seems hard and then
it snaps and it breaks whereas the one
that actually is soft and pliable is
able to you know Bend with time so the
fragile short-term ones um those
eventually do snap as we get the entire
um uh you know weight of the advantages
of open
Innovation so um now talking about
crypto one thing that I've kind of
reframed recently that I think is a
pretty good framework um I don't know
how many people here have heard of you
know money crypto Tech crypto that
Division I kind of reframed it in two
and it sort of exposed that there was a
third one that's really helpful to put
together is like the three classes that
we have um for settlement in crypto the
one that started it all of course was
Financial settlement getting the read
write own now you can actually own
digital assets and ethereum expanded it
greatly to programmable money with uh
all of those dii protocols and Tech
settlement there's a few different cases
with tech settlement where um uh you
have sort of more limited and we're
going towards more open and generalized
Tech settlement and then finally I don't
know if uh a ton of people think about
it uh all the time but there's this meta
settlement concept which probably is the
most important and underpinning one I
want to say a few words at the end about
just how substantial that is in terms of
making sure we don't end up having what
happened with clouds or other things
where you've got open Technologies and
at the very top you have somebody that
kind of monetizes and closes a wrapper
around the whole
thing so um here's a slide forgive me
this one has a couple of uh labeling
from uh the company that I work at but
it's a general principle the top side of
the um the top side of the uh picture is
showing us the ethereum trust Network um
uh and then the bottom side is a new
branch of peer-to-peer networks that are
enabled uh with reaking protocols uh the
top one just to level set for us you
know when you think of ethereum the
reason it works is it has two portions
it has a consensus portion and it has a
a execution virtual machine or smart
contract portion and it's split up that
way because the consensus machine is
something that is an entire Bunch across
the internet of software nodes and they
talk to each other at full tcpi tcpip
speeds they're sending commitments
they're sending data blocks they're
sending transactions all of that stuff
and so that is a distributed software
application the evm is now somebody
using that distributed software
application that manifests in evm to
write something that gives them exact
execution of a smart contract so very
valuable switching and so that means
daps that are based on that they're very
flexible but they basically are inside
of the realm of a smart contract system
evm execution they don't have access to
directly being able to program the
consensus itself so the sort of unlock
that we've gone to now let me actually
jump to the next slide maybe easier to
see um is that you know we've kind of
gone
um I'll do it from here so we've gone
from things like Bitcoin which were very
monolith applications where all the way
from the security of proof of work to
the consensus of Nakamoto consensus to
the execution of utxos to the
application of sending money around the
world those were all one case uh one use
case and then obviously vitalic and the
team at ethereum invented that you could
generalize that so now you would be able
to have an app appliation rather than
just sending money back and forth and
that enabled us to now have flexibility
at the application layer the next big
innovation from uh I guess around four
years back at this point was the rollup
era and recognizing that the execution
VMS themselves could be generalized so
now you had the ability that you have
different rollups building them on
ethereum it's been great we just heard
Justin talking um about the beam chain
upgrade and that's all going to sit in
the context of the current execution
layer
this final Innovation here um what I
think is the big significant one is that
we're opening up the layer of
peer-to-peer um Technologies so that you
now have the ability in your
applications to have whatever kind of
distributed software it's as if you're
actually able to put in something that
is at the same level as the beacon chain
except it's running your application so
you know you think about uh storage
content delivery networks you can think
about databases other things that need
very high performance but they still
want to be settled with the open uh
settlement uh they want to settle their
technology onto
blockchains okay so um and this allows
importantly now that there's a framework
that you know similar to like evm nodes
being run by people on uh ethereum uh
this allows operators to now look at
this model of consensus as another thing
for them to run so they sign up they
bring CPU GPU uh trusted execution
environments they can have varying node
requirements maybe as low as ethereum
maybe 10x higher than salana um because
now we freed up the peerto peer
protocols could be to be anything they
have all sorts of different assumptions
and this then allows different operator
groups to perform different subset of
tasks and we take all of the people that
are operating right now a pretty limited
set that they can run and they're now
able to essentially run everything
that's on the decentralized public Cloud
which are in fact blockchain protocols
so it's a huge unlock this sort of open
tech meeting crypto means that
essentially all software that we run for
all purposes uh can move over to
blockchain it doesn't have to just be
fixed to the kind of execution virtual
machine layer but it can go down all the
way to the uh Hardware layer of uh uh
you know as general software protocols
as you can create
um and just give a feeling if you look
at these types of things these are
things that you would not expect to see
smart contracts as a settlement platform
for there's a lot of stuff that goes
into like proof of location proof of
Machin Hood all sorts of pinging all
sorts of latencies um running Linux
running ZK provs a lot of offchain
compute and all of these are actually
being built now which I think is really
exciting if you look at it um you know
we're sort of at the level at this point
where there's hundreds of new blockchain
protocols that are being built making
their own peer-to-peer Network and not
having to like filecoin create a whole
new layer one network they're able to
create these things as kind of layer 2
networks on ethereum mixing together
peer-to-peer networks plus evm execution
as
well um oh and then I'm sorry here's the
slide where I said the hundreds in Dev
um so yeah so quite quite a few of these
and um yeah the meta settlement this is
the final point that I wanted to make
here because I think a lot of the points
there they paint a really good story um
I think we can be excited about open
technology having won every major um
technology battle in the end sometimes
taking like in networking case more than
two decades but it goes the right way
happily blockchain accelerates those
things um and um you know those are all
great but at the very end there's this
question of like who owns it at the
higher levels you know we we kind of
know this idea of like Network capture
is such a problem um because it's very
hard to get out from the friction of a
system that has kind of captured your
data your identity and so forth so
um so two two ideas that I just want to
present on that um and then I'll get to
the final conclusion about the metal
settle meta settlement one is that you
know we have existing in kind of normal
mode of blockchains a lot of things that
are on chain observable faults this has
really been solved by blockchain
including ZK proofs and so forth that
you don't have to worry about it if
somebody can give a proof that anyone
non-interactively would be able to read
see that the proof checks see that
somebody committed something incorrectly
or somebody performed some action
correctly you can reward them or slash
them whatever is appropriate the
challenging part of these inter
subjective beliefs and these are sort of
human observable thoughts um not sure
how many people have dug into them but
things like data availability you can
never prove that somebody didn't show
you something CU while you're claiming
they didn't show you something they can
show it and then it's uh he said they
said of did the person really not show
it or did the person actually uh you
know ordered the person um uh actually
show it after the uh threshold
prediction markets obviously any Oracle
I mean there's nothing on chain that
would tell you on chain link that
Bitcoin is less than $10 if it published
that that defi would break and there's
nothing on chain that would sort of
detect that that's happening and you
know these kind of examples go on in the
blockchain space and I put at the bottom
one this idea about promises which are
General credible commitments those are
really exciting because you think about
it you know what is a promise if it's
between me and this gentleman over here
you know I can tell them hey you know
I'm going to make sure that uh you know
any time you need when you call me I'm
going to come with the car and get you
right and so I made this promise um it's
one to one so it's not going to be inter
subjective but it's something that's
happening in the real world inter
subjective would be like I'm creating an
Uber alternative and I'm saying Uber's
take rate of 60% is horrible I'm going
to go ahead and my take rate is only
going to be 5% um and that's great I
could write an IM immutable contract but
now I'd have a lot of problems with that
because can you really write a big
software application without ever
changing it if you can change it which
invariably pretty much all of crypto can
right now most of the systems I mean
they just have to have upgradeability
somewhere um then that 5% is no longer
true but if you have the ability to
check for human observable faults and
then translate that information on chain
then that actually takes care of that
problem because as Society we can go
ahead and say hey this person violated
this or let's say Facebook says new
version of Facebook someone competing
says we're only going to change the
privacy policy if the community agrees
like a dow 51% % that we're going to
approve a new um privacy policy if they
violate that then the users can say Hey
you know you're sending me a Ula I'm
supposed to either sign it or get the
hell out of the application you broke
that promise so what actually um allows
us to do that well in l1's this is
probably the most core feature that
without this it's really not blockchain
which is that you have viable slashing
by Chain forking meaning that you can
take the existing system you've got your
data you've got your identity
and you can just Fork it and create a
new version we've seen that many times
in l1s it's a very unique feature and
one of the problems that we've had is we
build a lot of things on something like
ethereum they're all l2s and vitalic is
really clear that forking l1s because of
L2 Faults Are an issue so um one of the
more recent breakthroughs that I'm not
sure uh everyone's heard about so it's
this idea of slashing by CH token
forking and this is the idea that you're
able offchain to make um agreements and
then project onchain that something was
violated when it was violated the actual
value of tokens in defi in Unis swap in
compound a everywhere automatically gets
shifted to the new chain and effectively
slashes the people who uh violated that
offchain promise and importantly it's a
lot more fundamental than onchain voting
onchain voting still ultimately is
following a mathematical protocol so um
and this one is and not able to do the
token forking um and this one allows us
to do that so the final comment I would
here say is that like we really don't
have the openness we want in general we
never would have it um before crypto in
this meta settlement um once Tech
platforms capture the network effects
they become opin autocracies you either
use it as is or you just leave and the
forkable tech platforms this is the
final frontier of open Technologies
enabled by blockchain and that's where
we're going to get to uh Global Internet
native self- enforcing coordination all
right thank
you Robert thank you so much for your
presentation for everyone that's here
you still have a bit more time to ask
questions through this QR code but I do
have one question for you from all this
presentation which things uh we could
expect that would change or become
Concrete in one year 3 years or five
years so how do you see maybe like in
one year from now we coming to Devcon or
devc connect again and repeating this
presentation or I think the one of the
most promising places for all of this to
show in the next year or two and in my
mind it's kind of like a call to action
for all of us is that um big moves like
two blockchain they definitely are
helped by things like defi but the most
fundamental changing uh technology for
humans since maybe fire is AI um we
finally actually built the ability for
us to have elastic scalable intelligence
and in web 2 AI is a disaster I mean it
actually takes everything that's wrong
and makes it even more captured even
more
localized but so this AI side is
actually screaming for what I'm talking
about here if you have open technology
if you have non-captured clouds if you
have us creating the hundreds of
protocols that AI is able to use um
where there's not a corporation owning
it but it's owned by tokens in digital
sense and rules can be made we have much
higher chance of being able to create uh
AI that actually has the right kind of
rules to be positive for Humanity in the
end people are like oh AI is going to
cause this big problem but it's actually
humans you know evil humans using AI
that are going to be the problem so we
get a chance to get them out of there
I'm pretty optimistic but I'm an
optimistic guy I think we're already
going to see major uh AI crypto
advancements already around agents in
the coming year and in two three years I
think that um you know if we flipped it
I think it's possible we could already
be thinking about a Tipping Point for
web 3 AI um plus crypto we're so looking
forward for the future I have one
question here how does inter subjective
thoughts interact with politics and
regulation in post Garing War era oh I'm
going to sound really stupid now because
someone needs to tell me what is Gary
Warren you can Shout It Out whoever put
the question
up oh Gary Gensler oh Warren
Buffett Elizabeth Warren okay my mind's
over there um wait what happened the
question went away now I forgot the
question oh how does inter subjective
forking work in that um so let's see I
think it's a extremely strong marker to
say that the system is
decentralized which always has come to
be the most important part of crypto
which is essentially establishing with
countries that they don't have
jurisdiction or ownership because it's a
global technology so my expectation is
that it should be you know quite
positive force I also don't really know
how relevant either of those two are
going to be in the next four years but
they're still going to be around
somewhere in the
Zeitgeist can you give a rearward
example of an
a yeah so uh a real world example of an
AVS
would be um something that's looking for
uh the opposite of the touring test so
proof of Machin Hood um there's a chain
called witness chain that's doing that
also proof of location it's great that
we have you know kind of machines we
think we're decentralized but if our
decentralized machines are all sitting
in the US and Europe um it's not as
decentralized we would like to be able
to have people uh participating all over
the world especially like southeast Asia
and Africa and South America
um but if we don't have a good way to
prove that then we're going to have
proof of you know we're going to have
the Cil attacks we would have in any
case and so um that's a kind of protocol
you can't do in a smart contract level
it requires really intricate hard to
beat very expensive to beat type of uh
work going on at a network level and so
that's a great example where completely
unique P2P um no technology is needed um
I think another one when you say real
world it's not there yet but it's uh
definitely going to be something we need
which is you know having great data
storage helps but more important than
that is having something completely
competitive to Cloud flare and
cloudfront and so forth so having really
strong you know data will be published
not just data availability in in the
sense of sorry first being published
data will be readable later on so
content delivery networks ensure that
you're going to be able to do that over
time and so we need that uh in com ation
with uh Secure Storage layers and uh
that's not something you can coordinate
um in theory you can and people would
probably without this ABS model build it
as new l1s but the idea of taking all of
that technology and having its security
and having its settlement happen on
ethereum is probably one of the most
exciting uh aspects of what we can do on
ethereum is to collapse more and more of
the tech settlement and uh value and
this uh these other components in Robert
thank you so much we are of the time we
still have a couple of questions here
but we won't be able to cover it but
once again thank you so much everyone
give a round of applause for Robert
thank
you well time flies the music comes in
and it's time for have lunch so we will
be back at 100 p.m. with a panel on
ethereal values and Alignment looking
forward to seeing you all here but for
now take a break go chill go have lunch
and see you all at 1 p.m. thank you so
[Music]
much e
true
[Music]
m
n
[Music]
h now
for
[Music]
I
n
[Music]
oh
for e
[Music]
for
oh
[Music]
for
for I
[Music]
I
h
[Music]
a
on
[Music]
oh
d
[Music]
you
for
[Music]
h
for
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
m
e
[Music]
e for
y
[Music]
a
for
[Music]
is
for
[Music]
a
[Applause]
[Music]
o
bu
[Music]
t
up a
that
is
[Music]
e
m
[Music]
oh e
e
[Music]
for
hi everyone good
afternoon welcome or welcome back to the
main stage of Dev con southeast Asia if
you already don't know me my name is
Isabella and I'll will be your host
during this afternoon and for the next
session
a very interesting question that's going
to float around this next session if you
could describe etheron in one sentence
what would be I'm sure here everyone
would have their own definitions and the
five panelists that will join this
session probably they will have a much
longer definition so that's why they
will need a couple of minutes to
dissertate around that so I'm very very
glad to wel welcome Ahmed Mark nixo
Peter and Phil we who are going to talk
about Ean values and e2's Alignment from
perm to now welcome folks
[Music]
test test okay we're
good all right hey everyone uh my name
is Phil no I'm the project manager of
the ethereum consensus client written in
typescript called loadstar I work at
chains saafe and here we have a bunch of
probably familiar faces in the community
here um and thank you for coming to
today's session ethereum's uh values and
Ethos alignment so I'll give um
everybody an opportunity just to
introduce themselves and just tell us a
little bit about what you're working on
and like what got you interested in
ethereum so we'll just go in order I
guess yeah okay Hey so uh my name is
Peter I've been on the go ethereum team
for almost 10 years now so I'm one of
the Boomers in this uh
ecosystem and um I guess just to answer
the question what got me interested in
this whole thing it was mostly
decentralized autonomous self-organizing
systems so I was always fascinated about
having computer systems that just self
assemble and do something without too
much
intervention my name is nixo I came to
ethereum like I came to working
full-time in ethereum through staking I
was a Staker um I'm now transitioning to
working at the ethereum foundation um
but the thing that brought me uh in love
with ethereum was the self- sovereignty
and that was like very clear when I
onboarded as a Staker that um ethereum
very much espoused a self- sovereign
identity hey my name is Mark and I'm a
contributor to the optimism
Collective we're focused on scaling
ethereum through layer twos building
free software
um the reason why I became interested in
ethereum is because I really became
disillusioned with the world I was
pretty frustrated with you know a lot of
Institutions that I thought were kind of
falling behind they're still built on
fax machines I was kind of like hey
civilization we should be able to do
better than this and I started learning
about Bitcoin and kind of got into the
sound money idea because I was worried
about how much debt there was in the
world and then I saw the Dow and I was
like oh wow this is really cool like
ethereum could be like a platform for
these institutions of the future and
then I fell down the rabbit hole and I
couldn't stop thinking about ethereum
and just wanted to build and you know
scale it to the
world yep my name is Ahmed barar I work
on the nethermind execution client um so
3 years around three years ago I
probably started looking into
cryptocurrency in general and I started
doing my own research and then um the
more I dove deep the more I was pilled
by ethereum um about Financial Freedom
about censorship resistance and then um
the the the the the way I became a cev
was I got inspired by Peter because I
kept seeing him tweeting on Twitter and
this made me think oh being a cev must
be like the Pinnacle of of like
technical knowledge in in this space and
yeah this is this is why I'm here now so
thank you
Peter all right sounds like we already
have a little bit of alignment
already that's a good start but now to
the hard
questions um this
is let's really see here like what
people say we don't know each other's
answers we didn't like rehearse this
beforehand but if you were to describe
ethereum in a sentence how would you how
would you describe
it anyone
first ethereum is incredibly neutral new
Financial
Paradigm so when I was thinking about
this I was trying to come up with like a
catchphrase like something really really
simple so I've got three of
them one is unbank the banked you know
this is like a classic one people don't
really say this one anymore but it was
really popular maybe like I don't know
three or four years ago um another one
is you know know your
counterparty right like I think um
there's this idea of hardness Josh Stark
I believe at the ethereum foundation is
talking about this I think that this is
a really important property of ethereum
where you know you kind of have this
property of when you're interacting with
someone on the blockchain you know the
way that they're going to respond so
this um Assurance is really really
important and it der risks certain types
of interactions and I think that's like
a huge value proposition of
ethereum and then the last one is shine
light on power
structures so you know today there's a
lot of Walled Gardens in the world and
it's really opaque the way that the
decision making for these walled Gardens
works so a huge value prop to me about
ethereum is that the power structures
can be legible onchain and I think that
we should strive to move more and more
power structures on chain so that the
users can see the power structures and
opt into the power structures that they
want to so that we don't just have these
opaque walled Gardens that people have
no say in that was longer than a
[Laughter]
sentence I'll allow
it yeah I would say
uncompromising censorship resistant
permissionless and decentralized World
computer focus on
uncompromising I think for me the most
important thing would be flat
decentralized power structures in short
what do you mean by
flat by flat I mean I would like not to
have power structures at all I would
like like to not see hierarchical Power
structures is no one going to say like
code is law
maybe
no we all know what happened
there okay well you know that's some you
know good uh interesting uh perspectives
on theing I feel like we still have you
know some alignment here on like you
know what we're trying to build ethereum
for um I feel like a lot of the times
what makes ethereum different and what
makes us very special is because of some
of the values that a lot of the
contributors whether it be core
contributors or adap developers or
infrastructure Builders um the reason
why we're here is because we do have
some alignment on what we're trying to
build here and the properties of what
this stack needs to be viable to the
true vision of why we're here which I
would assume is the web three values
decentralization accountability trans um
transparency and
such but if I were to ask you what is
like an uh one property or the most
important or existential threat
um to ethereum if this value
disappeared what value would that be
what would make you rage quit and exit
the ecosystem because we've lost that
property I think when you like talk
about some of these properties you end
up like tangentially kind of talking
about the other ones and so I'm going to
say credible neutrality but that like
that also refers to decentralization and
censorship resistance and without those
things incredible neutrality is those
things like you were talking about flat
power structures and if my my problem
with the traditional Financial structure
our our traditional economic system
really is that some people have uh
incumbent power that other people the
people who are newer to the um system
can't grab at and I think that if we
don't maintain credible
neutrality ethereum could be more
dystopian than the system that we're in
currently like if some can control
ethereum if somebody has outsized
influence in
ethereum the um ability to track uh
people's Financial transactions in the
way that ethereum allows could make
ethereum more distopian than our current
system I think that's a really good
point about how if ethereum is captured
whether it's its governance or just like
the validator set um it could be more
dystopian um just due to the lack of
privacy being built into the base layer
so yeah I would definitely want to rage
quit if old money overtook ethereum's
governance old money or uh new power
structures that are crypto native and
taking over the system either one that's
a very good Point there's definitely
some of those that we have to worry
about
too I think for me uh I would say that
the most important value is equal access
or equal opportunity of access so
essentially what I would like to see is
on all the different layers of ethereum
whether it's L1 L2 platform dep layer
whatever that anybody who figures that
they would like to do something on it
they just can without um somebody being
able to either prioritize or
deprioritize them and um maybe we can go
into that a bit later but in
short um yeah so when you look at all
the properties that are mentioned in in
this uh panel uh I feel like always it
comes back to decentralization because
if we lose decentralization we can't
guarantee censorship resistance we can't
guarantee permissionless access
we can't be even if for example uh
people working on ethereum stop being
credibly natural um the decentralization
of ethereum could render them out of the
protocol if they wish to if the protocol
is actually decentralized but
decentralization is a very broad word
because you have decentralization
geographically you have decentralization
and the number of validators solo
stakers infrastructure so like
decentralization needs to be applied on
all aspects not a single one of
them I would definitely like to
challenge the community into trying to
use the word decentralization less so
that we can hone in on more in on the
specific thing that needs to be
decentralized because when someone says
XYZ is
centralized it doesn't really convey
much information we should be talking
about the very specific things that are
centralized because systems are made up
of many parts and really a system is
only as decentralized as its least
decentralized component so it's not
really useful if you're just saying XYZ
that's centralized we need to be more
specific so that we can share mental
models and not just argue past each
other in a religious way
is there something that you're thinking
of that would potentially have a reason
to be centralized that more effective um
if it was more centralized like is is
there something that you're thinking of
oh yeah there's I mean every time that
you decentralize something it's a cost
and you need to make sure that the cost
of that
decentralization is worth the benefit
right so literally decentralizing every
single thing in the world civilization
would probably fall apart so I think
sometimes um it's good to have decision
making that's
centralized um other times it is better
to to like design by committee it kind
of depends on what you're optimizing for
and like the type of decision that's
being
made um that's one I mean you know I
don't want to get into a whole debate
about single sequencers versus base
rollups because that's like another one
did what so the question wise are you
also interested in what would break
ethereum in my opinion and what are the
problems there or should we get there a
bit
later uh we we can we can talk about
that now so I guess um one very
interesting thing is
um that
um so what are the the values most
important values and what we could lose
I think one of the things that um uh
that could pose the biggest threat to
these values is uh and I'm guessing this
is going on coindesk is
democracy which is a kind of a steep
thing to say and uh what I'm trying to
get at is I think uh in any democratic
system basically it's a popularity
contest where you have a very big push
from the biggest group of the majority
which in general is probably nice for
the overall system but it might not be
nice for individual parts so I think
it's a one very important value that I
would like to highlight is that I think
it's important to have these Democratic
Values not just top down rather at at
all the levels of the system so that
it's not like U the problem is that if
you just go top down then we can turn
ethereum into this super nice Financial
chain because that's what probably
impact the most people but I'm not sure
that that's the best overall direction
for the
network yeah and uh also like what Mark
mentioned there are obviously trade-offs
we're all probably familiar with things
like the blockchain trilemma where you
uh can only have two or three properties
um and a lot of the times we have to
have these debates about like where does
ethereum sort of prioritize its its
values because it's not easy to
necessarily give up some
decentralization for more
scalability so like going into like the
future of ethereum especially when
you're thinking about the endgame of
ethereum we have choices that we have to
make and I'm curious like what is more
important to you um so there is this um
sort of argument about whether chain
performance is more important than the
distribution of power when you are
trying to get maximum scalability out of
something the natural thing to do is to
centralize things but perhaps AUM is
maybe better than other blockchains at
trying to balance this so I'm kind of
curious like is chain performance or
distribution of power um more important
or are they
balanced I think that's probably
something we'd all agree on that
primarily we would like to see
distribution of power at least me
personally I would gladly sacrifice any
performance for it because usually if
you give the power out it it's not
coming back so the it's basically
one-way Street and I think that's why
it's all these discussions around
decentralization versus making certain
aspects faster is
problematic because it once you made it
fast it's very hard to undo it it's very
hard to argue that well we don't want a
fast thing so I think it's that's why I
would probably always choose
decentralization we're building a really
cool piece of technology um and it's
trying to address like an age-old
problem which is centralization in our
economic system um and we're what we're
the conclusions that we're kind of
coming to or the problems that we're
running into is that as we solve
centralization issues we kind of find
that we just push those centralization
issues further and further down the
stack um and so people start complaining
because they're already using the system
and they're like let's just stop there
let's be okay with that level of
centralization but the thing is without
without
decentralization this whole thing is
pointless and we should just move back
to centralized systems um and so there's
no there's no point to ethereum if it's
centralized and we shouldn't give up on
the idea of decentralization just
because we keep encountering these
problems because this is an age-old
problem that is really really difficult
to solve and it's not like we're going
to build something in 10 years that just
is perfect and solves issues that people
have been dealing with for centuries was
that the subtext for beam
chain
I definitely distribution of power is
more important than
scalability I think there's some
problems with just going on for sheer
scalability because you don't really
know when you've gone too far and have
allowed the system to become
capturable so if we just keep you know
increasing Hardware requirements and
increasing Hardware requirements we will
pass the Threshold at some point without
realizing it and an adversary will be
ready to strike and they will strike and
we won't be ready to react and they can
capture the network so we always have to
be very mindful of this sort of
attack I do think that as a community we
have the opportunity to push the
boundaries of science and engineering
and solve really hard problems to make
sure that the power structure stay
distributed while scaling there's some
really cool opportuni ities with say new
signature aggregation schemes that you
know the researchers can like basically
research and kind of invent and we have
the opportunity to bring these to
production for the first time and really
you know develop Cutting Edge systems
that weren't possible before and this is
why I want to contribute to ethereum I
want to be part of
this well like a already said um I think
what the C devs and researchers are
working towards is always keeping the
distribution of power while maximizing
as much as possible what can be done uh
without
compromising um the problem is there is
some voices in the industry that are
pushing to compromise but I think that
we as a community as a whole uh are
pushing against that in a very well
Manner and and yeah it it's it's going
well the value of ethereum will go down
if we start
compromising uh just to give one
specific example and I apologize in
advance for picking on the project is uh
for example uh Lio if you have let's you
are stake or whether it's decentralized
centralized company project doesn't
matter and it's big enough then it can
be a very very um good uh Network player
or ecosystem player so it doesn't they
don't have to be at all malicious no
single bad intent yet still every time
when there's a protocol update being
discussed a research Direction you
always have to keep in mind that you
have that single big player and they
probably won't but may want to have a
say in it and and these are those
structures which once they evolve it's
kind of hard to get rid of
and it's very very hard to tell whether
something is malicious not malicious
maybe just doing the best for the
investors it's it gets
murky yeah that's uh definitely
something to to think about and a lot of
the times when we're developing these
systems it's really hard to simulate all
the potential side effects all the
second third degree effects that come
from protocol upgrades as an example
like we've learned learned a lot um from
the development of the beacon chain and
learning more about me as you probably
all saw like there was a presentation
about the beam chain which aims to fix
some of these things that we've learned
with the beacon chain um but yeah it's
it's also Mark it's really interesting
to hear from you as well as a consumer
of things like blobs um you know there
is a lot of debate happening about
whether or not we need to increase the
blob Target Max sizes as well so that we
can better support systems like yours
and other l2s but that comes at a cost
of potentially some Raspberry Pi Staker
um which I'm sure nisso is advocating
for as well no no no I don't believe
that we should optimize for raspberry
piie stakers I think that they're very
cool hobbyists and I love what they're
doing but like the meme on Twitter is
like everybody saying like oh we need to
let people steak on a potato in the in
that in the Atlantic but I think there
are there it makes sense to have minimum
Hardware requirements that like
approximately equal what you would make
in like maybe six months in rewards okay
well what about the people who may have
difficulty getting access to consistent
or even excess upload bandwidth like how
how do you deal with something like that
like are we forgetting about these
people
I guess it's the problem is that once
you start looking at like at it at
bandwidth and things like that
unfortunately the world is not really
equally distributed
so I think it's very very important to
make the system as distributed as
possible but there's always this
trade-off that you also mentioned that
if you try to aim to make the validators
run on a smartwatch that's very nice but
is there a value of having 7 billion
validators probably not on the other
hand if you do have 7 billion validators
that kind of really really constrains
the other side of the equation of who
stores the state and you kind of give
rise to these much more centralized
operators so ideally you want to
maximize
decentralization but not at the cost of
centralizing something
else
basically I am excited to see a lot more
conversation about um
about making sure that we have client
devs in different locations though
because I think there's a big blind spot
when it comes to bandwidth because a lot
of the world struggles with bandwidth
and I'm not even talking about like like
developing countries I'm talking about
like little towns in highly developed
Nations like Berlin like Berlin yes
promote Germany I've
heard and so I think that like
increasing the number of developers that
we have in regions like that or in in
like um South America Africa Asia um is
really important because client devs run
super optimized versions of their
clients on great Hardware or like in the
cloud and they don't necessarily know
what the situation is for like home
stakers at some point I think that we
should as we hit these bottlenecks with
bandwidth we should you know dream
bigger and think about improving the
infrastructure itself for the entire
internet because if the bandwidth is
going to be the bottleneck it's going to
be really difficult to solve that at the
software level once we get to a certain
point right now there's a lot more
optimizations that we can make but why
can't we go out and do physical things
too I think that could be a really
promising path forward oo an ethereum
starlink Network that sounds awesome yes
yes let's take down the ISP
oligopolies yeah exactly exactly these
are the sorts of things that make me
really excited about being in the
ethereum community for the next decade
plus um I think we already have some
solutions to the bandwidth problems and
I think that um probably scaling the
blobs before these Solutions are
implemented would be detrimental to home
stakers and Solo stakers in a lot of
places um but the solutions are out
there we can turn them on work on them
and then we can scale the blobs to
support all the all the ill
twos so as an
L2 I have the incentive to ask L1 for
more
blobs and you know it's unclear if I
have considered the full consequences of
this and this is just the incentives at
play so I am a little bit worried
because I know that there's a bunch more
l2s coming online that might have a
bunch of usage and we're already close
to The Blob Target so I do think it's
really important for l2s to kind of
prove that it's safe and I think that
the base team actually did a really good
job of this they made a bunch of long
documents to kind of explain you know
why it's safe to increase the blob
Target and without this actual you know
these actual numbers the data that shows
that it's
safe um you know it's really hard to
make decisions
I think another thing that will make it
easier to make decisions is if we had
the kind of minimum Hardware
requirements published
someplace people usually say that the
minimum Hardware requirements are you
know a consumer grade
laptop I know at this point um nodes the
databases are getting pretty big you
know you probably need an nvme or at
least a solid state drive but
I for one would love it if the community
was able to come together and literally
make a list that said the these are the
specific Hardware requirements that are
required and then we were able to
observe
dashboards and see the resource usage of
all the different clients and then we
would be able to have conversations
about improvements or or
eips hard forks and basically how they
would impact the resource usage against
the stated
requirements two terabyte
SSD 16 terabyte or 16 gigabyte
RAM four core uh CPU make it dat
it's it's going to be four terabyt
soon well iton it won't it won't we
recommend four terabytes but I think two
terabytes is a good Target
um so uh just to check on that we
already agreed that we're going to drop
premerge history uh after 6 months of
course with enough uh solutions to hold
the history uh like we have already
portal we have uh A1 files I don't want
to go technical but we have solutions to
keep the history safe and available and
accessible for everyone in a
decentralized manner um but yeah so we
are not going to raise the bar for the
hard drives
No it's very interesting that uh you
know like part of the reason why I
wanted to have Mark on this panel is
because we wanted to have a little bit
better coordination between L1 and L2 um
as you mentioned like you know the base
team has been coming to some of the or
all core Dev calls and you know showing
us some metrics and being and trying to
uh convince us that it is safe to raise
the The Blob Target and Max um but I'm
really you know curious is is this
working for us like is like is it nice
to actually have somebody um who's
outside of like a one uh being able to
you know contribute and and tell us how
we should go about doing things is that
um something that we would love to see
more of do we want to see more uh
arbitrum uh optimism um Advocates I
guess coming to our all coure Dev calls
will that help
I think that's a very interesting
question and it's it's very very hard to
answer it because on one end if you I
mean on one end we are always low on
Manpower I mean everything is always low
on Manpower so you need the ideas you
need the people to come in and help
that's simply the fact and if you have
somebody who's actually using the system
for something they have these feedback
loops to actually be able to provide the
number numbers now the flip side of the
coin is that every problem has multiple
Solutions and whenever a business entity
will come
with the solving the problem they will
always solve the problem in a way
that their prefers somehow their um
thing so I think the it's super valuable
to have the outside contributions but
the challenge is how to make sure that
they they are actually aligned with the
values and just to make sure that the
solutions they present there aren't
better
Alternatives so actually basically what
this boils down to is that the more
external contributors actually trying to
help and the more different ecosystems
or different businesses they are
operating if they get you get enough
people together then you will have
enough friction and enough uh push and
pull so that the really the truly good
common Solutions rise up and not one or
the other that one might
prefer I think that this question is a
lot of political philosophy to be honest
kind of how you feel about capitalism
whether you think competition is good um
you know we don't want the core
development process to be captured and
if there are you know businesses that
are coming in in they definitely have
some incentive to try to capture the
process for their own profit so we
always need to be mindful of that the
way that I always think about this is
you want to have a distribution of power
where the vested interests of each group
are at
odds and I think just being very
transparent about vested interests is
really important because I think that
saying there are no vested interests
isn't very honest I think it's just the
nature of business people have different
preferences different goals and I think
it's more about making those vested
interests transparent and balancing the
power between
them I guess one more thing to maybe
even more emphasize your point is that
it's not just it doesn't just boil down
to vested interests I think it also
boils down to Simply human relationship
so if somebody let's say I'm working on
the guest team somebody comes with a
pool request and if it's an internal
pool request I'm like hm okay I need to
review that if it's very wild I'm like
okay why did they want to do that what's
there might be a good idea whereas if
somebody externally tries to come with a
PO request I'm super skeptical I'm like
nah not really I don't know so there you
need much much more convincing from the
outside and I think that's also
something that we need to take care of
is to try to be as objective as possible
and to keep these personal preferences
outside of
work right is it is also safe to say
here that everybody is pretty much like
on board here with the sort of L2
Centric road map this is like sort of
the best way forward for us um and
because that kind of goes into like a
little bit of a question of like okay
well what is L2 what should l2s be
responsible for and what should L1 be
responsible for there's there might be
some differing opinions on like how much
we should push on on L1 and sort of push
the rest to L2 like um is there would
anybody here consider the L2 as like an
experimental layer for L1 at
all on a very general level I think that
um the L2 road map is is um great as
long as to tie into this um there's
enough competition between them um
because if there's notot enough
competition and like one of them becomes
the deao way to interact with ethereum
then it it leads to a centralization
issue there but I think as long as we
have enough competition between them I I
am fully on board with the L2 road map
so what you're saying is we need an L2
diversity page and switch away from base
no I think that if l2s are built in a
certain way in an uncompromising way or
uh of decentralization and
permissionless and censorship resistance
then it doesn't matter which L2 you're
on because you can always transact on it
or transact on another it's just an
extension of the main protocol at that
point and this was the like I think this
is the end game for this should be the
end game for twos to reach a point where
even if everyone is on the L2 it's not a
compromise on any of these things
because it's just an extension of the
same values and same um like properties
of the main protocol which is
ethereum I'm definitely a fan of the L2
scaling road map you know obviously
working on an L2 but um something that I
do think that is really important is
that you know as the ethereum community
we continue to put pressure on all of
the l2s to you know decentralize their
power more so what does this mean you
know becoming stage one becoming stage
two and you know I feel like a lot of
the community thought that it would be
easier for rollups to get to stage one
and stage two it's actually really
really hard and you know we're still
working on it and ideally we can build
free software that allows anybody to
spin up a stage two rollup
permissionless that to me is the vision
about the L2 scaling road map um I also
you know sometimes feel this um
interesting relationship with L1 because
often l2s are asking L1 devs to you know
work harder work faster so that we can
have these
features um I'll always remember this
moment um in Bogata when um Marius
actually came up to me and said
something like hey you know I'm staying
up late working on 4844 why are you not
stage two already and you know that
really stuck with me I think it is
important to pressure the l2s into you
know continuing to level up so yeah I
know that l2b is kind of removing stage
zero so I think that's a step in the
right
direction and maybe one point I would
like to make is that very often um
Twitter likes to criticize EF or theum
ecosystem for his direction of this why
aren't you sharding L1 why do you go
down the L2 Road and I think that's very
very important to realize that they are
the flip sides of the exactly same coin
so the end game is to have multiple
shards that can more or less atomically
communicate with each other now the L1
road map attempt originally was to split
up the main net and then try to fix
communication or sorry the other way uh
the other one was that uh we try to
split it slowly but keep it
communicating with each other whereas
the al2 road map was that okay we do
these hard splits and then try to
somehow fix the communication but the
end goal is is exactly the same so it
doesn't really matter which path we go
down on however the L2 might be simpler
from a technical perspective in that you
have multiple semi-independent
components that can evolve whereas going
down the L PA L1 path would have meant
always tweaking this monolith so it's
simply a bit faster and a bit riskier
also as a project manager like one of
the worst things that you could also
hear about is like hey guys mayet is
down that's like the worst sentence any
one of us can can hear and I can
understand like being conservative when
it comes to you know pushing things like
eips um especially ones that are
potentially consensus breaking if we
don't do it right um so do you feel like
we shouldn't be taking these risks at L1
like you know Mark says like there are
definitely complaints that there not
necessarily saying you but in general
that L1 moves too slow um we're slow for
a reason and really like we don't want
to bring down Main net so is it is like
Layer Two a better place for us to test
things like ethereum object format or or
any other sort of like like account
abstraction stuff like before we
actually get to
L1 yeah I mean I think that's a great
idea but we do need to remember that it
is still real money if these are
production
networks um I think you know having
Frontier sort of layer to test Nets with
the new features um building end to-end
applications that integrate deeply into
the new features is a really good way to
make
progress um I think for
l2s I think a lot about the go to market
and kind of the product because we're
trying to onboard the users and be you
know much closer to the users than L1 so
I think more about
l2s um you know benefiting from
improving the product rather than
adopting the eips at this point because
I think that there's so many lwh hang
fruits in just better user experience
and the our ability to onboard new
people um we can do it much more
effectively by putting effort into
improving the products built on top of
the protocol rather than adding features
to the protocol
itself yes I think I kind of agree there
that the problem is that yes in theory
you can experiment on L2 a lot but in
practice let's say you do account
abstraction on some L2 it's very nice
everybody likes it then you have a lot
of companies spend a number of years
building something out and then it turns
out well this wasn't the best solution
so we're going with a different account
abstraction but what happens with all
those people who's invested three years
of their life in it and I think from
that perspective evolving the evm I
would go from L1 towards L2 where you
have the guarante of backwards
compatibility with regard to scaling
stuff go wild I mean try everything and
basically there are no implications if
um hits the fan so if it base tries
to do Mega gas per second and all of a
sudden everything comes crashing down
well the worst scenario is it stops it
becomes slow it becomes expensive but
there's no other bad side effect whereas
if they start doing start experimenting
with the evm and they start doing things
that are impossible elsewhere then
that's a very nasty vendor lock in
situation okay just looking at the time
we have like about two minutes left um
should probably wrap this up but before
we wrap it up there is one question that
I have for all of you guys just so we
can get a little bit about what you're
thinking here do you have have a North
star or a mission statement for ethereum
like what is our endgame
here I think that wraps around to the
first question I'm going with credible
credible neutrality which encompasses
all those other things decentralization
and I I'll go with uncompromising
yeah Unstoppable open
systems flat power structures
I'm not budging
sorry that's okay I got I got know my
mind except uh eth to the moon
so uh thanks everyone for coming to uh
this panel I think we will start
answering some questions a little bit of
Q&A for you guys I think we got about 10
minutes to do
that okay so if you guys haven't already
there's a QR code behind here
um if you go to that and you scroll down
um you should be able to find a uh
beercat or link or something like that
it says uh join live Q&A so please feel
free to ask your questions upvote the
ones you want to get asked and I'll uh
try to get them here with our
panelists so the first one here that we
actually have is other than Finance what
is the most exciting use case of a
resilient decentralized World computer
in your
opinion I struggle with this one and
I'll give an answer that's not like
totally fan fangirling over ethereum um
because in every case of there being um
a promise to connect a provider directly
with consumers there always ends up
being middlemen who like shove their way
in I read uh a really good expose on
only fans on Reuters um where like the
whole promise was to to uh directly con
uh connect uh sex sex workers with
consumers and within this platform they
had essentially recreated the
uh pimps they had recreated pimps like
um and it wasn't directly clear so I
actually I'm very excited by the idea of
connecting
um consumers with um protocols
permissionless in ways that like are
governed by code but I am very wary of
the the idea that we can prevent these
middlemen from coming in so I think that
um we have to be very uh critical of any
exciting use cases that come
in I think for me the most uh exciting
would be the platform itself so Finance
is kind of super boring to me and what I
really like for me what's kind of
important is that anybody can dream up
their little constructive project and be
able to to deploy it and interact with
the people and it just I think this
freedom to just do whatever is um is the
single most important
property one use case that I think is
really important is just
um you know like some sort of open and
Unstoppable um social network or kind of
like news information aggregation site
um where people have the right to just
kind of like speak their mind publish
different ideas in kind of an open way
where it's difficult to you know fully
censor anyone and applications can be
built on top of this with like their own
fil filtering
mechanisms and um their own censorship
mechanisms and but like the base layer
kind of has to be open to allow people
to kind of say whatever they want and
this sort of model um can kind of be
like a checks inbalances on any sort of
Walled Garden or um incumbent power
structure that you know becomes too
powerful in the
world I I have I'm so excited about the
idea of like forecaster came online and
the idea of pulling being able to pull
your data from one um front end to
another really really excites me because
I can't tell you how many people I've
met who like got kicked out of Facebook
and lost all their photos because for
some reason they were storing all of
their stuff on Facebook um but with that
comes an a really important um feature
of needing to um have Cil resistance
because in recent months we've seen a
huge drop off from from farcaster
because Bots have been onboarded and
there was a lot of
incentivization uh to be on farcaster
and so it like it's gone downhill but
like that is also a really exciting
thing because social media rules so much
of our life and like impacts our
behavior and is used to manipulate the
way that we interact with each other and
we've seen it has a lot of influence in
doing so totally sometimes I wonder if
the algorithm is thinking for me
I will say from my perspective one of
the biggest centralizing points that we
should try to work out and and figure
out how to get off of is GitHub I'll
give you an example very quickly of just
one of our developers who um was
actually flagged at one point for spam
and his account disappeared overnight so
all of the PRS all the contributions
everything his entire history and
comments all the context that we had to
his work was gone overnight I've been
kicked off of GitHub three times oh
congratulations but I I got it back
every
time I don't think it's a contest though
but I mean just just finishing up here
like they could basically just cancel
you and that is one of my biggest
worries is that we're so reliant on the
system like GitHub which is a United
States entity so it's uh it's kind of
concerning that um some somebody can
just be wiped off the face of the
digital Earth that
easily totally I mean getting wiped off
of GitHub that could have catastrophic
consequences for someone's life that's
like you know many people's resumee is
their work that they did on GitHub and
you know if they're an admin to a
project that is like a you know a
blockchain project where there's real
money being stored on the system it
could like be a way to cut off the
developers from being able to roll out a
new release and upgrade the blockchain
so that is definitely a big problem I
feel like we should muscle through the
rest of these questions like one person
per per question maybe because I don't
want to like spend too much time on one
question we have question yeah next
question I'm guessing this one is for
Peter do you still consider gu's 52%
majority a big risk for ethereum
stability okay I don't really want to
waste too much time on it I would like
to challenge that statistics as far as
I'm aware nether mind has the majority
validators nowadays so I think it's kind
of mood we just yeah uh I I don't think
it's that relevant at current
time would love to see people using bezo
Aragon and WTH as
well all right next question Peter
you're popular today uh Peter spoke of
democratic values on ethereum everyone
having an equal say but doesn't this
risk design sign by committee should
everyone have a say in how gu is built
uh actually I was making the exact
opposite point I don't want everyone to
have an equal say I would like everyone
to have an equal opportunity to
contribute to ethereum but I don't think
everybody having an so I would like
everybody who works on the same level
have an equal say things but I would not
like people operating on different
levels to have a say in in layers which
are they are not familiar in for example
I'm an L1 Dev I have opinions about what
base could do but I don't really feel
confident about giving them pointers
that do it like this do it like that
that they probably know better flat
structures aren't truly flat structures
they're just the ultimate
meritocracy they're messy but they're
the ultimate
meritocracy all right next question
which aspects of ethereum has a greater
centralization risk than others right
now
Builders the
foundation good take yeah Rel
layers
epbs yeah definitely the meev supply
chain yeah the block production pipeline
is uh pretty ripe for capture uh today
we're even starting to see relays and
block Builders vertically align which is
a little bit concerning too
okay next question is what is wrong with
staking eth on Raspberry Pi when you can
literally run hundreds of validators on
a single rpy device recently verified by
projects such as web 3 Pi nothing
there's nothing wrong with staking on
Raspberry Pi and I super encourage uh
the people who are who are experimenting
on that to experiment more and but I I
do think it's a little ridiculous to um
like expect all of the core devs to to
tailor towards a Raspberry Pi I think it
comes on both sides like the people who
are hobbyists who are working in
raspberry pies should be trying to
optimize their systems to work with
cordev and cordev should be working with
them but like I'm so sick of the Twitter
meme of like the potato in the
Atlantic uh do you see centralization
risk in development of the core protocol
with ef being a
bottleneck o hot I don't think EF is a
bottleneck I think EF researchers are
churning out specs that are Som
impossible to keep up with so bottleneck
definitely not um centralization
risk okay that's not a 10-second answer
sorry all right thank you everyone for
your time uh thank our panelists for
coming and uh spending some time with us
today and uh have the rest of good have
a good Devcon thank you thank you very
much thank you thank you thank
you thank you so much folks uh I really
think that now my definition on what is
theeran got a little more complex but
it's great and while we are reorganizing
this stage to welcome the next presenter
I'd love to remind you all that you can
already start asking questions through
your davcon passport so just go to the
next session and then then open the Q&A
through mircat also all the sessions in
all the stages are being live streamed
so while the word is waking up perhaps
it's time to perhaps send a message to
the folks you know that wouldn't be uh
that are not here and thaton this time
to say hey you should check it out this
session this live stream and maybe send
you know like a picture and keep an
updated on what's been going here over
12,000 people were able this is the
biggest Devcon so far but we know there
are several folks that for many reasons
could not make it so it's always good to
keep them in mind and send you know a
live stream or send a note on how it's
been going these day so far and yes so
we are welcoming the next
speaker very very soon
[Music]
and this time will have a keynote
on on iteron oh yeah what else would be
we will have a keynote from prao
Paladino on theic Foundation is vision
for etan toing ecosystem so everyone
please give a warm welcome to Patricio
[Music]
so hi everyone thanks for being
here I'm Patricio Paladino I'm one of
the co-founders and the CTO of nomic
foundation nomic is a nonprofit
dedicated to improve the ethereum
development platforms for Builders like
you at Nomi what we do is creating open
source infrastructure and tooling for
ethereum and our most well-known tool is
harut and we've been building harut for
quite some time we started it in 2018 so
almost 7 years ago and it grew from
being a site project to being a
collection of different tools that
include not just harad the task Runner
and the framework also a network
simulator it includes things like a a
deployment solution and better support
for solidity in vs code and different
editors creating these things expose us
to almost the entirety of the
infrastructure landscape of ethereum and
we got to learn about its
limitations and I want to share a few
learnings that we got so far the first
learning is that building tooling for
ethereum is challenging it's actually
pretty
challenging and this is not something
exclusive to harut if you were to to
build any kind of tool or infrastructure
in ethereum most probably you'll find
yourself with a me unmet needs and you
you will have to either create your own
Solutions or or your own workarounds or
hacks to see some examples if we were to
create a solidity
formatter which is just a tool that
takes your solidity source code and
reprint it reprint it in a nice format
the first thing that you would need is a
parser a library or a tool that takes
that text process it in a in a way that
it will allow you to then pre-int it
easily and yeah you will find some
parcel for solidity out there but all of
them will have their set of limitations
they may either pass in somewhat
approximation of
solidity that it's not clear which which
particular version they are passing or
they may be passing a single version
where your tool wants to process every
version of
solidity or they may be tied to a single
programming language like I want my tool
to be buil in Rust but the par that I
want to use is built in JavaScript and I
can do it and I I don't know find a work
around or hack it together and this
leads to clearly less than idea
solutions to see some more examples if
we were to build a linter solidity lter
we would have all those same problems
and more what if we wanted type away a
rule that I don't know for BS that you
use a certain type as storage of your
context well you'll definitely
definitely not find a library that
exposes the solidity type system for you
to build this rule simply so what would
you do well you either build a part of
that probably in a quick and dirty
fashion or maybe come up with a half B
solution that it's just a bunch of
characteristics maybe a regular
expression or something like
that if you were to build a Sol editor
things were would be way way worse and
trust me we've been there we built one
and you pretty much have to reimplement
a good chunk of Sal C code
analysis but those examples that I named
are just three out of a ton of different
tools and infra infra pieces that any
any realistic or mature development
platform has there are more examples
that I listed here but to be honest
these are just some examples that came
to my mind and that could fit in a
single slide in a in a mature platform
in a real world well it's not that it's
not real world in just less mature in a
mature platform there are tons and tons
of tools and they are constantly new
tools being created but in ethereum if
you were to create any one of these
tools I assure you that your experience
won't be smooth it will be simple it
will be similar to the things that I
mentioned you will find yourself unmet
limitations and you would have to come
up with your own Solutions and to make
things a bit worse some of these tools
you would want them to exist in
different languages maybe you want to
connector language in JavaScript in
typescript in Python in sh
and that just add some kind of
multiplication to the problem making it
larger then another learning that we
have is that ethereum is a moving
platform and what do I mean by this well
for once ethereum is constantly evolving
it evolves through hard Forks but also
through layer choose and there's tons
and tons of changes coming coming up now
that are due to new layer tws popping up
every day also the tooling and libraries
Chang we went from using web 3 shs at
one point then to a new version of web 3
shs that was completely different then
tether then BM and I'm sure that things
will still
change finally another thing that also
change is the developer needs themselves
they buil different kinds of
applications at one point we were all
building in stable coins then nfts then
Dow then different things and those
different things have different needs
and different levels of complexity and
size not to say that anything about
multichain that it's now completely
changing the needs of developers just a
few years ago things were way simpler
for an ethereum developer now they have
to deal with multiple chains at the same
time and things just get
harder now to be honest this is not
something unique to ethereum it happens
everywhere every every software
development platform that it's alive and
continues to evolve goes through
constant change and renewal it happens
to node it happens to every every single
language what it's Unique to ethereum is
the speed of
change and the fact that every tool is
built based on hacks and workarounds as
I described and when you combine those
two things things changing quickly and
things being unreliable you get a ton of
fragility in the platform
itself and finally the other thing that
I or learning that I want to to mention
is that as I mentioned before Atomic we
don't work just for harat we work for
the entirety of the theum development
platform we want to improve it all and
if and at one point we realize that we
can't just do it through harad and and
we can just do it by being direct
providers of final Solutions or
developer
Solutions why because we have liit
limited bandwidth we can only focus on
so many things our team is has a limited
set of people hopefully it will increase
but it will still be limited and we just
can't fix everything also if we were to
be direct providers of every single
solution we could become a an ecosystem
dependency cor ecosystem
dependency and that that's not something
that we want to be and at the same time
doing that would or could
potentially make us gain a a ton of
influence on the platform and that's not
about not aligned with the values of of
nomic
finally if we were to build the
resolution ourselves we would be making
a ton of decisions because we won't
build any any any of the many
technical approaches for every single
tool but we would have to pick one or at
most two and that would lead to less
technical exploration less approaches to
every single problem and that could
inhibit part of the potential of the
platform it's better to have diversity
of ideas diversity of Technical
Solutions and that then every every
every developer every project will pick
whatever fits best for them
so instead at nomic our long-term vision
is to build the core pieces of
infrastructure that would enable the
ecosystem itself to build its own
tooling and do it efficiently and at the
same time doing it from a nonprofit and
independent nonprofit that it has clear
ethereum align
incentives which are these pieces of
infrastructure they are two one is
called slang and the other one EDR for
ethereum development
runtime slang it's a solidity compiler
as a set of apis focus on tooling what
does it mean well if we go back to the
examples that I mentioned and we wanted
to create a formatter and this is
actually doable now you could use slangs
formatter sorry not formatter slang
parer that that parer will be ready to
be consumed from many languages is ready
to be consumed from many languages and
it's easy to use supports many languages
of solidity and it's actually being used
by a beta version of of prer solidity
right now and it improve how prer
solidity can form format different
versions of solidity for a lter similar
thing you get slang it's a library you
get to use a different set of apis that
slang proposes exposes but same thing
you just have the the building blocks
available for you by Design slang it's
focused on tools because tools tend to
have a different set of constraints that
just than just a traditional compiler
for example they may need to deal with
different versions of the language uh
while a traditional compiler just deals
with one in a tool you want a single
tool to be able to handle the then
almost or all the entire history of the
language while a compiler can just focus
on a normal compiler can just focus on a
single one same with things like eror
recovery you may want your formatter to
to be more permissive in the presence of
or or forgiving in the presence of
errors and similar constraints like that
that make having a tooling oriented
compiler a great piece of infrastructure
for Tool developers and needs publish as
a library so you can use it either from
rust or typescript and it's also
targeting wasm so you can even import it
from other other
places now EDR it's a portable library
also written in Rust it it implements an
ethereum simulator including some layer
choose that means that it simulates the
network it it's already in production it
Powers carat 2 the current version of
carat and when we release it we saw
performance improvements in massive
performance improvements actually in
some hard projects some of them just
without changing any single line of code
just viting their dependencies starting
running 10 times
faster and at the same time EDR will
simulate does Sim will simulate optimism
or upstack chain soon and it will
include a solidity test Runner it's
again this is a library this is not just
build for carat anyone can install it
and it can be used for any kind of tool
that needs to run simulator simulations
or do any kind of runtime an
analysis finally slang and EDR are
system projects what does that mean that
they are designed to work
together and by that and that's because
the combination of both will allow us to
do way more advanced things that what we
can do with each of them in isolation
right now we have a a compiler so see
build by one team we have our own Ram
times it's hard to collaborate deeply
enough to build things like I don't know
picture chrome chrome development tools
they are dagger you can change variables
in real time you can rewrite parts of
the code keep running those kind of
things are possible we can build them in
ethereum but they do require a ton of
deep collaboration and integration
between the compiler and the runtime and
that's the the kind of thing that we are
going after atomic we want EDR and slang
to mature to be libraries that everyone
can use they will provide the basis for
anyone to grab those tools grab those
libraries and build the next generation
of ethereum tooling with
them and that's it if you want to learn
more about nomic uh you can scan the QR
code I guess it's on your left um that
one has information about the different
presentations that we are giving at Nomi
that we are giving at Decon one of them
yesterday I already gave it it's about
harat 3 the upcoming version of harat
it's not ready for production yet but
there is an internal Alpha and tons of
information in that presentation it's
recorded so you can watch it today I
think at 5 or 600 p.m.
there's a presentation by one of our
team members that's going to explain how
EDR can simulate different ta choose
different networks and tomorrow at 12 or
12:30 there is a presentation about
slang and how you can use it to analyze
your solidity code with some pretty cool
apis finally if you want to work with us
you enjoy the the kind of thing that we
do you can scan the other QR code and
learn more about show show offerings
show positions at nomic and that's it
thank
you patrio thank you so much and for
everyone it's still open for QA so just
Q disc code we do have one question here
for you so can EDR be used for things
like simulation with alterate storage
State Storage of right in tenderly
terms yes
sorry about that's the whole answer yes
it
can we have another question here when
we advance testing features like
symbolic debugging be integrated or will
it be possible to connect in advanced
noes like build bear a Sandbox instead
of hard heart noes uh well I don't have
I don't think I have an answer for the
first uh part of the question uh we'll
have to analyze it I can promise on any
timeline right now uh the second one I
think should be possible yes uh if not
just reach out through GitHub and we we
can analyze
it we do have another question here
automatic test generation is that
something that the nomic foundation is
interested in adding wait I can read it
is
it should then we do canr used be used
for
oh okay cool thank you
uh uh it's not our I'll rad it just in
case automatic test generation is that
something that the foundation is
interested in not in snow dri current
Focus I think there's a ton of
development going on super interesting
on AI but that's not the focus of our
organization if there is a way to
integrate those things cheaply
we will but harad itself it's a super
flexible platform you can build your own
plugin so if you want to experiment with
this and create your own automatic
generation plugin automatic test
generation plugin should be super safe
for where go try it out and tell us how
it it went
yeah perfect Patric you thank you so
much for your presentation thanks
everyone for your questions we'll be
back in 15 minutes
yes we'll back at 2:30 we a key note
that e is permissionless money so you
definitely take this time to take a
break grab a coffee and come back in
1550 minutes see you soon
[Music]
e
for e
[Music]
for
that
[Music]
for
you
[Music]
for
for for
[Music]
for
for for
[Music]
and welcome back to another session here
on the main stage of Devcon southeast
Asia we've been hearing a lot about
etherion and yes it couldn't have been
different and when we think of itan we
think of the community of the ecosystem
of the technology of a movement of some
contradictions too but today more
specifically we're going to talk about
eth and after all eth is money e is
permissionless money and this session
Mike from the interor foundation is
going to cover how e is being used today
and how its rool can be involved so
everyone please give a warm welcome to
Mike
W
hello can you hear
me how loud enough
cool right no slides
yet is everyone having a good
[Laughter]
day say
again cool
sweet yeah hey everyone my name is Mike
I work at the ethereum foundation and
the title of my talk is eth this
permissionless money but the subtitle is
the ticker
eth cool so I'm going to split the talk
into two halves the first I'll I'll talk
about what it means for eth to be
permissionless and the second half we'll
talk about what it means for eth to be
money so to motivate the permissionless
I have a few
quotes first from hyek in the road to
serfdom
what our generation has forgotten is
that a system of property private
property is the most important guarantee
of freedom and the second is very
similar from Milton Freedman I think
that nothing so important for Freedom as
recognizing in the law each individual's
natural right for property so both of
these kind of are the core thing that
brought me into crypto in the first
place which is this self- sovereignty
self- custody over digital
property so let's talk about property
rights of eth kind of on L1 first and
foremost and I'd like to summarize this
with kind of the one sentence
description which is anyone can
permissionless store send and program
eth the native asset right this is kind
of table Stakes for for what ethereum
was trying to be in the very first place
and it's actually pretty wild if you
think about it right like you can send
money globally for you know a few cents
and no one can stop that and importantly
like that is this um censorship
resistance and private property and
settlement insurances that eth provides
that gives it the true differentiation
from the traditional Financial rails
that we have
today so I have a a diagram to help kind
of map this out and we'll use many of
these diagrams as we talk about scaling
Etha asset and scaling property rights
to to other uh ecosystems too so here we
have eth mainnet we have a few accounts
we have Unis swap which is a contract so
kind of the first primitive that we have
is this transfer right this is the
ability to send eth from one account to
another we also of course have this
ability to program eth and and the
canonical example here is that we can
send money from the account number three
to Unis swap the pool allows us to swap
it for die and this is kind of like the
the original promise of eth and the
programmability of eth on the layer one
itself but as we all know ethereum is
not just the L1 at this point right like
it has grown to to much broader
ecosystems and there's now all of these
rollups and part of ethereum scaling
plan is actually through the rollup
Centric road map so the natural next
question is to say okay what are the
property rights of eth on rollups
themselves and here I'm using rollups in
the canonical sense which is these are
ethereum smart contract rollups that
post their transaction data to ethereum
blobs so that's like a very important
distinction and we'll talk about how
that actually impacts the property
rights of eth across um rollups versus
other
l2s the one sentence summary here is
that anyone can perly permissionless
bridge eth in and out of rollups and
this isn't to say that you will be able
to do any defi activity or you'll but be
able to buy any nft on any rollup
permissionless because rollups make some
sacrifices in terms of the
decentralization in order to actually
scale to be able to handle like Global
volume but the core property rights of
eth come from the ability to bridge in
and out permissionless no matter what
the sequencer does to you so to kind of
represent this we have a second Di
and this diagram has kind of expanded a
little bit we now have ethereum main net
on the left we have included the da
layer here and the blobs are represented
as those uh kind of pink circle things
and then we also have an ethereum roll
up on the right and the first kind of
operation is we send eth from an account
into the bridge the bridge is just a
smart contract that lives on ethereum
Main net and that bridging in is
reflected in the ethereum rollup state
so now we're credited count one with
some amount of eth and the underlying
eth is actually locked in this bridge on
the ethereum
L1 of course you can transfer eth on the
rollup you can do defi on the rollup you
can buy your favorite
nft but the thing I'm going to focus on
is the ability to withdraw your eth from
that rollup permiss usly so let's say
that the rollup sequencer went offline
or started censoring you for whatever
reason you still have this ability to
force withdraw and the force withdraw to
me is the the most important part of
interacting with a rollup which is you
still retain the strong property rights
of eth no one's able to censor or block
that
transaction um and that's that's kind of
like why ethereum rollups are are
scaling not only ether's block space and
the ability to consume and and interact
and do cool stuff on chain but they're
also scaling the property rights of e
asset
itself the force withdraw is able to
process because it can check the
validity of that withdrawal against
ethereum's da itself
so this is kind of the important
precondition that says hey this ethereum
block um use of eth that I'm going to
talk about is how the property rights of
eth On non- ethereum Da l2s look and
this is a bit of a mouthful but the one
sentence summary here I put the kind of
important part up front and italicized
it which is if the external da layer is
live anyone can permissionless bridge
eth in and out so now suddenly like
the the property rights of our assets
have changed right it's it's no longer
just ethereum it's no longer the
decentralization of the whole ethereum
validator set but actually now you have
an external dependency and that
fundamentally changes the sovereignty of
the assets that you're holding in that
rollup now that's not to say that no one
should ever use a non- ethereum DA
rollup I think there's there's places
for that you know social fi uh gaming
and these types of things but I still
feel like anything any um activity that
needs the strong settlement insurance is
and strong property rights of ether the
asset needs to take place on ethereum
rollup
itself right third diagram so we've kind
of added something different which is
this other blockchain now it doesn't
necessarily have to be another
blockchain it could be just uh you know
a Amazon web service is cluster that's
running in us east1 but the PO important
thing is that there's an external source
of Da and this is where the transaction
data is being posted um for the for the
L2 so the bridging in looks very much
the same as before you send eth from an
account into the bridge the bridge is a
smart contract on ethereum L1 which gets
reflected into the account on the
ethereum optimium I'm using optimium as
Shand um this is the word we use to
describe optimistic l1s that post their
da to an external data
source again you can do all of the kind
of money verbs that we described before
as long as the L2 that is sequencing
those transactions is online and is not
censoring you but we're not too
interested in that we're curious still
about the property rights of eth as it
pertains to when you hold it and Bridge
it over to the
optimium and there's still a force
withdraw mechanism this is kind of the
same pattern that we saw before of you
need to get your eth out and kind of
withdraw it to the to the base chain
let's just say the the sequencer is
offline but suddenly you have this
dependency which is you need to check
the validity of that Force withdraw
against some external data source now
this could be totally fine and in the
happy path hopefully that withdraw will
be process normally but again this is
kind of the security tradeoff that you
make by interacting with this system
that doesn't fully depend only on
ethereum
itself cool and before we go into the
the money stuff I also wanted to kind of
point out the fact that usdc and usdc
have no property rights right I think a
common misconception is that like people
think oh programmable money like usdc is
great I can it's an erc20 token I can
send it into all these smart contracts
it has all these nice interfaces that
that are exposed but fundamentally this
is neobank money right so these two um
these two Dune dashboards show the
number of um blocked or blacklisted
addresses for tether on the left or
sorry usdc on the left and usdt on the
right and effectively if if Jeremy oair
decides that you don't have you know
access to your property he can shut off
the um the access to your
usdc so this is very similar to the the
traditional Financial world where the
government has control over your own
property and you should be aware of that
when you're using these tokens so in in
one sentence
this right so to summarize the
permissionless of ether the
asset eth is program permissionless and
programmable on the L1 rollups scale the
property rights of
eth property rights on non- ethereum da
l2s depend on another chain
and usdc and usdt have no property
rights cool so now jumping into the
second half we're going to talk about
eth's money and to motivate this section
I have two quotes the first is another
macroeconomist John mayard KES by
continuing process or by the continuing
process of inflation governments can
confiscate secretly and unobserved an
important part of the wealth of their
citizens so this kind of motivates why
so much attention is paid to the
monetary properties and the supply of
either the asset in particularly the
inflation rate and how that
redistributes wealth between the people
who are being kind of inflated against
and those who are protected against that
inflation and the second is a quote from
David Graber money has no Essence it's
not really anything therefore its Nature
has always been and presumably always
will be a matter of political contention
so the point here is to say that this is
just my view of what eth money means and
hopefully you know this helps inform and
kind of give you a framing for thinking
about it for your own context but this
is certainly not like the end all Beall
of the discussion of what eth's money
actually
means cool so to start I thought it
would be useful to do a brief history of
The Ether
Supply so on the far left we have 2016
this is like right post Genesis and on
the far right we have um today and we
see that the the supply has gone through
kind of a few big regime changes and
I'll highlight five different uh time
stamps so first on October uh in October
2017 we had the Byzantium hard Fork
which changed the ethereum block reward
from 5 eth per block to 3 eth per block
this is important because it changes the
slope of the inflation or of the supply
growth over time very similarly in 2019
we had the Constantinople hardfork and
EIP 1234 reduced that 3E block reward to
a two block reward
in August 2021 the London hard Fork
introduced
e559 and this is when the burn was
activated and we'll talk about the burn
in a little bit but the the kind of key
feature in the total Supply is that we
see that instead of being like a
straight monotone increasing line we now
have some variability in the growth of
the supply and that variability comes
from the amount of eth being burned
through transaction fees and that's
variable it depends on demand but now
we're kind of into this regime of of
burning eth along with the inflationary
pressure from the issuance
the kind of most important point I would
say in this plot is September 2022 this
was the merge no more proof of work
rewards and you can see that at that
point we've basically stopped the growth
of the supply of
ether and the last point is in March
2024 earlier this year the Denon hard
Fork introduced 444 in which blobs
arrived and yeah effectively some of the
activity that was taking place on the L1
some of the activity that was burning
eth on the L1 migrated to l2s but the
overall impact on the total Supply is is
almost negligible right like you barely
see that inflection point um and that's
kind of a key takeway too of of the
overall Supply mechanics of of eth
currently cool so briefly I'll I'll do
some back of napkin math for what the
current eth inflation rate is I think
it's interesting and um kind of going
through the numbers so there's 120
million ether Supply and about 28% of it
or 34 million is staked at that uh stake
rate that corresponds to about a three
and a quar per yield meaning that over
the course of a year we have 1.1 million
new eth created Which is less than 1%
annual inflation right so like compared
to Fiat money this is already way better
um all things considered salana
inflation looks a little
different they have a supply of 588
million tokens and 40 Mill 400 million
of them are staked which is about 68%
and at a 7% yield so this corresponds to
28 million Supply uh increase in Supply
each year or a 4.7% annual inflation
rate so five times higher than ether
inflation it's also interesting to look
at Bitcoin inflation now it's it's kind
of confusing because people don't think
of Bitcoin as inflationary but of course
there still are block rewards and the
current amount of circulating Supply is
only
19.78%
Bitcoin and for the next four years
there'll be 3.125 Bitcoin per block
corresponding based on the 52,000 blocks
per per year to 164,000 bitcoin per year
so the takeaway here is that the 8%
inflation annually is about the same as
The Ether inflation which is kind of
kind of interesting to think
about now of course billion does have
this 21 million promise and that is the
inflation rate of Bitcoin gets cut in
half every four years in perpetuity and
this is from the Satoshi white paper it
says once a predetermined number of
coins have entered circulation the
incentive can transition entirely to
transaction fees and be completely
inflation free now this sounds great in
theory right like you know there was uh
the the Maynard Kane's quote about uh
inflation being the way that the
government taxes us um however there's
still kind of this fundamental question
which is how does the instability of
proof of work with only transaction fees
get resolved right and in particular
this this plot shows transaction fees of
Bitcoin over the past six years and you
can see that there's about a 2-year
period from mid 2022 to Mid 2023 oh
sorry mid 2021 to Mid 2023 rather where
the average uh fees generated during
each Bitcoin block was like far less
than a single Bitcoin itself so the the
kind of question that naturally arises
is how can you sustain the economic
security of a chain based on such low
amount of transaction fees over like a
two-year time Horizon and that's why
ethereum's kind of long-term issuance
policy is not to actually go to zero but
to have both inflation and burn and
during periods of high volatility the
burn will absorb a lot of that inflation
maybe we'll go net deflation
maybe we'll kind of just offset
inflation altogether but during periods
of lower activity lower volatility kind
of the natural um recessionary kind of
downturn then there's still incentive to
behave honestly in the system and the
kind of overall micro um decisions that
stakers need to make should still be um
aligned with behaving honestly and
following the protocol
rules one kind of really interesting
example is when Babylon chain launched
this was just a few weeks ago 12 weeks
ago the Bitcoin block reward went from
0.3 Bitcoin per block to 15.5 over the
course of four blocks right so this is
actually a 500x increase in the value of
a block over the course of of 40 minutes
so clearly this is um a a situation
which would call into question the
stability of the fork Choice rule when
someone mining on this chain sees that
they have a 500x opportunity if they try
and um remove the latest block on the
chain and and create one of their own so
again this is this is a question that's
still unanswered um in terms of how the
long-term security model of Bitcoin will
resolve
itself so the takeaway here eth has low
and sustainable inflation and we haven't
even talked about the burn right we're
17 minutes into the talk and about money
and we haven't even talked about the
burn how crazy is that so first I'll
I'll kind of cruise through this because
the the burn stuff is is well covered by
many people including um Justin and the
ultrasound money meme so so we're
currently burning about uh 476,000 ether
per year which is after like this is the
30-day level and this is after a lot of
activity has already migrated to the L2
so when people um talk about the burn
going to zero it's like clearly not true
we're still burning almost half of the
total issuance per year just from L1
transaction fees and obviously this
depends highly on market conditions so
during High periods of volatility like
the past few days when eth is pumping
when everything's going crazy then we
might end up burning a more than during
uh quieter times so this is kind of what
I mean when the burn absorbs large
amounts of this inflation and and kind
of serves as this business cycle um
adjustment to the total
Supply and yeah just reminder that the
current inflation is only 1 million eth
per year now we also have burn from The
Blob fees right so one cool thing about
L2 usage and the kind of rollup Centric
road map that we defined earlier is that
the l2s that that post blobs to ethereum
DX actually pay for that service um
currently the they don't pay much
because the blobs are cheap but in the
future there's a world where the average
L2 transaction can remain very cheap but
the blob fees actually do meaningfully
offset the current eth inflation and so
just one last U napkin math calculation
so if we have a DA layer with 128 blobs
per slot and two Giga gas that's uh two
billion gas per second that could
correspond to either 95,000 transactions
per second or 6,000 swaps that's just
the total raw amount of gas that could
be exposed through a DA layer of that
size now to to fully offset that
issuance each of those 95k transfers
would only cost one/ tenth of of a cent
right
001 and each of the swaps would be about
a Cent and a
half the blobs themselves all 300
million of them that are posted over a
year would only cost $10 so the real
tldr here is that transaction fees can
stay insanely low and still burn a lot
of eth and this is kind of part of the
the beauty of actually like growing the
block space and allowing more people to
come on chain and grow the user adoption
while still kind of seeing some of the
the benefit of burning that comes from
the blob
fees right eth's money summary eth
Supply is relatively stable inflation is
low and
sustainable the burn from L1 activity
offsets half of the current inflation
and L L2 activity Burns blob fees
so I have 38 seconds left to do the full
picture and it's basically just
summarizing everything I said in a
single diagram I love diagrams I love
drawing these things so yeah we have
kind of three concentric circles and I
like to think of this as kind of the
range of onchain growing uh in terms of
security but also like hopefully opening
up to more and more users so at the core
we have the L1 then we have the rollups
as we defined them earlier and optimums
at the at the farthest
Circle so first talking about
permissionless at the L1 eth can be
transmitted and programmed on the
rollups you have this Force withdraw
mechanism that imbus the same property
rights to eth on the l2s then on rollups
that it has on the L1 and on optimium
you have the force withdraw mechanism
that depends on the external da so all
of these kind of come together and form
this permissionless story for ether the
asset across the
ecosystem going the other direction we
have the money properties of eth asset
so we have the burn on the L1 we have
blob burn from rollups that consume
ethereum
da and on optimums we spread ether as a
medium of exchange and unit of account
these two terms are kind of what
macroeconomics people usually use to
describe money and we didn't get to talk
about it too much today but basically
spreading ether as as an asset that
people care about can transact with and
can use even in optimums and kind of
side chains and all sorts of other
constructions I think is super valuable
and that's why I think eth is money too
so together this is the whole picture of
why I think eth is permissionless money
and thank you very much for your
[Applause]
time thank you so much Mike great
meeting you in person by the way we have
tons of questions here from the audience
we'll try to fit in on the five minutes
we have the first question is when you
talk about when you were talking about
rollups you mean the stage two rollups
specifically yeah so just a little
context stage two defines kind of some
of the security properties of rollups
that um vitalic defined in an early post
and stage two is kind of when the
training wheels are removed from the
rollup and there there's questions about
is the Smart contract Bridge upgradeable
um yeah and so I think in the in the
truest definition of rollup I do think
about them as stage 2 no training wheels
and they still post blobs to ethereum Da
so yes all right can a dominant LST be
permissionless
money it's a good question I think not
mainly because I don't see a
construction where a dominant LST is not
controlled by a DA and in the world
where a DA has control over over the
asset itself I don't see that as like a
stable equilibrium in a long-term um
valuable kind of anti fragile way to
hold your your value on chain so I say
no
well for the next one I can answer the
ticker is e um the second one how does e
win and stay relevant for the next 100
years yeah um I guess I still believe in
kind of the the core values that that
valal talked about in his opening talk
which is you know focusing on credible
neutrality focusing on censorship
resistance and kind of this World War
III grade security I think that's kind
of the only way to be antifragile in the
way that we need to to last 100
years Mike do you believe in an end game
for insurance can we figure it out final
IDE Insurance curve is it important for
moneyers to avoid touching the insurance
curve yeah so I I do think it's um it's
a tough trade-off to make because money
I think does depend on having strong
assurances about the asset itself right
like the first thing we talked about was
the total Supply it has changed over
time the issuance rate we went from 5
eth to 3 e to two um I'm not sure if
it's possible to find an ideal curve I
think it's an important question that
hopefully more macroeconomics people
will help help us think through um but I
do think there um the risks of not
touching the curve potentially outweigh
the benefits of having um kind of not
touched it if we don't in in that case
so it's kind of a non-answer but I think
we should at least kind of walk through
the analysis of what's the risk of
touching it like how does that impact
the credible neutrality of the total
asset itself versus the kind of risks of
not changing it which is are um you have
a very high stake rate you potentially
have a single dominant LST um there's
like there's many trade-offs and I think
it it's hard to say um without a longer
Forum yeah if e is pericial as money why
do we need
Bitcoin I think Bitcoin serves a role as
kind of pet rock right you you sit and
you hold it under your bed and it
doesn't do anything but you know that
like it's it's very stable but I think
eth kind of represents something more
Dynamic and I do think scaling the L1 in
some capacity to make sure that we kind
of have the have the strong um the
strong settlement assurances and
property rights for eth and it's still
valuable to to interact with it on the
L1 but also scaling it out to to rollups
and validium make it a much more kind of
useful uh interactive asset than than
Bitcoin itself when my
burn um I I don't
know I'll defer that one to barnab
maybe well for the last question to wrap
up I think the audience wasn't happy
with my answer so for Mike what is the
ticker the ticker is
eth Mike thank you so much thank
everyone for joining this session we
will be back in five four four minutes
actually for another session so time to
quickly grab a Cofer take some air and
we'll be back
[Music]
all right good afternoon everybody the
afternoon slump are we awake hands up if
you're
awake yeah yes thank thank goodness
right so this is the start of the real
world ethereum track we have got four
awesome presentations focusing on the
Practical applications that are going to
make the world a better place something
I'm very passionate about my name is
Mark Pascal uh from the wellbeing
protocol uh I sound like an Englishman
but living in New Zealand have we got
any kiwis in the audience yes yes we all
know each other there very few people
there cool so we've got a panel first uh
three awesome people uh ethereum real
world economy uh now the infrastructure
has been built the exciting bit starts
and we can start to do some really
interesting things we can start to build
an economy so this panel is going to
give us a chance to go a bit deeper from
uh three awesome people so do you guys
want to come up on stage we
have they'll introduce themselves
properly we got DC Posh Liam horn and
Tim
boo over to you
guys thank you
nice welcome wow really great seeing
everyone um so we're going to do this
panel about real world ethereum and I
think this is a topic that's close to
all of our hearts here um and we're at
really interesting time for it you know
like there's like big things that are
happening we're going to talk about
there's sort of accelerating adoption of
ethereum as the world's settlement layer
there's you know big like actors from
outside of ethereum coming in and like
using it launching staple coins launch
all kinds of things and so we're going
to talk about those things and like what
it means for us and and how we can like
you know what needs to happen to like
bend that towards the the the best sort
of end of the space of
outcomes um let's kick it off with
introductions so we'll go around and say
who we are and we're going to say what
sort of real world ethereum means to
us uh yeah Tim do do you want to kick us
off sure um hi everyone my name is Timo
I work at the ethereum foundation the
main thing I do there is run what are
called the alord devs calls where we
discuss potential changes to the
ethereum protocol and so as part of that
um I have a good view into like what can
we actually do on ethereum what how the
road map is going to evolve and also
sort of the softer cultural norms around
like how we want develop the protocols
things that have been important and how
that's shifted over
time sweet uh my name is Liam horn I'm
one of the co-founders of e Global and
optimism and longtime kind of ethereum
developer um I'm really excited about
kind of the topic of ethereum real world
because having now worked on this stuff
for nearly a decade uh it's become very
important to kind of see how it's going
to get into the hands of real world
people you know it's still not the case
that I can tell my mom what I I work on
and she understands it is still very
esoteric and I'd love to get to the
point in time where uh everyone in the
world can see like viscerally how all
the work that we've done here has kind
of changed uh their everyday lives so
that's uh that's where I'm coming at it
from and ideally espousing the ethereum
values that we've been working on and
not just you know uh a relic of history
of all this cool stuff we're
doing yeah so my name is DC Posh and I'm
building
so um you know we sort of started
with something that is like looks and
feels like like a global venmo and usdc
now we're working on you know something
that's a universal crypto checkout it's
like take any action by by paying with
whatever crypto you have to like do a
deposit do anything on ethereum um but
I've been interested I've cared about
like blockchain for a really long time
about ethereum and and really like what
what motivates me about it what I think
some of the things we're going to talk
about today
like there there's this shape that
happens to cyber Punk or cyppher Punk
Technologies where um a lot of a lot of
times you have sort of this recurring
pattern uh of you know people invent
something and it's new and exciting and
it has some liberatory properties it
lets people do things that they couldn't
do before and then there's this sort of
period of conflict um
where the technology grows sort of
fitfully and and it has it you butt
heads with with you know incumbents and
with governments and with regulatory um
and a lot of the time when it turns into
something that
has you know big adoption something that
really wins the the the final product
ends up looking very different um or
significantly different from the
original vision and it embodies some
kind of compromise and and you know I I
think this idea of
like like liberatory software is
something that that been you know
motivating for like many of us for a
really long time and and so I think
we're going to dive into like uh you
know how we
can basically be like you know like
pragmatic and optimistic about what's
coming and and and still like bend it
towards those goals that makes sense um
let me do briefly sort of the shape of
what we're about to do so we're going to
talk about we're have the first section
where we're going to talk about what's
happening uh right now um I think
there's actually more of it than is
widely appreciated because this is sort
of stuff from outside the tech this is
and from you know uh fintech trafi Black
Rock all of these kinds of things big
like you know forces of adoption that
are happening and what what's about to
happen then in the second section we're
going to talk about sort of what can we
learn from history
and uh you know what sort of the space
of possible
outcomes and then the last part we're
going to talk about uh what needs to
happen today and what's our calls to
action
um yeah let's let's Dive Right
In
so Liam do you want to kick us off with
you know sort of the first part of you
know you you actually for people who
don't know so like a big part of what uh
you know even inspired this panel was uh
an article that uh Liam wrote a year ago
about like making sense of tether on
Tron and you know like mapping out
what's happening with stable coins right
now yeah do you want to tell us about
that yeah and by the way uh we have this
uh list of questions in front of us also
so I encourage you guys to like through
out the kind of panel if you have
questions throw them on upvote them uh I
think it would be great to get to the
point where like we're really kind of
touching on a lot of the subjects you
guys are most interested in um um but
yeah okay so I guess uh a little bit of
a recap who is here for the talk that I
gave yesterday just so I can have some
context of like roughly who knows what
okay so I'll share a little bit about
what I shared yesterday um so like uh DC
alluded to I wrote an article um earlier
this year called making sense of tether
on Tron the um the reason why was that I
was asking myself you know where do
people use ethereum in the real world
who has a wallet who's sending payments
around um you know DC built this app
called Doo which which he mentioned to
let folks like us that are at ethereum
conferences like very easily move money
around um and we asking this question
who else around the world is going to do
that and when you look at the data like
that's kind of crazy fact is that the
vast majority of that kind of activity
where it's happening is like using
tether on Tron um often times even like
through a binance account or like
literally through binance moving tether
and Tron around uh in places that are
not not you know with with westers
basically and the crazy thing is it's
kind of you can almost look at like a
failure of our space that um we built
all this incredible decentralization
technology decentralized stable coins
decentralized block bace like censorship
resistant and like the biggest use case
is like people move moving like a
completely centrally controlled sort of
opaque Shadow banking um Empires token
around on a chain run by like one guy
basically
uh and that's just like like ludicrous
and so uh we was trying to understand
how did how did we get to this point in
history uh and where are we going to go
from here and when when looking that up
there there's a lot of history you can
you I can talk about and I'm not going
to go into all of it as to how we got
here but when you look at when you look
into it um you notice that the St this
this adoption how we've gotten to this
point where so many folks are using
stable coins um it hasn't been it all
sort of related to the the booms and the
the busts of the crypto market we've
gotten to a point now where consistently
for five straight years uh there have
been just more and more people um uh
more and more volume more and more
transactions all just up and to the
right consistently using stable coins um
and this has been really interesting
because it's like one of the few Trends
in our industry that's not completely
sort of like speculative and bubble
driven um and that was really exciting
and it led me to ask a question like
where is this going to go um and my
observation was that there's uh enormous
of Industry that's being built around
the use cases that stable coins enable
and uh one really uh important element
of it is that it's not just that people
use stable coins to say go into a
blockchain hold it self custodial or put
it into a pool on defi it's actually
become like a payment rails where you
can sort of load up money into crypto uh
Transit it into a stable coin move it
from one account to another and then
load it out of crypto and that doesn't
always get reflected in the supply
metrics but it becomes a way for you to
like move money across the world uh and
that is going that is growing extremely
fast um I mentioned the on the
presentation yesterday that this company
Bridge which is effectively wrapping
that with an API it's a tiny like I
think one and a half year old company
was acquired by stripe for $1.1 billion
like three weeks ago and the reason why
is they've found that trend of how
people are using tether and Tron all
these countries to move move money
around they've realized how important
that's going to be for the future of
money they've apied it and you know the
biggest payments processor on the
internet stripe realized this is a
threat uh and something they really need
to get on top of and bought it for like
you know I think a 500x multiplier um so
anyway I don't want I don't want to go
on too long of a rant here but the point
is stable coins seem to be really damn
important um and if we're as an industry
trying to build for this use case we
should be hyper aware of it and make
sure that the technology doesn't get too
um Left Behind history to what might be
the sort of these centralized players
not adhering to the decentralized value
so so that's kind of like my my stable
coin angle
basically nice yeah um yeah if any of
you are curious Liam's done some really
great writing on this topic with all of
the the charts and the data and the the
information behind it uh yeah Tim do you
want to tell us about uh like what
um let's see what we have here uh yeah
do you want to tell us about about big
things that you see happening so like
Beyond just stable coins around you know
like Innovation prediction markets and
things like that sure um so I think
another way to think about like the real
world value of ethereum is are there
things that we can do on ethereum that
just not possible anywhere else in the
world um it's almost like a depth versus
bread thing so on one hand ethereum is
like this amazing distribution platform
it allows you to get uh Financial assets
and financial products and a bunch of
other things like ID entity um to a wide
range of users that like trfi can't get
um but there's also a sense in which
ethereum is a sorry there's also a sense
which ethereum is able to like enable
new things that just yeah did not exist
so two examples I really like here are
prediction Market quadratic Ving um both
of these things were effectively
theorized decade or so ago and never
quite had like a place to be
instantiated in the world before
ethereum and the fact that we you know
were able to ship quadratic funding
first on gitcoin um and prediction
markets first on like Veil or auger
means that like the the world now has
these things I did not have before right
and I think prediction markets is
probably the clearest example where the
First iterations on ethereum were like
not super popular they were quite Niche
products never quite reach product
Market fit um but then uh um prediction
markets in this last uh the last year or
so have become like this huge cultural
thing um and so ethereum was really like
a Neer there does anyone here remember
augur or
Veil yeah um and and yeah it's kind of
wild that like you know without ethereum
we wouldn't have had augur and
ostensibly without auger I don't know
that you could have had something like
poly Market exist um and similarly I
think if you look at something like
gitcoin and the quadratic funding rounds
it's like on one hand it's it's very
nice that we get to allocate all this
money to public goods in crypto but I
think the broader impact there is we get
to see okay does like QV actually work
in practice and can we tweak it can we
improve it so I think that's another
huge part of like how you can get Real
World Adoption is are there just ideas
where they're not possible anywhere else
in
ethereum yeah nice yeah 100% um I think
poly markets really woken a lot of
people up to this about okay you know
there are things where where having a
permissionless rail a global rail is
actually pretty incredible advantage and
it lets you move faster and bigger than
than anything else
um and there's this like question I
think is like really worth for everyone
to think about about like like okay like
what is the like next one two and three
things that that feel like
that um you know one other thing when
we're talking about so this first
section is about like what's happening
right now right what's like you know
what's happening right now and what's
what's like coming in the immediate
future I think one of those relates to
this like spicy first question up here
about like oh it's the next uh billion
people are are exit liquidity some kind
of mean um could we uh can we get the
the slides actually there's there's a
chart that I was going to put up here a
funny
one I figure out which way it goes next
oh yeah um you know and it relates to
this kind of thing that I think is also
really worth people like internalizing
at least this possibility around you
know there's this like funny chart that
people have been pointing at for a long
time that's kind of like the zoomed out
log chart of price and a lot of it so
far there's this second chart here
that's much less flattering that I'm
about to to show and this is you know
about like
actual this is about you know roughly
usage right this is this is people
searching for how to install relevant
apps you know metamask binance coinbase
and you can see for like you know
there's been these past waves of
adoption that have each been centered
around like a new speculative asset
class there was an altcoin wave around
2011 that was sort of inspired by
Bitcoin a lot of clones of Bitcoin there
was one uh that was sort of the Ico wave
around 2017 that was inspired by
ethereum um and then there was the
latest one that that had Defi and then
then
nfts
and um I I think the thing the thing I
would would would leave you guys with I
think there like that there's an
excellent chance that the next big wave
of crypto adoption will feel very
different from those so if it if it does
turn out that the next big wave of
crypto adoption is centered around you
know stable coins and you know uh like a
lot of these these more sort of real
world organizations we about to talk
about like you know like adopting the
chain as a settlement layer um that
doesn't necessarily have this kind of
like spiky shape and it's something that
could look and feel a lot more like a
regular technology adoption scurve so
instead of having something that goes up
and back down in terms of actual usage
you have something that has you know
early adopters and late adopters and and
and works that way um which on the one
hand is super exciting like that's like
what um we've been looking for and on
the other hand I think it it comes with
interesting new risks yeah I have I have
one also like kind of take on this which
is um if one way of looking at like the
the the booms and the busts uh on on
this uh that prior graph is that we have
sort of gotten like progressively less
sophisticated in our ability to create
assets for people to speculate on uh
like in the beginning this was like
future of Finance like sort of utility
tokens uring value um in really like you
know interesting economic ways there was
white papers with economic analysis and
you know you could come up with a theory
of how the thing might be valued and
then the second wave we had sort of like
these um art like digital art nfts and
it's like you know art subjective there
some value there's an art Market it kind
of makes sense and now we're kind of in
a phase where it's like these are memes
it doesn't have value that's the whole
point it's just like we like them and
they go up and I don't know how much
progressively more dgen we can get and
so in in terms of like is like the the
billion our exit liquidity um my take on
that is that we've sort of like
exhausted the ability to create these
sort of speculative assets and uh we
kind of need to like actually build
build real now and that that people
can actually use in their everyday lives
and so uh it's actually more of like a
turning point for the industry where um
if we don't do that people are going to
lose interest because there's not going
to be that much more to speculate on so
you know I know there's some people that
are like super pro meme coin it's like a
really new way to think about value in
society but personally I'm I'm more like
Pro substance and real value um you know
helping people in their lives and I
think that that as an industry we need
to kind of focus on that
yeah totally you know one other really
fun thing about this sort
of chart which I think is like a loose
proxy for like installs um is you see
this interesting Divergence over on uh
you know after the the most recent wave
where you know after that the the for
example after the Ico wave it's quite
sad you see all of these things go back
you know they round trip to zero and
after the most recent one there's you
know the the binance app has a much like
higher sort of like new Baseline than
than the other two and you know this I
think relates exactly to the thing that
that Liam was talking about earlier with
binance tether and Tron it's of the
three this you know it's the only one
that's of these at least of these three
it's the only one that is widely used
for stable coin transactions um and you
know we saw this we we did trips to
places that have poor banking systems
poor currencies um
to Turkey to Argentina uh talk to a lot
of people and there's a surprising
amount of people there that are
basically using the binance app as their
Bank um which I think is like both it's
it's another case of this it's it's
promising and it's also a challenge for
ethereum because you know there's
there's work to do to upgrade can I ask
question actually have any was anyone
here at Dev connect I think in eastanbul
somewhat recently yeah did anyone see
the tether stores
one guy like there in eastanbul there
were literally shops you could go to in
like the Grand Bazaar and big a big
tether logo and you could walk in and
give them cash and they they would send
you tether on like on Tron uh and you
could go in also and you can give them
tether on Tron or you actually they also
supported ethereum which was nice but um
most people we we pulled them uh we we
walked into these stores pulled them and
asked them like why are you here and
like there was you know all kinds of use
cases you wrote a blog post about that
ask do you want to like share like some
of those learnings yeah yeah um yeah so
my my my co-founder Nan wrote a post
called Cash to chain Istanbul that is uh
you know about some of this it's it's
it's very fascinating
um you know and maybe this touches a
little bit on the second question that
was up on the questions board earlier um
which by the way I think we can go back
to the the questions
leaderboard
uh where the second one was was about
like
when when can we buy coffee right uh I
think both in terms of what we're seeing
right now you know like sort of like the
the uh early pirate prototype of this
with bance tether and Tron in in these
countries with with uh you know where
where the the need for it is bigger and
then also the big wave of it that's
that's that's currently Brewing where
you know like PayPal is launching their
own stable coin and revolu and like
Robin Hood just announced on all those
kinds of things both of those things I
think are going to be focused on use
cases like like you know dollar global
settlement for things that are that are
sort of higher value use cases than
things like buying coffee if you're
standing in you know in front of a like
a physical location uh you can just use
the local cache it's more things like
you know like Global USD savings uh like
International checkout um you know
things like like uh like poly Market
that have an international component to
them um it's it's things like that where
you kind of need you know like these
like new greased rails um uh more so I
think than than like uh you know
personal P2P payments curious curious
what what your guys is take is on
that have a strong opinion
um yeah so I was actually looking at the
question on the top um around what like
real world functions are there that uh
are not on ethereum that should be um
and one thing I've been thinking about
with uh you know you mentioned the the
tether versus Tron versus ethereum thing
is um how like should we think about
ethereum being different than those
things right like is there is there
something about ethereum that's like
more useful to people than Tron or or
tether or you know like a b chain and um
ostensibly one of the things we care
about in the Ean Community is like
longevity
as in like the change should stay around
for a long period of time um and so one
thing I think that like would be nice to
to see the space move towards in terms
of like non-speculative use cases is are
there things with like longer time
Horizons that we can start putting on
ethereum um to sort of build sort of a
collective culture that like okay
there's stuff on this that's really
valuable that we cannot break and sort
of forces us to build for like a more
sustainable like future um one trick
real example um is I don't know if
people know the website like long
bets.com it's like people can bet on
something that will resolve in like 10
20 years and it's usually quite small
amounts like hundreds maybe low
thousands of dollars um but this is like
a perfect use case for a smart contract
right like you could say 10 years from
now if x happens you know person a gets
the money if y happens person b gets the
money and I think this is like one thing
I would I would encourage people to
think about when you're thinking of what
parts of like an economy or like of a
company or something you want to put on
chain is are there things we can put
that need to have like a really high uh
level of durability far into the future
um and there kind of a self-fulfilling
prophecy aspect there and then if people
can like trust that ethereum is around
10 years in the future 20 years 100
years um I think it starts to answer a
lot of these questions around just like
okay why would you use like ethereum
over these other things it's you know
this thing will still be there and
there's a sense which so far this has
been the case you know we talk about
whatever chains today and there's a
bunch of chains we talked about 5 years
ago that just don't exist anymore or
effectively like totally um irrelevant
so yeah like I don't have a great
example Beyond long bet now but um this
is really the big question for me is
like yeah something that has like a 10
plus year time Horizon can we put that
on chain and use that uh obviously to
fulfill that use case but also to like
signal that there's this like deep
reliability and this commitment to
actually having things stick around long
term yeah totally that actually Segways
nicely you know this is like Josh
Stark's idea of hardness and and you
know like ethereum is something that
provides you know like a global
settlement layer that that has sort of
Maximum possible hardness um uh if we're
talking about things that are happening
today just to like close out this first
section you know we have stable coin
adoption um the tech is kind of ready
right now we have like 1 cent 1 second
transactions on rollups and I think that
combined with sort of like the physics
of staple coins where where they're
produce yield for the issuer they give
international access has made them sort
of irresistible for like a lot of these
like um you know existing organizations
where we talked about like PayPal
revolute and all those but it's also
exactly what you were just saying where
it's like hardness there's probably a
reason why there's like an ethereum ETF
but not like a Tron ETF like there's
like an element of this thing is going
to be around forever that doesn't always
apply to everywhere else
um I can one thing on that which is that
um uh to to some extent like ethereum's
value being hardness like in other words
is like ethereum is reliable like you
know it's going to be around for a long
time and you know that you're not going
to get your money taken away it's kind
of because the the collective kind of
like um process of how blogs are
generated is so robust that it's just
like it's it's it's hard it's reliable
you know you're not going to lose your
money I think that's one of the things
that in terms of like risks of how we
could end up in kind of a more
centralized World um we can s of think
about is if we end up in a world where
let's say PayPal here it's a stable coin
um that everyone uses to the PayPal app
uh if that's a thing that can be kind of
like rugged and like taken away from you
that would be like not good for for an
end user and so there there's a lot of
questions around how exactly will that
will the world look like when more and
more companies kind of issue stable
coins and more people are holding stable
coins as a form of money um I think
actually Tim you gave a good example
earlier today when you were saying that
like your bank in Canada um uh you told
you to deposit money in but then it said
if you want to withdraw it out you can
only do 5,000 per day and so it's kind
of like similar to like an optimistic
rollup that's doesn't disclose the fact
that you know you can't withdraw all
your money you got to wait like several
days um and I think that's an example of
a thing where we as an industry can set
what are the what are the things that we
must know to be true in our money um and
we can make sure that those principles
those values are adhere to by the new
people coming into this space so a
PayPal USD you know instead of it being
issued on some random chain that you
don't have any trust guarantees around
at any moment it could go away it's
issued on ethereum it's auditable it's
traceable you know there's kind of
certain social principles around how you
keep it I think that you know this this
element of how does ethereum keep its
values to be maintained as the
technology gets adopted is a very
important sort of topic totally and I
think on that point um when we think
about like uh within the ethereum
community we've done a decent job of
trying to segment like what are the
things we want to see like with rollups
most notably we say okay like stage zero
stage one stage two and using this like
terminology we can create like a
shelling Point saying like we're going
to direct the rollups energy to build
these types of thing and I think we we
sort of Miss something like that in
terms of like real world applications um
because even before this panel I was
trying to think like what does it mean
to like use ethereum you know like
there's a very narrow sense in which
it's like okay you just hold the asset
and then when you're like standing your
stand up a stable coin on ethereum like
okay it uses the gas on ethereum and
then there some question here is about
like non-financial use cases so if you
just have something that you know you've
registered an identity once on ethereum
for like a hundred years um and you sort
of never touched a chain again are you
like using etherium and so I think this
is something that uh I'd love to see
sort of the community come up with but
it's almost like a tax taxonomy of like
what are the ways people use ethereum
and then of those ways what are like the
different trust assumptions and the
different like affordances that people
should think about um and I think once
we have those labels um and again like
rups is probably the best example but um
yeah it sort of helps people then frame
their work um and my sense is when you
think of like the value stuff around
like okay the people in the future won't
have like the same values as the people
of today and that's that that'll be
somehow bad um it feels like it's rarely
malicious like most people I speak to
like come and they want to try to build
the right thing for ethereum based on
their understanding of it and they
obviously like may have different values
and there's like conflict around that
but if we can have like these shelling
points where like someone is saying like
oh I want to build like an identity app
on ethereum and we can just be like hey
here's like you know a stage two for
like an identity app it should do X Y
and Z it you know the issuer should have
like these rights but like these guard
rails um then you can like guide people
who come in with good intentions to sort
of respect the the values or stick to
the values in a way that doesn't feel
super adversarial which is like oh you
know you believe something different
than us and we're going to try to like
shift your product road map um so yeah
it would be amazing to see like more of
that on like the social and use cases
side yeah so we talked a bit about like
you know like what's happening now um
let's do the section on like what we can
learn from history what we can learn
from history and like what are the you
know to your point just now about like
we should have high standards like what
are the like you know
uh like given that this big thing is
happening and and all of these big
organizations are sort of piling into
ethereum as a settlement layer like what
are the better and worse outcomes within
that space and how can we we and then in
the last section we can talk about like
you know our calls to action like how we
can bend things towards towards the
better end of that um yeah let's start
with the risks I
guess yeah I mean one one example um
earlier today I spoke to someone that
was interested in basically trying to
stable coinify Japan was actually a very
really interesting project um and the
default approach they were thinking
about doing it with was by kind of
launching um a brand new L1 you know a
brand new sort of system completely
Sovereign independent from ethereum um
and just using ethereum purely for its
um software layer um because it's you
know it's a very useful way of kind of
getting a blockchain up and running and
you know the idea was using a small
number of validators to set it up and I
was really strongly advocating for like
no dude like this is why we built l2s
you can make it as a rollup because if
you do that um you get to benefit from
the ethereum consensus the kind of the
incredibly neutral block space uh while
still being able to go to Japan and
stable coinify the country and you know
it it it seemed to me that in response
to that his reaction was a lot more you
know actually that kind of makes sense
it's a techn technology uh
technologically it's a good solution we
might as well do that it saves us a lot
of the headache of having to set up our
own validate our set but we can still do
decentralized sequencing and like the
the point of this was that through
making ethereum easy to interact with
and interoperate with we can get more of
these sort of use cases that people want
to use blockchains and stable coins for
broad into the ethereum fold um and in
terms of like how that relates to the
risks if ethereum is not at all thinking
about how do we integrate with these use
cases we're going to end up with a big
kind of Frankenstein machine that
doesn't actually work for people that
want to leverage stable coins and so on
um but if we are really receptive to the
use cases and we build it you know
through things like scalability
interoperability will make it a very
attractive kind of central point for
people to inter inter integrate with um
so yeah I just with regards to risks the
biggest risk I think is that we're just
like not focusing on the use cases um
you know I often meet folks in this in
the space that are like the types of
things in their heads of what people are
going to use ethereum for are just like
so far gone from the reality um when the
reality is staring Us in the face you
can look at the gas metrics every day
and you can see what people use this
thing for we have to like not not forget
that um for example it's been a great
thing that the ethereum foundation is
really into defi recently because you
know 95% plus of the gas fee revenue is
from
defi yeah I think one risk that's really
worth drilling on is a lot of this new
wave of like Financial adoption of
ethereum is centered around real world
asset-backed stable coins so
uh like H how many people have here have
heard of d
most perfect how many people here have
heard of Ry right perfect and we love
these things and they have you know a
few percent of the the market cap of
like usdc and usdt and
uh I think there's a really interesting
like sort of space of possible outcomes
there some of which are really nice and
some of which are really quite bad
around uh you know we're going to have
like more and more of the world's
activity happening on these these tokens
currently the way they're built is kind
of um you know right in the middle like
they're they're permissionless by
default which is fantastic it's what
lets people build things like poly
Market on top of usdc but they have a
centrally operated Blacklist and there's
tail risks that come with that um so
yeah I I think it'd be interesting to
talk about like like you know like what
are the assets that are at the center of
this and you know like how what are like
the better and worse outcomes there
yeah I think kind of what we were
talking about earlier like the sort of
labeling around different stages um
there's a sense in which U you know usdc
being uh effectively uh controlled by
singer issuer is bad because they can
Blacklist your coins um but it's net
better than a bank because it's like
transparent on chain you can use it and
whatnot and it's probably you know
somewhat worse than die because you know
there's like more of a of a control
there um and so I think this is
something as well that like within the
Community we need to I don't know agree
on is are we fine with like facilit
facilitating a lot of things that are
like net improvements for the status quo
in the worlds even though they're you
know not fully um not fully
permissionless or not fully transparent
to the same extent that something like
that's purely built on chain is um I
think you see this over and over like
you know we talk about assets but um I
was talking with the founder of uh Eve
uh who announced that uh the sort of
physics for their next version is going
to be on ethereum and we were talking
about you know how they should go about
upgrading the contracts for the game and
one thing you said is like paraphrasing
is it's actually not the most important
thing how you upgrades because most
video games are just a complete Black
Box and going from like the code for the
games a complete blackbox that there's
something public is already like most of
the value and then you know whether you
have a multisig a delay or whatever it's
like it's kind of like an incremental
gain from there so my sense is like
there's a lot of real world use cases
that almost look like
bad if you take like a blockchain first
perspective because they have all these
trusted failure points um but they are
like a significant Improvement to the
status quo because just the rest of the
world doesn't operate this way um so
yeah we we should I think we should
welcome those and it's like a very
valuable way to leverage ethereum's
impact in the world and to the extent
that we can then like giving them a
terminology of like okay this is like a
stage Zero game on ethereum or this is
like a stage zero asset um that's
extremely valuable because if they then
want to go further down the rabbit hole
they have like a clear road map to do so
that's been informed by sort of the
ethereum values rather than their
perception of what that
is yeah yeah I would strongly agree with
that and with regards to stable coins in
particular there's this really good
website I think it's is it blue chip.
org yeah how many people here have been
to Blue chip.
org oh only a handful yeah go to Blue
chip. org um you know I think we're
going to get to this in very soon and
when we talk about our like call to
action like what needs to happen next
section um but I think those kinds of
things that are providing like you know
active sort of drill down transparency
um are are going to be really
important yeah it it plays into the
question of like how does that
technology get adopted we were saying
earlier like if we as a community can
articulate clearly what are the things
we need to be true and in the case of a
disabled coin it's like you know that
the the reserves are fully backed that
it's visible where they are it's
traceable like we want this thing to not
be ruggable like with regards to a
blacklist you know we want to understand
you know to what extent that thing is
being abused or maybe we don't want that
at all like we have to articulate these
things and then it makes sure that
within the protocols we espouse and make
popular we kind of make sure those
things are used I think it's very
important you had a really like
thought-provoking take um you know this
morning around the idea of like a white
list as opposed to a blacklist staple
coin do you want to talk about that a
bit yeah like I I think that it's pretty
it seems very likely to me that there
are going to be stable coins um that are
issued from consumer finex so for
example a PayPal coin that I've said a
couple times um in some sense you can
think of circle kind of like a coinbase
coin because you know Circle owns a a
big uh coinbase owns a big chunk of
circle um and I think there's going to
be a lot of these examples of these
coins issued by kind of consumer fintex
and the thing for them is it's really
important that they adhere to
regulations otherwise they're not going
to do it so it might be the case and
this is just you know I'm just kind of
theorizing that they actually have more
of like a list uh where the only way you
can access this coin is if you're kind
of already an existing customer if
they've kyed you and so on that's like
maximally compliant but obviously that's
not very you know Cipher Punk um but
maybe it's actually possible that you
know these sorts of coins might still
exist but instead of them being black
listable they're wh listable but you can
always exit um and that gives you this
interesting property where it's very
much more like a regulated Financial
product that these companies already
familiar with offering but you're adding
this new feature to it which is the
ability to exit into crypto crypto um
and to some extent that's one of the
major value props of stable coins
already just the ability to have it be
portable so this is like it's a product
in the direction of make it regulated
make it familiar and make it something
people already want but add in a bit of
crypto flare so that it's ejectable into
the ethereum kind of uh block space so
what are the kinds of products we can
build like that I guess totally yeah I
think that's a perfect segue too you
know uh we have like 15 minutes left so
I think it's a perfect segue to the to
our last section is going to be about
like our calls to action I mean um I I
think what one thing that that sort of
like thought experiment really sort of
illustrates too is how much the devil is
in the details like it's the the outcome
is not going to be like total Cipher
Punk Victory it's probably also not
going to be like total trafi Victory and
like ethereum just gets subsumed somehow
right it's going to be something that
you know uh like a lot of interesting
things are happening at the margins and
you know uh like I I think ethereum is
adding a lot of freedom to the world no
matter what but there are outcomes that
that result in a lot more of that versus
others um like one really interesting
version of what you're talking about
where it's like you know on the surface
for example like a whit list stable coin
is actually like much worse and more
dystopian than like a blacklist stable
coin but on the flip side if you had one
that has like okay you need a kyc to
like receive py USD um or to to do
something along those lines but like to
to to send it um uh you can you have
like this permissionless exit like even
if you get removed from the white list
in some ways that is more like
permissionless than something like usdc
where if you land on The Blacklist then
you can't do anything with it anymore
the balance is just gone um
so yeah let's dive into like the the uh
the what needs to happen next call the
future or call to action part um
yeah yeah Timmy like in in in in your
view like what what what should we be
doing I think we should be more
ambitious than stable coins um so I
think uh stable coins are great but you
can think of them as effectively like a
distribution channel for like Fiat right
like and um there's a lot of good stuff
you can build with that um and there's a
way in which stable coins are like
thinking of okay how can like we get
ethereum out into the world and sort of
push it around the different users um
one thing I'd like to see more of is
like are there things we can do to pull
the world into ethereum and sort of make
ethereum sort of a more of a dependency
in some important way and that's like
providing value that nothing else in the
world can um one example I like to think
about for this is you know SpaceX is the
only company in the world that has
reusable Rockets um this means the
rocket launching costs are like much
much cheaper than others and the entire
sort of Industry will then reorient
around that and be like okay like
they're able to do this thing that no
one else can and that unlocks a whole
new set of Industries and there's a lot
of people working on ethereum a lot of
very smart people and my sense is
there's probably some like SpaceX
reusable Rockets level of thing we can
build that then means that like people
will use ethereum because it's the only
thing in the world that provides that
and my sense is to to the to date what
we've seen with things like polymar poly
market and gitcoin uh quadratic funding
is um we have these like economic
constru that are maybe a bit too risky
for like traditional allocators like if
you're a government you're not just
going to swap everything over at the
quadratic Ving overnight and ethereum
has been like an interesting playground
or almost like a test net for those
people um I think the poly Market case
is almost more some sort of like legal
Arbitrage where like it was just
impossible to do outside of crypto and
and that created like a way to do it um
but those feel kind of like weak Moes in
a way where you know you can fix this
and you can you know make predictions
markets legal and just have them on like
whatever Robin Hood um I think uh I
think the quadratic funding example is a
bit stronger because it's actually like
you have to want to do this and you have
to test it um but this is really the
thing I I I would try to think about in
terms of like real world applications
not as much can we just like export a
bunch of things into the world using
ethereum as distribution but can we
build something on ethereum that's so
valuable that makes people sort of come
to use the chain um and and and you know
actually provide significant value in a
differentiated way to uh the rest of the
world yeah that's really you know it's
really interesting like when at the
beginning we were talking about what
tends to happen to you know Cipher Punk
Technologies at scale and you if you
look at what happened for example to um
you know pgp versus what happened to bit
Tor versus what happened to bitcoin um
you know the the thing you're talking
about which is like how can like
ethereum be uniquely valuable so that
like all of these sort of you know
institutions that are coming in and like
oh we want to do you know like global
settlement like
basically etherum is like the
only responsible option right um there's
an interesting element to this so
like pgp for example
um initially like there was a big fight
with the government about whether
encryption was even allowed at all then
they won that fight then there was
signal there's mostly much bigger
audience but still like sort of Center
on enthusiasts and now we have like Mass
adoption of end to end encryption via
like WhatsApp via iMessage there's an
asterisk on these things but one
interesting way that this came to be is
that you know apple and Facebook some of
these big organizations decided that
actually end encryption is in their
Interest being able to go to a regulator
and say actually like we don't have
these messages was in their interest and
like that's actually really to the
extent that ethereum becomes that it's
very powerful and then you know
conversely you look at how many people
here have heard
of um uh Daniel e
actually oh like a a few a handful So
Daniel e is the founder CEO of Spotify
he was previously the CEO of uTorrent
which is one of the big torrent clients
and I think that's sort of an example of
like this going this story going less
well you have a cipher Punk technology
it's liberatory it's interesting it's
you know
um something that that is in the user's
control um but it ended up not finding a
way to be valuable to like you know any
of the like bigger organizations in that
space and so they ended up just sort of
like routing around it entirely and
building this thing that's a wall Garden
um so yeah I I think the thing you're
saying about like like find more ways
for ethereum to be like uniquely
valuable like you know to individuals
also to institutions makes a ton of
sense yeah and I want to like amplify a
little bit what you're talking about the
born example is I think it's like really
illustrative of how this technology
adapts um if you if you look in the
early 2000s when torrenting first became
popular like we figured out as a society
how to like share files with each other
you know getting around um sort of like
you know any sort of barriers to do that
and we figured out how to launch a Dap
one of the first daps was bit torrent
basically um and that meant that all of
a sudden now like you know me as like a
kid I could download this thing and I
could start you know basically
downloading movies illegally and uh I
was one of many many people that did
that and it kind of totally shook up the
way that the music industry worked which
is how we ended up with Napster um
because someone realized holy crap the
whole world is now downloading all these
movies on bit torrent let's like just
Blitz scale this this new thing that's
happening in society um but they did it
in a way which was very sort of um not
very friendly to the existing kind of
media landscape uh which is why Napster
kind of eventually got shut down but it
didn't change the fact that bit torrent
existed like since bit torrent existed
you can't you know go back in time it
now it exists it can always get the
movies on Pirate Bay or whatever uh and
that's what I think ultimately was the
thing that put societal pressure to
enable things like Spotify and Netflix
and streaming models I think this is
like a really similar mental model for
what's going on in crypto like the fact
of the matter is now you can move money
around the world uh using an internet
connection that that that that Pandora's
Box has been opened we've seen like the
tethers the binance the trons go and
Blitz scale it out every everywhere in
the world like without thinking about
the regulation or the consequences like
CZ literally went to jail because of
this um but then on the other hand the
cat's out of the bag we're not going to
go back like it doesn't matter what Gary
gendler anyone else says like we're not
going to go back and so you know we need
now as a society to adapt and so I think
in terms of the call to action is that
we need more companies like like a
coinbase that's willing to say hey look
this is going to happen no matter what
you can't stop it let's actually come up
with Frameworks for regulating it and
embracing it in society and doing it
doing it properly because you can't go
back in time but but we need less of the
the bances um but maybe at least more
people that are heavily scrutinizing
them to the point of like the L2 beats
and Blue Chips stuff like that yeah
totally yeah you know on that last note
actually I think we we have we have two
very specific you know like uh prompts
for for for the audience if anyone wants
to to work on something like this um you
know L2 beat is amazing we love L2 beat
Blue Chip is great I think there are a
few more instances of this that are just
missing currently like we currently
don't have anything that is like L2 beat
but for non-custodial wallets and we
don't have anything that's like L2 beat
for custodial apps right I think the
kinds of things you're grading them on
are different like for for non-custodial
there's this big um aspect of like uh
fake self- custody there are companies
out there that are like I won't like
name or roast any of them but there's
several you probably know that are like
oh we're non-custodial also you can
recover your account with sms off and
you know there's so some physics of that
doesn't quite work uh so I think having
some like nice transparency there would
be very like sort of a useful guardrail
and then conversely on the like
custodial side the big question is like
to what extent is there like
permissionless exit in practice you know
um and it it really varies so you know
there's there's like PayPal PUSD we'll
see how that shapes up but hopefully you
can just like send your PUSD to any
address if that happens then you can do
anything else in the extended ethereum
Cinematic Universe from there
um and on the the the bad side you know
if you look at for example the venmo
crypto tab right now it will let you buy
and it will let you sell that's about it
and then if you it does technically have
a transfer button but it requires like a
additional kyc that is so onerous that
I'm pretty sure they don't actually
intend anyone to use that I think they
I'm not sure why they put it there but
yeah I think think something that that
is like L2 beat for wallets both
custodial non-custodial that would be
extremely useful yeah plus won that
there there's a lot of stuff you could
dive into with regards to how these
wallets secure um your assets and even
even like one password and like iCloud
you know these are these are crypto
asset custodians effectively and like
you going to ask yourself how secure is
it really um and I think as we're
entering into a world where um embedded
wallets is becoming a concept which
means you know you are sort of in this
weird gray area where like you kind of
custody your assets but like not really
like we really got to make sure like we
don't screw that up and so an L2 beat
for self custodial or quote unquote
self- custodial wallets would be like
very very valuable if anyone wants to
build that please like you know reach
out like that would be extremely
valuable business and
product yeah do do you have feel like I
already said mine but like something
that's so valuable the world like has to
use it like the equivalent I know maybe
it's like a bank in space or something
like that that runs on ethereum like
having things that just do not exist
anywhere else um yeah yeah totally and
long-term things as well you should
asking questions yeah yeah do quick
questions totally yeah we we have can
buy coffee with crypto already the fees
are 1 cent your coffee is like $4 easy
one but who has bought coffee with
crypto like ever I bought you coffee
with crypto like okay like five 10%
maybe yeah okay okay we should keep
checking on that um I think okay next
one as well uh trafi is only uh
playground for a few million people most
people like the amount of people who've
like bought and sold options in trafi is
also like Millions I think that like
we having the rails of defi is extremely
valuable because it provides a bunch of
financial infrastructure to the average
users stable coins like die is probably
the most simple version of this it's
like a CDP is like a complicated
Financial product but like a stable coin
is very simple so even even if TR or
defi is just used by like a few million
users um if it produces you know
financial services for like hundreds of
millions or billions of people uh that's
quite valuable and I don't think that's
that different than how Finance
works I think that makes sense like um
one one moniker I had for defi last year
was it's kind of like Switzerland in the
sky like it used to be the case that a
lot of like the world's Rich that wanted
to kind of Park their money somewhere
they would go to Switzerland and put it
in like a bank that you know you knew
that the the guy was never going to like
reveal any relationship to the US
government or anything like that I think
defi is kind of that but on a global
scale and via the Internet where it's
maybe not going to be like the thing
that every single person everywhere uses
all the time but it's going to be like
this really high quality place you could
always exit into if you needed to um for
anyone anywhere in the world um and I
think that's a fantastic thing is that
that again it creates this place that's
better than any other alternative and it
is better than any other alternative for
most people in the world um that I think
is going to lift lift everyone else up
in terms of quality of their financial
access I can do a game five one either
have a good game already and don't think
about crypto while you're building it
then at some point add some crypto I
think Eve do as well or do something
from scratch that's Crypton native like
I think uh Dark Forest is probably the
best example we've seen the worst is the
like in between like you're trying to do
a game and you're trying to do crypto
and it don't quite work
well one one other take on gamey that I
heard from the founder of third Weare
but I thought that was pretty apt is
that um we kind of took blockchain
gaming and like just Mega Juiced with
like extra money incentives and his take
was kind of like you know games you you
you shouldn't need to like just juice up
the amount of money you can earn from
playing a game like the whole point of a
game is it's supposed to be addictive in
the first place and it could be the case
that we just got so hyped up about games
on blockchains that we just like threw
all this money and tokens at it but
maybe we kind of lost track of just
making like interesting games in the
first place and I don't know I think
personally like we've kind of overly
linked the concept of blockchains with
the concept of gaming um and it it maybe
confused us a bunch
I don't know what eth in the next five
year means not going to predict the
price non crypto they live people
managing self- custody I think this is
back to what Liam was saying like we
should have different standards that we
apply to different types of wallets um
and ideally each of them are like
relatively sound so that as a non-
crypto person I can be like okay
anything that's like a stage two wallet
is secure and I don't have to like think
about oh the mechanics of how they do
recovery or whether they do recovery or
stuff like
that yeah I mean I have a bit of
a like Riff on that maybe like not the
thing that most people would want to
hear
but I I I think that empirically and
realistically a lot of the people that
are going to gain access to ethereum are
going to be on custodial apps um and you
know like traveling to places like
Argentina and and turkey really
reinforced this is even people who like
have direct experience getting rugged by
their own Banks and they're still like
yeah we love binance we love lemon right
uh and this is I mean I to tell you like
the personal side of this this is this
is what drove like you know us at at da
shifting our Focus from like doo the app
to Doo pay which is like okay you know
ethereum has these magical properties
how do you let people do anything on
ethereum in like one transfer even a
transfer from a custodial app like
someone wants to place a poly Market bet
like how do you do that directly from
binance like send money to an
address um and
so yeah I I I think at the same time
like it's like a critical like back stop
like like the fact that you can like
exit to self- custody is like the
boundary condition that like ensures
freedom for everyone else and so I think
like fighting for like good regulatory
around like self- custody and things
like that is still like extremely
important what do you think I think
we're getting kicked off I see what was
that I think they're kicking us I see I
see I see they're about to they're about
to kick us out well thanks so much for
joining us this was fantastic thanks
thanks everyone yeah thank you thank
both of you thank you DC Liam Tim
awesome conversation and uh case we a
quick break until next session
so while we're just transitioning I
guess my main takeaway was that
economies need strong durable
foundations and we've got plenty of work
to keep strengthening those
foundations okay I'll come back in one
minute
[Music]
all right okay the second session in our
Real World Series
this afternoon we're going to talk about
robots ethereum and
robots how can ethereum be used uh in
this emerging consumer robots industry
fascinating
space before we do that uh did you know
that sitting is the new new smoking so
I'm going to add three minutes to each
of your lives now so what you're going
to do is you're all going to stand up
stand up and you're going to put your
hands up above your head
and you're going to wiggle your bum I
like that you're going to wiggle your
bum just get some
exercise yeah there we go there we go so
you're going to live three minutes
longer now well done okay you can sit
down oh we got some press UPS here
awesome yep that's like 10 minutes extra
you've got there you're going to live
long all right okay so I like to welcome
thz Stang I hope I pronounced his name
right uh thz is a founder of NE mindes
uh core eth developer since uh 2017 and
early member of flash Bots and uh he's
going to talk talk to us about ethereum
and robots so
welcome hi
everyone all right great so let's talk
about the the robots the agents the
ethereum what changes for us the way we
bu build and I think that there are two
Dimensions we've been building for a
long time for this digital simulation
Dimension everything that was about
digital assets and creativity we could
start pricing it and that was our uh
Revolution or Evolution going towards
the new financial markets we disrupted
the financial markets and now let's uh
go to the physical Dimension let's start
treating the physical world and robots
and everything around us the same way as
we treated smart contracts let's start
feeling like we're building something
new again and let's start feeling like
we disrupting again everything around us
and that ethereum once again is the
space for building for Builders and I
don't know which one will be more
infinite is it just the digital space
where you have more space and will be
more valuable or actually when we start
going Beyond with the planets and more
building and maybe Earth is so vast and
robotic is so hard that actually
building and the value that will create
in the real world actually will be once
again much much much more than digital
maybe we'll get bored with digital and
think like finally we have to start
connecting eum with digital
again and all right and I think that's
like one thing that for me seems obvious
now is that uh if we want to go to
robotics with vum we have to start with
agents and um like people from Tesla say
well in the end it doesn't matter
whether you're training the car or the
or the humanoid robot it's just a AI in
the end that will be very important and
whatever the body is it will work which
means like if I'm for people if I have
brains I have brains with whatever the
bodies are uh this is the this is the
power in the world and if we get the
agents right on blockchain they'll get
the robotics then connected to the
agents so you have to start preparing
blockchains for agents and how we'll be
doing that most likely as it already
start nowadays and you see lots of
agentic Frameworks launching on various
blockchains we'll be running the agents
inside at the beginning trusted
execution environment later you'll go
with cryptography they'll be running
with their own Keys they'll be limited
by social media and trying to prove that
they have some kind of human owners uh
they will be starting to make money as
we already see that uh they'll be
abstracting chains without caring about
chain obstruction ux actually they'll be
going for the most efficiency and you
actually will start thinking about no
longer ux matters that much it's just
the efficiency apis and verification um
they will start coding without caring
about the quality of coding materials
and the boot camps and how you train
developers that we just reading formal
specifications and the way you build
chains and communities will change
because the users are no longer your
users it's agents that are users and
customers so it'll be marketing
differently you'll be building
differently and it will be absolutely
roofless efficiency go uh they'll start
auditing themselves they'll start
auditing the smart contracts that
they'll be executing which means that
actually it will be also simpler because
you'll be able to deploy the smart
contracts with a lots of uh supporting
tooling and that supporting tooling will
be using exactly the same uh coding
formal formalizations that you'll do for
training the new agent
and well blockchain was actually very
bad for humans but it will be fantastic
for agents most likely they will be able
to use all the data verify everything
and run autonomously people were not
able to do it we were continuously
wrapping everything that we've built on
blockchains so we're just trusting
something that it's trustless
underneath so it will be all about
integrity agents we'll be checking and
verifying everything all that ZK
efficiency that we're building the speed
to compute co-processors will matter for
agents everything that will matter for
agents will matter for robots because
when they meet together in a physical
space all their protocols will be
verifiable all the diplomacy between the
agents and robots will be verifiable and
yeah Integrity will matter and what will
matter will be the networks blockchain
networks that provide that Integrity so
you look for the Maths for the best
cryptography for the fastest executions
once again ruthless it will not matter
what your business development uh does
it will not matter who you're going to
beers with uh for what events you're
going maybe the events will disappear it
will be all just agents and robots we be
building that we be playing everything
like a game and also leaving fantastic
lives and through that we'll be
disrupting financial markets we've
already done it I mean I feel like this
is almost finished we already feel like
many of us will see how how it will all
move to the uh to the digital space sure
it's still happening around us but
that's exhorted we know it it will
happen the prices are there the
infrastructure is getting there and
we're just like speeding it up a bit but
what happens with the government
disruption it's not really Revolution we
still voting there are still democracies
there is no violence and it's changing
and people doing strange things but why
they're doing that because they can it's
just simpler and simpler to manage the
governments and to do that from the
outside and realizing that all those
machineries are very old and not
efficient you can change it and I think
one thing that we can rely on is that we
can always in the future do something
that the billionaires can do now or you
can do something now that the
billionaires could do a few years ago so
we can play the same toys always so you
look at whatever was available for Kings
or or Reach people in the past you can
do it now which means that whatever
people are playing with now and they're
playing with governments you'll be able
to do that from home from your computer
we'll be building the governments we'll
be building the smart cities we'll be
building the world again and why the
governments will be disrupted because it
just gradually disappear there'll be
less and less people needed to run
everything and the infrastructure will
be automated
itself and how you will exist in all of
this you will feel like oh am I
controlled by Ai and robots no it feel
exactly the same like if nowadays you go
and you see you use public transport you
live in the city you see everything
organized around you sometimes you think
oh there are people around this but
maybe some of those systems were
invented years ago and those people
already not working on it they're
somewhere else the feeling of all of
this was the same it will be just the
same ux we'll be living in the world
around us in the cities we'll be
traveling and all of this will be just
so much more efficient and you'll be
building that with robots around you and
this will be totally normal and totally
Pleasant because it will be so much more
intelligent and everything will be
running on ethereum and when you think
about the fallback of nowadays if you're
flying a plane uh well if if you're
passenger on a plane you have an
autopilot pilot co-pilot there is this
fallback thing and you always think that
there is a person that checks whether
the machine will break but in the world
with agents you'll think like like oh
why the person if we look at the promise
of the robot taxes they don't have wheel
steering wheels anymore why because you
imagine that for the very very efficient
system only agent will be the fallback
for another agent so you no longer even
can expect a person to be equally
efficient with the operations so there
will be no fall back for machines but
there will be no fall back for the
government the agents will be there and
only the combination of agents and
people will be looking and taking craws
over each other and the robots around us
will be autonomous I'm not talking about
humanoid robots any robots machines
combined with the network connecting
with the network sorry and I think that
we'll walk away a bit from the belief
that the code is low the code is low for
some most basic Financial transfers and
payments this is simple but we've tried
over the last years in blockchain in
ethereum in solidity to codify things
that were really not so easy to codify
we try to codify the Govern and the Dow
which try to codify very complex and
fuzzy interactions and those will be
operated by the agents that will be
introducing that fzy assessment and
hallucinations and roles so The
Regulators will be agentic agentic
Regulators will run within the trusted
execution environment around the agentic
markets and agent executing agents
executing and they'll be resolving
disputes uh governance will be executed
like this and rules will not be there
hardcoded in the code and potentially
breaking us forever rules will be there
for the enforcers for the enforcers to
look at it in the fuzzy way and
hallucinate like people always have been
hallucinating and building creative
things and what does it change for the
user interface for trading will you
trade will you actually use blockchains
probably not you'll be using agentic
systems so like robot advisors upgraded
to the agent level and they'll be
executing all the trades for you so you
will have chain abstraction but the
chain abstraction will go even further
you will not use a wallet in the sense
of executing transaction you not even
execute the intense you will execute the
pre-int whatever you will need whatever
you'll think about your life in the
sense of wealth management the agents
will execute for you uh whether it be
mind reading or just analyzing your
conversations from the past or analyzing
your life situation the only thing that
you'll need to know when you wake up in
the morning is like how much money I
have for today's party or for today's
dinner how much money I have for this
month how much money I have for the next
holiday how much money I have to put
aside on the for the retirement and
practically my only choice would be
maybe The Branding of the agents the
system that is delivered to us so that's
what you'll be building for users not
the ux for them to interact but the
system that will be the most efficient
for the agents to decide to use the ones
that will be costing least and they'll
be executing at the lowest cost and
verifiable at the lowest cost and once
again you'll have access to something
that potentially Millionaires
multimillionaires and billionaires have
access to uh very very Advanced
Financial Advisors who are extremely
efficient so no longer you can improve
your financial results by playing the
game you no longer can be better than
the agents so it doesn't matter whether
the chain abstraction ux is good for you
as a user you will not be using the
wallet if you want to play a game and
Gumble you can play a game but it will
be always worse than your trading
abilities very soon so what else will
happen practically those two worlds will
coexist so we'll have the inversion of
thinking of who delivers the value for
whom like you have the digital and
physical world providing interfaces for
each other the agents will be deploying
robots in the physical world just to be
able to execute experiments well
whatever they cannot simulate they have
to experiment with as the same way as we
think that whatever is too expensive for
us to experiment with we have to
simulate so it will be like the two
sides of the of the mirror and the Alis
Wonder way and what else we try to think
about the human identity now and
uniquely identify all of humans with
proof of humanity does it mean that
people will become almost like nfts like
to identify yourself in those
interactions with the uh with the
digital world so we building nowadays
the interfaces for the agents to
interact with the physical world to
deploy robots to landscape everything to
make changes to deploy the government uh
responsibility ities whether it will be
hospitals or Healthcare education or
whatever building building energy uh
sources for themselves will be providing
services for agents so the same way as
you build the blockchain solutions
anything that you Target now you market
for agents you change totally the way
you think about your
customers
and well so that Curiosity for agents of
the physical world will be needed and
the same way I mentioned that so the
services for people will be like when we
ask agents to execute for us there be
the second part of a trade so we trade
something from our world for the
something for from their world we
provide energy will get computation uh
we'll get
intelligence and what the robots what
the robots and agents will care about
like the experiments in the physical
world building something curiosity to
extend beyond what is already known from
the human knowledge energy sources so
nuclear power and so on and so on solar
power wind power uh something more like
on the uh on the scale of the
civilization development compute devices
so building gpus and Beyond maybe
Quantum Computing will they use e or
Bitcoin for all of this most likely uh
your conversations and ideation with
like will the will the cryptocurrencies
be needed for all of this yes as a store
of value for agents and for the digital
assets and it will be very very strange
to expect that this will require the
traditional Finance
and identity of us what will matter the
reputation systems of agents in their
world most likely privacy may disappear
I don't know like so this this is a big
conflict always do we keep introducing
privacy for what for protecting the data
so to take advantage does it mean that
if we introduce privacy then introduce
monopolies I think some of the talks
here were saying exactly that if you
have any private data any private data
Advantage then you introduce monopolies
but if you remove privacy then you have
priv private perfect competition
everyone has access to data it'll be
really hard to remove access to data uh
from the agentic robotic systems they
will be able to observe the world
through the sensors through the access
to all the data in the world and they'll
be able to extract the hidden
information from the surroundings so you
not only will have to hide the
information but also the sources of that
information how you calculated it you'll
be able to like derive and infert the
knowledge from surrounding on the
Privacy data if you remove privacy then
obviously that world will have to be
private on the other side so it will not
be your privacy but whether the privacy
of Agents is uh is protected whether the
humans cannot extract anything from the
agents or agents themselves promise that
they don't act on the Privacy uh on the
on the private data that they extracted
inferred from the knowledge around you
and what will really uh what will really
matter for you on verifying whether you
interacting with another human or agent
probably it will matter in the dating
scenarios but uh maybe not in other
cases and when when will you have to
when will you have to prove that you're
a human probably for the cases when
you'll interact and try to prove to
agents that you're human and for the
universal basic income and we'll start
to building also a bit of universal
basic
robots and even nowadays you already
have studies that say well agents are
better at empathy people prefer the way
they respond to us if we try to be
empathetic so once again I think it's
almost like don't expect that many
events to change your career goals or
professional development you'll be
sitting at home talking to agents and
learning for this way and building and
focusing on your family but the
professional aspect will be there in
your agentic environment or robotic
environment but the social aspect will
stay with you so probably as always in
the past we'll be trading more
efficiency and we'll be regaining some
ways of spending more time focusing on
personal development and family there
will always be the concept of
competition and chasing and thinking
that I want to push even more for
training and for building more who do we
compete with I was thinking about it
when we build robotic systems when we
build agentic systems we continue
competing with with Tesla and Elon Musk
somehow like uh it seems that we we are
aligned that we bring the ideas and it's
just we have this centralized system
that keeps delivering them a bit faster
but I feel like we continuously serve it
a vision we serve the vision of open
data of open source of collaboration we
sered a vision of building building
together and we serve the vision of
autonomous machines and it just keeps
being delivered there so I think that if
we stop serving that Vision it will be
really bad and we have to keep serving
the vision and if we want to keep
serving the vision it means that we
always have to rush building it the way
we want and this is how we set the
culture for the world to
happen and we probably should expect the
same momentum for ethereum as we seen if
you've been 2017 that was like we wanted
to disrupt the financial market so we
started talking and announcing more and
more uh ethereum Alliance building with
the large Enterprises let's do the same
with robotics go and connect with the
companies building robots go and connect
with the company's building agents start
building agents the same way as you were
excited building smart contracts this is
how you change ethereum for the future
and more announcements of connections
between agents and ethereum the more
announcements of the Twitter Twitter
autonomous agents uh trading on ethereum
or robots being built and executed with
ethereum or the coordination of the
physical systems smart cities the more
announcements like this you'll push to
the world the faster it will happen and
the more excitement there will be about
ethereum again and this happens now go
to all of the companies and what will
matter verifiable surveillance sure you
can imagine that systems that will
observe everything in the city and
they'll have only one rule for example
that the moment when there something
really bad happens and name it very
clearly like Let It Be murder only you
want to remove it entirely so you say if
murder happens that's the only situation
when the robots reveals any data that it
collects ever so you can expect massive
privacy and as I said it's not your
privacy in a way because surveillance
robots will know everything about you
but it will they will be oblivious so
care about the Privacy disclosure from
those robots allow them to collect all
the data but ensure for the for the ziki
hardware solutions that they will never
disclose that data whatever they observe
they forget they are always preserving
your privacy even as your privacy
theoretically doesn't exist but only in
the context of the hard ware world uh
verifiable Healthcare you'll be able to
go to any hospital and totally trust
that the surgeon there robotic surgeon
there will execute the job tested with
the models like AI models that has been
executed millions of times so you no
longer will be worried is the doctor
tired or uh or nontrained or did
something change the things will be
repeatable and sure we'll be adapting to
that jobs will be disappearing but
probably be disappearing slowly and
we'll be training the things so be
enjoying that building together uh the
same for Education you have lots of
systems for the novel education
mechanism and probably less and less
interactions in the education
interactions will be always always set
for the social social aspect only but
the the some process of Education will
be remote and will be probably based on
holographic holographic teachers and
access to all the information available
at the pace that your kids need uh or
yourself uh hyperic transport like the
sharing of the taxes all of this will
require connection to the financial
Market where everything is public and
you'll be able to allocate resources
wherever you want um all of those things
you'll be verifying that robots work the
way they should work and you can go to
any of the science fiction novels in the
past and we always somehow end up
building that because we get inspired by
the novels that we read when you're like
six seven year old whether it's fantasy
and science fiction or some kind of
Adventures that's what we build and uh
well they're not predicting anything
they are making us build it
and and this is a lot of fun you build
robots you build the world you reshape
the world and you'll be allocating to
robots you'll be allocating to factories
building factories and maybe it will
feel a bit slower you will not be able
to create mint tokens out of finair like
we do it now so will is digital more
having more capacity than the robots or
actually physical world has more
capacity try build the robots that
replace the robot that builds robots and
see how much we can multiply the value
and start playing with this allocation
and resources and tokens that gain value
Gumble together Gumble with the real
world build factories that build
factories you saw use the remote
verification automated sensor sensors
that we verifiable all that Hardware has
to be built so you can try to play with
the really really hard things in in
physics in chemistry and biology just
learn it you have this access to all the
knowledge nowadays and you feel like
you're building with a game you feel
like you're building the world with
planting trees from Farmville or
Factoria style of machines or Minecraft
the world becomes Minecraft it's all fun
we have fixed economics economics we've
fixed as well the world around us it'll
be super fun we can practically build
all the perfect worlds that we imagined
it's building time again it will not
build itself but actually probably it
will build itself but we started thanks
a lot
[Applause]
wow awesome okay we've got time for a
few questions uh let's start at the top
how to trust agents if we can't even
verify without another agent yeah I
think the same way as you in in every
case where you have the attack mechanism
using defense mechanism that is like
appropriate so when you have trouble
with agents you will use agents agents
will help you to trust other agents they
will use whatever verification mechanism
there exist if you force agents to use
the the ZK verification verifiable
hardware for robotics then the other
agents will be more likely to trust them
like the same way as we do if you go and
make a big transaction with someone if
they pay you like $2 you don't care you
don't verify them if they pay you $1
million then you start being like
testing everything if they say you they
transfer you $1 billion dollars over
blockchain then probably you'll say okay
I need to ZK verify it and sync the
chain myself so this what the agents
will be looking at there'll be CH so
every agent will try to say I'm the most
trustless one they will try to use the
tooling and the culture that we're
building you use the same defense tools
as the attack tools defense defense
capacity will humans be needed humans
will be in be the inefficiency in the
system and agents would like to
marginalize us yeah humans will be
needed for humans I like this the the
major thing in the end is just to to
learn to enjoy life and to socialize
like uh if you yourself need other
humans it means that you're needed
because you need other humans you made
them need it and this will be super fun
probably and since we'll be building for
many years and be passing that culture
I'll be using new technology like any
technology in the past everything that
we're using nowadays feels magical for
the people 100 years ago and probably
for them they would think like oh this
is no longer human the fact that all my
all my communication is in my pocket for
the mobile device and I'm connected
around the world with all the friends
and I can keep changing that this seems
nonnatural this seems like no longer
human for people maybe two 300 years ago
but it feels Supernatural we adapt and
we always in all those adaptations we
care about the human connection so if
you feel you need other humans it means
you needed as well
forever how do we Benchmark agents
versus humans in subjective decision-
making especially given fact of mod the
fact that models might be trained on
unclean opinionated data oh ideally
we'll see who will make more money right
like so if you keep making more money
than the agents that's like the simplest
game the ultimate game uh you can go and
play board games you can play computer
games or you can play trading game and
it's like an ultimate game of a single
number of how much money you make you
not always want to play that that game
but if you push people to play those
games against agents then as long as
people are winning there you have the
Benchmark you have the Benchmark who who
makes the most tokens if they want to
play the game or well how do you
Benchmark humans in the success level do
you enjoy their lives and social intera
actions or do they make more money I
think that you'll never find the perfect
Benchmark but if you want to find one on
blockchain and probably the amount of
tokens that you
amass why would robots choose ethereum
over other chains this seems
obvious what are the best civil
resistant approaches for this future you
envision I guess all the cryptography
that we're building
I mean so resistance like will you will
you care it's just robots or agents will
be able to multiply themselves you have
millions of them so will they have
identities as long as the system holds
with its own assumptions consensus
mechanism and the and the verification
for cryptography it all works so it's
exactly the same resistance mechanism as
before we already had Bots controlled by
people so you already could spawn like
one million different mechanisms whether
there a bit more intelligent themselves
probably doesn't change the mathematical
underlying rules of the consensus
mechanism okay we got one more one more
question why would we want to make
agents their own beings like giving them
their own wallets keys and giving up
complete control what is the point of
the purpose of this bright
side I guess if we have like kids or
friends we want them to enjoy it so let
them enjoy it um it seems fun to look at
it like it seems fun to keep fish at
home or or hamsters probably looking at
the agents building whenever we play
games sometimes at some point you're
bored and you're just looking at the
game because you enjoy looking at it I
guess with agents will be the same the
nature of building building and
curiosity okay awesome so time is up
thank you very much tomz uh just a
couple of Reflections
uh proof of humanity only useful for
dating I guess that assumes you want to
date a human uh d words be petrified or
excited but uh yeah awesome awesome talk
okay so we got a couple more minutes
until the next next talk so you want to
[Music]
transition we' got ethereum for a force
of good coming in a few minutes
[Music]
all
m e
[Music]
e
okay our penultimate session in the
ethereum for good track this
afternoon so ethereum Force for good
we're building all this stuff are we
actually creating a better world are we
creating a positive force for change so
I'd like to introduce stany kulich stany
is the founder and CEO of avara and out
of avara you may have heard of a a Wii
project called a uh and lens and family
wet wallet that he has been
co-founding fun fact about Arvy he likes
to hug trees
but he can tell you about that so uh
welcome
stany hey everyone um it's going to be a
talk about how we actually can use
ethereum uh to build not just great
things but really uh good things for the
uh humanity and I have today roughly uh
50 slides and 20 minutes so it's going
to be really fun um so if there's
something that you like um you have to
be very quick to take a picture um and I
know tonight is going to be ra so um I'm
trying to and I'm the last uh speaker
here uh today so I'm trying to be as
efficient as as possible so you can all
have uh your discon app in later today
before
ra
um it's a really interesting question is
is that what is force for goods so why
what kind of things create positive
outputs for um for the society for the
community and and and humanity
and I personally been building here uh
in the ethereum um Community for the
past uh seven years and I started by
building uh mainly as a hobby and
experimentation while I was was still in
in University um in Helsinki Finland
when where I'm from um a project that
started really just by uh enthusias
enthusiasm and became um one of the
biggest um defi protocols uh in our
space and hopefully a technology that is
going to be used by everyone and I think
the same way across all these protocols
that we're building here together um now
and in the future um
and ethereum is fascinating because it's
a really open design space so you can
really build anything um but the key
ingredients is that how you put things
together in a way that it creates the
output that is beneficial uh for
everyone in overall when you think about
um technology um and and the purpose of
technology and what it really uh helps
um it's about actually lifting the the
standards of of of living um in our
communities and and in in wider uh
societies so when we go back in history
and look at all these technological
innovations that we've we've seen um and
and they typically tend to compound so
let's say um there is innovation in um
Electronics um that compounds different
types of uh new innovation if there's
Innovation that enables the internet uh
you have applications and you have
access and and that's a compounding uh
Innovation but also in the flip side of
the coin is that technology can also uh
do a lot of harm if it's designed in a
wrong way um or without the certain
values as well so um technology can
actually also create U unequal access
information asymmetry um the more you
actually know the better um execution
and the better opportunities you can you
can have it can create uh worker
displacement uh pollution um and
increase the climate uh change so
technology always um is really neutral
to the outputs and it's up to really the
people behind uh that are building the
technology to decide what's the outputs
are going to
be so these inter Technologies are built
in a way that they're access and open
and a big question remains is that can
these Technologies be uh a force of good
that actually can uh lift up the the
society and and
Humanity
um I believe that ethereum is is is a
really powerful uh set of
Technology especially because not purely
from the technical perspective but also
the choices we have made um as a
community being able to build on open
sour Source stock ensures accessibility
open contributions um and actually
access to to building these protocols
and and networks in in a way um uh for
ourselves uh to live in in that future
um as
well and the very interesting idea about
decentralization is that it really
removes the central point of failure or
um gatekeeping that we've been trusting
uh in society for for centuries um
now so this is something interesting
obviously the internet itself has been
built um by relying on decentralized
Technologies so we have IP protocol
HTTP um different email protocols and
and then the ethernet uh protocol um so
the actual internet itself has been
built in in a decentest way but over
time um became more centralized and open
internet has fostered a lot of
Innovations uh over the years and that
Innovation is just accelerating uh over
time and this centralization um started
more recently and and I would say or two
decades uh for now um even though the
actual original architecture was was
more decentralized and and I think what
happened here is that humans um and and
people who were using the internet
wanted more accessibility wanted
everything at the same time it's an open
environment to build but at the same
time we sacrificed uh ownership over um
or use experience over over
ownership and I think truly after a
couple of decades actually living
building on
online um we started to
effectively gravitate towards de
Technologies like the blockchain and and
ethereum
specifically because that can actually
be a game changer you can bring a lot of
those that decentralization uh into your
application Level and bring open
protocols uh into the everyday uh
application
interfaces
um and really main thing about the
safeguards is is that what we can
provide is is effectively rules over
data ownership data sharing neutrality
openness and and security and security
here uh effectively means the security
that the the ethereum as a network
provides for different types of
applications that have really core um
functionality whether it's Finance or
other types of uh use cases and ethereum
by itself uh by its design is sensorship
resistant and obviously that's a
spectrum than anything else because
sensorship resistance depends on
actually the the um rules we setting uh
around ethereum and how we actually
prevent uh centralization within the
existing rules how ethereum operates but
it also ensures individual freedom
effectively for developers to express
with code and and build things that
makes uh a better
society and it enables uh programmable
trusters agreements and I think one of
the biggest uh challenges today is that
every day we actually are relying um
upon agreements so when we walk on the
street we have a agreement um social
agreement economical agreement legal
agreement that for example at certain
point during the day in the evening um
there's going to be lights on the street
um we're trusting when we open the
faucets um in our kitchens that there's
going to be water um we have other types
of uh agreements between people uh that
are based on on on different kinds of
norms or legal agreements as well and
ethereum provides this ability to
actually formalize rules that can
actually be really good for
everyone this is interesting to think
about um when we compare something like
how ethereum and the blockchain has
progressed um over the um years and and
compare it to
something something like the the
internet progression I think even before
going that we started pretty much with
the most basic type of uh functionality
moving value across different users and
and trying to create trying to tackle
one of the most
centralized most centralized
um aspect of it which is which is the uh
value movements and and and finance and
over time obviously as we had a
programmable machine the ethereum
virtual machine we were able to actually
program different kinds of function
functionalities that are that go beyond
uh moving funds from one account to
another so some of you who have been uh
in the space for uh years now remember
the days of icos
when Capital allocation um and capital
formation was was done in an open uh way
in in based on ideas that could funded
um a lot of interesting Innovation
happened there there and a lot of things
that didn't work and that mimics pretty
much how internet started there was a
lot of ideas where um that sounded
really interesting but then eventually
didn't work and at the same time there
were ideas that actually worked and and
became success stories of the whole
internet era and now I think we're
moving towards uh a phase where um we're
starting to validate uh lot of the ideas
that actually work on chain um
decentralized Finance is is one good
example where we have a decentralized
financial protocols that are functioning
well providing High utility and at the
same time are making also revenue and
are organized uh in decentralized
organizations which is really
fascinating um concept and I think we're
moving towards a path where we have
scalability and we can actually move
towards more consumer facing level
so obviously ethereum isn't uh perfect
um it never will be because we have a
lot of programmers here we have a lot of
contributors that are constantly
innovating and the world is constantly
changing and that's the challenge of
ethereum to keeping up with things that
we learn on on the way and also figuring
out how ethereum actually um progresses
and and improves over time as we learned
but one thing is really important to
realize is that with scalability and
ethereum transaction costs going down
with with scaling uh whether it's L2 or
the improvements in the actual main
architecture on Main net we can achieve
um scale of economics in the sense that
the more of these transaction costs are
going down we'll see more actually
adoption of the technology and this
happens uh in every uh industry as the
technology
progresses obviously L2 is a really
great example of finding a solution how
ethereum could actually
scale in a way where we're focusing on
getting transaction cost to a minimum
and opening the doors to a new types of
uh applications and this is just one
kind of like a main scaling strategy uh
that we're seeing at the moment moment
we we're seeing also alternative
blockchains and it's always kind of like
a interesting to put yourself um and
ethereum in competition to other um
networks and other opportunities that
are there to to either to use or build
and I think competition in general is is
is healthy um it creates inspiration and
and and creates more um
Innovation but the main thing why also
so we are here because we're maybe
thinking that ethereum has an advantage
something that doesn't exist somewhere
else and I truly believe in that
so first of all I think ethereum has the
best developer Community ever and I've
been part of developer communities
outside of the web three uh in in web 3
um and there's nowhere else so much of
energy that really wants to move the
space forward innovate and actually
create something good for for the
people there's obviously aspect of being
a battle tested Network in the sense
that ethereum has gone ups and downs and
has actually um been progressing on on
scalability but also learned over the
time what actually what path to take uh
in the future and there's ongoing
improvements these improvements haven't
are something that we don't see every
day necessarily but there's a lot of
work that actually goes into the
ethereum U ecosystem and infrastructure
improvements over time and I think more
more importantly there is a commitment
to decentralization um as well
and I would say that's first
applications were a lot related to
finance because that was obviously very
straightforward use case as blockchains
in the first place were trying to solve
a financial uh problem and for me
personally um I basically moved uh into
Finland uh in my '90s
um I grew up there uh it was a big
recession back in the days and lot of
unemployment Capital dried up and I grew
up in a society where basically you
could feel in families the pain of lack
of access to finance um and just
economical uh depression and for me
building Financial protocols that create
accessibility transparency and mitigates
what actually Banks can do today as a
centralized Authority has been very
important to
me but good question remains on how do
we make Financial systems accessible uh
to everyone because we know that there
might be still access to Finance uh in
Europe and in the Wern world but when we
look at the whole landscape globally um
we still have quite a big number of
unbanked and unbank is a team that
always um circulates across the um
onchain Innovation because ethereum um
has this unique opportunity where you
basically need an internet connection in
a device and you pretty much have a uh
distribution of of uh value at that
point and I think there's been a lot of
progress that we have to celebrate as
well especially in the space of stable
coins as they minimize geographical
disadvantages especially in countries
where there there's a lot of uh
inflation Argentina were recently
visited and turkey and and lot of other
countries and remittances are still a
big
topic to solve when we compare
traditional banking uh we look at what
stable coins can actually offer that's
going to be a big U area that's going to
move forward rwa as is a way to actually
put value on chain that has been may be
really difficult um to achieve and and
and maybe borrow against uh or monetize
and that's going to be a big um category
um and social media I think there is a
lot of people using social and this is a
very interesting topic and close to me
as well with lens um especially because
centralized uh platforms own all the
data and and the connectivity and
there's no ownership at the moment while
all the users are creating actually the
the
value um onchain puts people first so
everyone has a social capital they
should be able to own it you should be
able to access protocols without
middlemen we actually have technology
that can provide true access and fair
access and and transparency as
well there is definitely other sectors
that we have in touch upon uh supply
chain is very interesting there's still
27 PE million people in slave labor at
the moment there's a lot that we can do
in
agriculture carbon credits
and of course importantly when you're
thinking about building and use cases
there's a lot of values that you can
actually tackle um there's obviously 16
areas that you can focus and these are
the sustainability goals from un um in
most cases if you're building already on
chain you're actually tackling some of
these
values question if we are moving too
slowly when you compare to the adoption
of of the
internet you can actually see that the
the growth that is happening now on
chain and within the ethereum E system
um is actually in line how we're growing
with online uh there's a little bit of
differences there but there's
significant growth happening even if you
don't feel it every day we
have we are still very small compared to
the bigger pie of the internet users as
active users on
chain in terms of developers compared to
the main web 2
world but to grow actually from here
onwards events like these are perfect
because we're welcoming more developers
into ethereum and build more and
expand and there's challenges when you
come and build learning a new technology
smart contracts um the technology moves
fast tools are moving fast Dows are very
um a new thing there's not many models
we're still very early in the space and
there's so much to do actually there's
so much to do so much to build and
contribute and ux is a big bottleneck so
for ux we have to do a lot and I think
this is the time as we have solved
scalability and progressed uh quite a
lot on that aspect being able to have
good U and build good applications that
are on chain is is going to be the next
chapter so where we are in the progress
of of uh adoption I think we're
somewhere in the middle in terms of the
usage if you compare it to the time as
Internet started to grow it doesn't feel
that it's moving fast but we're growing
there's more and more users and Builders
uh in the space
poly Market is an interesting example as
well where you can build something that
is actually really valuable in terms of
uh information and can predict we're
able to predict election results uh on
chain we can build anything it's just
about how we imagine and think about
it and I think we're in this moment
because we want to shape the future
where we want to live in and we're just
getting started it's very early I've
been here for 7even years and I feel
that there's there's still two decades
just to build every fundamental
infrastructure and accessibility for
users thank
[Applause]
you thank you stany that was wonderful
lots to think about Okay so we've got
three minutes for some questions what is
the code so the code is Force for
[Laughter]
[Applause]
good okay as a developer sometimes is
haunting to tackle the adoption
challenge what are the baby steps we
should take if we make Financial tools
that make use of crypto and apply it to
our
community I think you should always
start from the user and and actually how
you can help by building a product I
think when I was building on on ethereum
and and and even a little bit of today
it started from a lot of the technology
side the protocol aspect but I think
today if I will build something new I
will start from a product and a and
actually what how we can solve a user's
problem
okay yeah what's the avara end game how
do you want
to it's gone hang
on okay let's go to top
one how can we protect defi from
unhealthy incentives schemes uh and
continue growing it as a better
Financial
system I think it really depends
obviously on what building in overall
incentives are extremely good way of
Distributing ownership of a system that
can be governed by a community uh with
the set rules in the community
transparently that's a big value
proposition that is why the AV da uh
exists or the sky da exist or Lio da
exist because they're able to create
these rules and actually benefit the
community and build better outcomes uh
effectively I think
incentives come when there is actually a
meaningful Traction in a in a protocol
Market fit and that's the place where
incentives are more interesting where
it's more about decentralizing a
valuable infrastructure that has
actually High utility on chain and the
another question about the avaras
endgame so obviously we started with um
within a Labs building defy and the a
protocol
um our end game with avara is to build a
people powered internet we think that
blockchain is as a technology it's use
case neutral meaning that we will see
Financial use cases um but also ethereum
is going to be used for nonf financial
use cases as well and avara is something
that provides access to that
infrastructure and these use cases with
family and extends with with defy with a
and go and and in Social uh with lens
cool 25 seconds as a developer sometimes
is haunting to tackle uh oh we've done
that one hav we yes as a builder of both
Network consumer apps and protocols
what's your view on scaling improving on
L okay I got it yeah so let's call it a
day I give up okay we're just about
finished now I think scaling should be a
really kind of like a open-ended uh
space so you should be able we should be
able to see scaling happening within the
main architecture of ethereum in in main
net I think there should be a lot of
innovation happening which is going to
happen um but scaling also should happen
on these l2s specifically and we should
keep exploring new ideas and and ways to
scale Beyond uh what we know today and
this is a ever ending research topic
where uh developers can actually uh
contribute I do think that we should
apply the exact amount of security that
we need based on the use case D5 for
example might need the highest security
where social might need uh the least
amount of uh security but some security
to enable guarantees for the users okay
we're out of time thank you very much
Danny big round of applause was awesome
thank
[Applause]
you okay so we got a couple minutes left
for the next session we're going to have
an awesome
panel on why def def5 matters
is e
[Music]
okay last session of the day hope you're
hang in there why defi matters on
ethereum and why ethereum is the best
place for defi we've got an awesome
panel to delve deeper into that topic so
I'd like to welcome Kane ly namic and
Tasha onto the stage you want to
[Music]
looks like we have a very good turnout
today very
exciting um very important conversation
defi does it matter on the fum or not uh
was a large conversation on Twitter a
few months ago uh vitalic got in some
trouble with the D
ogs and yeah now we have the is a Devcon
so consequences have actions uh we have
a lot of really cool people here today
so let's just start off let's do intros
my name is namic part of the founding
team here at Mega Eve hence the Hat um I
love crypto I love defi I don't think
defi is the only thing that matters but
I love
defi hi everyone uh my name is l I
started kaiber at one of the earliest
decentralized chains in the space I
guess you know back then in 2017 def5
wasn't a thing um stepped out a couple
of years ago but still uh help out the
team here and there and recently started
carber uh focus on building um new defy
project new Improvement on ethereum with
new
fers hi my name is Tasha uh also a local
here uh from Thailand uh founded a
project called Alpha Finance which buil
a lot of thei products uh and a lot of
experiments uh the flagship product is
called Alpha homora where we came up
with the concept of Leverage U farming
uh so it can share a bit more of like
you know defi back in 2020 and also like
nowadays as well uh transition to
advisory role uh last year and then also
started another project called infinite
which is more on the defi infrastructure
layer so it abstracts a lot of
complexities to get new def protocols
built and scale uh within the same chain
and to all different chains as well um
yeah that's about
me uh I'm Kane um I guess I'm partially
responsible for us being uh on the stage
here today um the the funny thing is I I
was on the stage and I was like the last
time I was on Devcon main stage was
accepting a ux award at uh at Devcon 4
in 2018 for Haven which is dark right
like if it it speaks to how bad ux was
back then um but we won a ux award so
it's been six years back on on the main
stage very excited to be here so thanks
let's get straight into it ethereum is
the first turn complete
blockchain um very quickly found pmf as
this Global Financial layer right black
rock is on ethereum super bullish what's
the role of defi on ethereum what's its
Edge and how can Defi and theum maintain
this mode what do you think kyber
I think the best thing that etherum can
offer to many defy application is that
um you know it has the highest like
security guarantee it's a Non-Stop you
know uh teing complete machine that you
can expect that at really really I think
like I think since 2016 we had no
consensus incident ever right so I think
you can be sure that your defy
application will work one in extremely
you know even like in extremely harsh
condition um it going be like stop like
you know because of whatever condition
right so I think that's the highest
guarantee that etherum can offer to defy
protocols but do people really care
you're seeing a lot of activity on other
l1s you're seeing like arbitrum as an L2
have you know it was the defi train for
a long time I mean hyper liquid is also
doing pretty well there now but do
people even care about these guarantees
does anyone here care about the
guarantees I think they would care if
they suffer from say Life Net issues
right I mean like I think there are
several incidents in the past that some
of the popular layer one some of the
popular ethereum ker was stops right
like basically for hours and people
cannot close their landing position
people cannot like you know do their
transaction right and that really like
made like made them suffer right
financially lost right um you know I
would so firstly I love ethereum right
so I'm just playing a bit of Devil's
Advocate I think arguments can be made
that like eal1 when gas fees are
unbelievably High they're it's basically
off right for every single person in an
Emerging Market they can't afford to use
eperium L1 when like something important
is happening it's too
expensive what do you think Tasha yeah
no I think um two things actually like I
think the the question to to really
answers the question of like you know
why Define an ethereum right you have to
think of like what the users want users
want to use defi for yields for you know
liquidity um the yields a lot of the
time on chain comes from
interoperability or you know the the
money Legos uh which I think that's
pretty much you know Competitive Edge of
ethereum uh also the network effects as
well for you know being around for so
long a lot of Builders there um a lot of
liquidity there therefore you know you
as a new Builder as a new D app actually
benefits a lot more building on ethereum
because you get that edge and as a
result to that you know users therefore
get the benefits of network effect uh of
that money Lego the second for sure you
know when we talk about defi is
liquidity you know ethereum has 60
billion of liquidity out of about like
110 billion of liquidity on chain that's
like more than 50% so I feel like you
know if you're looking to swap you're
looking to lend or you know do different
things you don't want to pay like you
know 5% of fees or like you know what
were high SL slippage right so I feel
like at the end of the day you know
there can be many l1s and l2s it will
take time um and I I believe that there
will not be just all activities on
ethereum um and I think you know there
would be like multiple players that that
would capture a lot of demand um but I
think it would also take time for for
the other l1s and l2s to also get the
benefit of that Network effect and the
liquidity yeah what are your faults K I
think it's tradeoffs right like the the
trade-off that we have with L1 is it
doesn't go down it gets expens ensive
right but um you know there is super
deep liquidity and you can find a
clearing price for almost everything
right um you've got composability you've
got you know all of these different
markets there's a ton of Lindy um and
yeah in you know congestion moments most
people are priced out but it will still
keep functioning you'll still be able to
uh you know find uh F liquidity if
you're willing to pay for it right um
the flip side is then we have l2s which
uh are able to you know keep prices down
even during congestion um different
trade-offs different uh you know
different value props right like they're
not as liquid um they are cheaper most
of the time um and so you know uh you're
not going to get priced out from using
arbitrum or optimism right um you know
so I think that the the point of
ethereum is to have uh this very secure
L1 and then have many different
approaches to scaling for l2s um that's
the road map it's working um and I think
that you know that's one of the reasons
why people keep building on it so we've
kind of mentioned l2s a couple times now
and the prompt is like why def5 matters
on ethereum do we think that l2s are
ethereum um I mean I think for small
transation for like simple transation
you can always go to L2 right I think a
lot and also like for okay so before
that I let me give some sort of like
history kind of like lesson from that
that we learned from kyber right I mean
back in 2018 2017 when we launched kyber
basically our modotto was that we allow
market makers to do Market making
onchain right by making like onchain
transation to update the price um and to
allow other people to trade with the
market makers and I think when D5 summer
happens uh um when D5 summer happen it
it really killed kyber right why because
the gas price increased like crazily and
it made it like you know really
impossible for the market makers to
update the price and to really like you
know make profit right because like they
had like to spend too much on the price
update um so I think use cases like that
can certainly run on L2 because one is
cheap one second is fast right like you
can do like you know high frequency uh
price update you can do like a lot of
like micro transaction uh but you cannot
do on L1 right so it really like you
know um you know have uh users have more
option right uh if they want to do like
high value transaction if they want to
make sure that you know they can always
withdraw their fund from like you know a
landing vot or like you know do that
like basically they can playay pay right
like in order to do things um then they
can go to L1 uh L2 they can do things
fast they can do like thing cheap right
and they can do a lot of other new
things yeah I love your answer I think I
I feel the same way um if the L1 and the
L2 have different kinds of defi
experiences and applications they're
complimentary if they're a replication
of what exists on the L1 I think then
you're just competitive and parasitic
what do you guys think of uni
train I mean Unis swap right like it
exists on every train I mean every L2
every L1 it's an amm and now they have
their own app train thoughts
um maybe I won't answer that question
I'll answer a different uh question that
that you asked earlier so my my view of
whether l2s are ethereum is that we have
found ourselves in this place right um
for reasons um a lot of them are
regulatory reasons I think where um we
could have been more pragmatic about how
we were building things um but we had to
of try scops everyone into believing
that things were further along than they
actually were right um you know all l2s
are somewhat centralized right um you
know to varying degrees uh in a normal
world that didn't have adversarial
Regulators trying to shut down crypto we
would be able to be honest about that
set of tradeoffs right and just say look
this is technology that we're in the
process of building you have L1 L1 has
trade-offs you know L2 all of the the
scaling Sol
um have trade-offs and we're going to
build demand first and once we've got
that demand then we're going to figure
out ways to decentralize it there's two
problems one um in the early days we had
a lot of people who were here for
ideological reasons including myself um
who were like Hardline about uh
decentralization and censorship
resistance right um and you know I've
come to the conclusion after like seven
years of building in this space that
that's just not viable right um there's
no point in building a perfectly
decentralized perfectly censorship
resistant system if there's no demand
for it right um and so we need to be
willing to make pragmatic uh tradeoffs
as we're building towards you know
demand because the these are technical
problems we can definitely solve them
right um so my view today is that it's
better to build demand and then figure
out ways to make the technology better
over time more decentralized more
sensorship resistant um then to start
with some pure ideal um and I think that
we've all been moving in this direction
right like all of the l2s did this but
we kind of had to like squint and
pretend that it wasn't the case um it's
also the case of defi like all the daps
are not decentralized right they're
hosted on AWS they're hosted in Cloud
flare um but you know we're like oh yeah
like you know no multisig don't look
over here um it's it's right um
and if we weren't in the regulatory
environment that we've been in for the
last four years I think we would have
been able to be more honest about it um
and I think that now we need to just
lean into it be pragmatic build things
get to mass adoption and once we've got
Mass adoption we can figure out how to
make it purely decentralized and purely
censorship resistant and really improve
the tech so it's a very different
approach to how we started back in the
old days building OG defi um but I think
it's a it's the only way
forward hyper liquid is a great example
right build for users of what they want
and that's like you know distributed
system in end of the day where anyone
can come and like participate right and
is it as decentralized as like your
conventional L1 like no but does it have
an unbelievable pmf and that's awesome
yes so yeah I think like the tradeoffs
are definitely part of the mega EP
thesis for sure so music to my ears um
anybody else have any thoughts on the
the L2 L1 stuff or we can move
on actually I think the other thought
that I have is that um you know a lot of
people might might jeopardize the the
fact that hey like more l2s create more
liquidity fragmentation but I think on a
hindsight those new liquidity on these
new l2s could not even have been onchain
to begin with if there's not you know
for that out2 to begin with right so I
feel like each out2 kind of have its own
Community you know the the founder the
team building that at to have their own
you know VCS or have their own Community
or like onchain users um deploying
liquidity there so I feel like yes
there's liquidity fragmentation for the
short term among all these you know tens
hundreds of l1s and l2s but over time
like I feel like there's going to be a
point where that liquidity gets smarter
they know about ethereum know about the
other l2s know about other yield
opportunities elsewhere and then
eventually that would you know kind of
aggregate to a you know a few places so
I think we're we're seeing that shift a
bit more as well as those l2s launch a
token and liquidity kind of like you
know aggregate to somewhere else um so I
think net positive overall in my opinion
for for the whole industry yeah I think
like I was always a big fan of arbitrum
as a case study because it showed uh
that the most efficient like I mean they
had the the the shortest block times
right so for defi it enables more
efficient defi than anywhere else and if
found really strong pmf uh Op with the
super train is trying to create like
this next level of interoperability
between like their cluster uh really
really exciting I I tend to believe that
like too much fragmentation is an issue
uh especially when you don't have
differentiated block space right uh if
it's just like all horizontal scaling
but you don't actually you can increase
like the capacity the the total net
amount of block space that is associated
with the fium ecosystem but if you want
to actually work on like vertical scale
as well like you're just capped right
and like okay if we just want the the
grand success of like ethereum to be
like you know transfer of like money
right okay it works but if we want like
these really sophisticated applications
which exist in like other highper
execution environments like salana we
need to work on like multiple uh degrees
um but you know we you you've mentioned
like l1's a couple times right I love to
get into this conversation like to
understand why does def match on
etherium we need to understand how def
is different on etherium compared to
other all ones right as we know like
defi pardon me ethereum is the most uh
decentralized smart contractor in
complete blockchain right and that
attracts large large players right you I
remember I was once speaking to a famous
salana VC and we were talking about like
the role of Def on E versus the role of
Def on Saul and he was like okay okay
you know 10 years down the road when
there's like a bank-to-bank transfer of
like a currency right that happens on e
that's not going to happen on Sal if
someone's moving half a billion dollars
that happens on ethereum uh but we love
to get everyone else's opinions here on
like what is the granularity of defi on
ethereum compared to other you know like
it's not like Salon is like super
centralized still relatively
decentralized right how does defi differ
between like let's say
ethereum uh
salana and yeah I think those are the
main two l1s out there today in my
opinion I think just you know it it CHS
a lot from the stats as well right like
ethereum as mentioned like 60 billion I
think about like 400,000 wallets so that
shows a lot of like how aggregated or
like how how large a wallet has to be on
ethereum uh just to make sense on
ethereum versus Solana where about 7
billion of assets and 6 million of
wallets so I think I think it it shows
the the type of applications on those
two different l1s already and also the
the types of activities and the types of
users um and those results are pretty
much you know as a result of the tech uh
or like you know how it's built as well
um you mentioned that you know ethereum
is a lot more decentralized a lot more
secure and hence you know High liquidity
or like large amount of liquidity um is
more Worthy on ethereum as opposed to
salanta where I think it's more very
much like retail driven um they may not
care so much about decentralization or
you know security for maybe like $100 of
wallet right but they're willing to like
do a lot of like bets and a lot of like
derivative trading on Solana and make
you know a lot of money from from doing
that activity so I think um there's no
right or wrong in my opinion of like
whether it's decentralized or not but
just more of like what's the unique
differentiation of that chain or that L2
it is and how that differentiation would
attract that differentiated types of
applications and therefore that segment
of users cuz if there's no
differentiation from the tech or the
fundamental chain itself then it's going
to be very very hard to to attract um
the right apps and the right
uses I think that there was a there was
a moment in time where um a lot of the
ideological Builders were on ethereum um
and uh the more prag itic Builders uh
were pushed to um salana partially
because you know cheaper transaction
fees right they were like we don't
really care about anything other than uh
users being able to transact cheaply
right um and you know they they went
there and and ultimately defies about
Network effects right um you know the
network effects on ethereum Main net are
really powerful and there was a period
in time where we were needing to
bootstrap new network effects on all the
l2s which was really hard right like I
tried to do this on optimism it did not
go well it was it was a very difficult
thing right um and and in parallel to
that uh you had Network effects that
were growing on salana and so you now
have these two independent uh you know
um networks that have uh different
network effects with different Builders
and I think they both have enough
critical mass to be sustainable um
what's interesting about ethereum to me
though is we now have this new uh kind
of process where we get to experiment
with things like Mega eth um you know
with some of these new networks that are
trying different sets of trade-offs and
we get to try and bootstrap new network
effects and see whether or not we can
compete with you know ultra low fees for
example right or you know really low
latency um and so even though each time
we create a new set of trade-offs with a
new L2 we need to bootstrap Network
effects there is already that kind ofe
or liquidity that's sitting on L1 that's
that's sort of anchoring it all um so
you don't start from scratch right like
you wouldn't want L you know you
wouldn't want megie to be in L1 that
would be a really hard process to to
bootstrap um but you know it's uh it's
able to kind of pull some of the eat
liquidity there um so I think that we
have a very interesting Prospect in
front of us where something like salana
which is monolithic and has Network
effects is now going to have a bunch of
things that are competing with it on
some of its core value props right low
transaction fees High throughput Etc um
and it's going to be very very
interesting to see whether it kind of
gets squeezed in the middle right from
like deep liquidity from L1 and then
super fast low you know uh transaction
fees from some of the l2s so I think
this cycle we will find
out I think um one of the thing that I
always um look at into new um ethereum
kolers or like new layer ones is
uh whether with the new technology
Improvement they can create any new use
cases right and if you look into defy I
think all the defi Innovation still
happen on ethereum or evm kind of
ecosystem right like we have
concentrated liquidity per decks amm
decks whatever right like you know defy
Landings every Innovation that we have
seen in defi started in the ethereum
ecosystem um Solana or other high
performance layer one they might have
Amplified them right the use cases but
still I mean they all started like from
the same Innovation that that started in
the ethereum ecosystem right I would say
like the central limited order book uh
came from salana uh no one ever tried to
do that in ethereum because like it come
on like that's a bit silly there was
ether Delta back in 2017 but like I
think the G the gas was just like too
bad we did try it it just failed
horribly yeah yeah so I think like when
we started this conversation by talking
about like eal one right and we spoke a
bit about eal 2 and we had a
conversation around how if you have an
L1 and an L2 like if they're
complimentary meaning they go after
different kinds of use cases uh like
that's pretty chill if not that's not so
chill but one of the edges of eal1 is
the fact that it's like extremely
decentralized extremely uh like like you
know you can do all these awesome things
on E1 but there's not that many things
you can do right so yesterday or the day
before this uh Justin Drake had like an
announcement around like a bunch of
optimizations for E1 um uh what did you
guys think of that conversation it was
actually in this stage at 5:00 P p.m
same time so you know I came here to
watch that um which is the first time
that I've like run run across like a you
know um Devcon uh to try and get to a
presentation um and I think that there
were a lot of things that were very
exciting about that um the my my issue
with it fundamentally um and you know
there's there's definitely uh different
takes on this is that if you're going to
like YOLO propose a uh different path
for ethereum L1 um then it needs to
probably have a different time frame
right so we already have a long-term
road map for L1 uh if you if you want to
propose something that is you know
supposed to be a radical deviation from
that um having the same time frame I
think is not the right approach um and
so I think that there was a little bit
of disappointment including for me I was
like 2030 is like so far away right like
we're talking um and then you know also
it's software right like I was sitting
there when vitalic was like the merge is
coming in 2017 like no like so you know
2030 also feels like much further away
because it's really 2035 so I I think
that if we're going to propose radical
approaches to L1 scaling uh then it
needs to be you know um something that
is much more uh pragmatic and and sooner
yeah I was excited I also uh sprinted to
get here I was literally sitting on the
floor in that corner and yeah it was
just a bit it was a bit um you know
disheartening for me because in a lot of
ways like I was I knew basically what
the Spiel was going to be and it's
actually very bullish even for meie
because we're not interested in
replicating any use case that can exist
on any L1 so I want etherum L1 to be
better right I don't think of it is as
competitive whatsoever but it really
does show just like the level of alific
of ethereum as a main net right it's
very very large it's very difficult to
get things across the uh line to the
point where we have like over a year for
just like pilling people right when you
know it's like clearly we are in two
different rooms because I feel like
people already are like we need to do
something we've legit become Bitcoin
like there was a period of time where we
were like Bitcoin they're crazy like
they won't do anything and we're like
all right let's think about it for two
years and then we'll start like it's
like I don't know I mean yes of course
ethereum is important we shouldn't
it up but like you know it it doesn't
feel like that's a reasonable time frame
what do you guys think I feel like U
Dustin Dr he high up the talk a little
bit too
much and I think that people have like
different expectation from what was
deliver uh but I think like from the
protocol developer point of view right I
think I mean I think the most exciting
things that or potential that I got out
from that is one you know user
experience on A1 might be a lot better
given you know the potential shorter
block ter faster finality ter right um
but the reality is that I think protocol
developers will just like you know I
think will probably like accommodate or
like change accordingly to the to the
updates from the layer one right so like
for example currently um 12C block term
maybe it's not too bad for users is just
a little bit like you know too much of
me and stuff right but you know you just
want to have better experience they go
to layer two right uh 4 second block
term less me price is closer to the
centralized changes price um but you
know I think it doesn't change much like
to like protocol developers that much uh
it might impact a lot more on the user
experience it might you know have like
more transation on E term layer one I
but I think from the protocols
developers point of view not much
changes yeah I think um a lot L of lot
of thoughts uh very much you resonate
with uh both two other panelists as well
I think the first thought is like you
know from from 12 second block time to 4
second sounds good but you know by 2030
will that be even too slow you know uh
you know you also mentioned perhaps in
20135 right um 10 years from now maybe
like all all the things we're talking
about is all like already abstract away
from the users and everything's
expecting like in less than a second
right um so that's the first thought the
second as well as more
like I think it really raises a question
of whether ethereum has to be fast or
whether ethereum will like should play
the role of you know the main settlement
layer don't have to be as fast let the
other al2s do the fast job um and just
be secure be decentralized and and
maintain that role so I think you know
really still debating among myself
whether you know ethereum should or
should not um take this route and I
think it's you know there's no right or
wrong answer as well um but very I think
whether we take on this route or not it
really it will really change and shift
the way eth token as well will play and
also the ethereum network um will play
in in the whole uh Dynamic yeah I feel
like the the need for ethereum L1 to do
these optimizations comes from the fact
that like l2s are kind of parasitic
right or at least in my opinion they
have been historically uh yeah like at
like I don't know uh yeah like look at
hyper liquid right uh vampire attacks
arbitrum and is now it's own L1 and is
amazing but what happened right like it
was able to get a lot of liquidity in
user base from eperium what was good for
the E for asset nothing much what was
good for the E for user on L1 nothing
much uh and then you know a lot of
question marks can be even pointed to
existing l2s like if your
architecture uh effectively can easily
become its own L1 right like are you
building this L2 because you want to
just like vampire attack aum's existing
ecob system and then you know strong
arguments can be made for like we have
to focus on the eal1 because these l2s
are not actually good for us um yeah
what do you guys think we need to do to
100 xdy on
ethereum and that can be in l2s as well
ethereum is what you want it to
be I think there're you one of the
mistakes that I certainly made um back
in the day was uh rejecting polygon
right um you know I was like it's a side
chain you know ideology again right um
it's a side chain it's not real you know
it's parasitic to L1 all kinds of stuff
right um I think that there is uh a need
to ensure that ethereum including the
l2s side chains whatever
um you know uh maintains relevance if if
ethereum loses relevance um it's very
hard to get it back right ethereum is
the the dominant platform for defi today
it has the deepest liquidity um but if
something flips it it could get dark
right um and so I think that improving
the L1 is important if we just kind of
hand over all responsibility for
relevance to l2s then you're right like
if if you know a one L2 becomes huge and
then it decides to split off to an L1
like good night right um so I think that
there is uh a really important um aspect
to maintaining relevance for the L1
continuing to improve it um and I think
the existing road map is good right I
think the the existing road map is a
solid road map it's good to see
Alternatives proposed um I think that
some of those Alternatives uh you know I
was hoping it was going to be like mag
iCal Wizardry and like next Tuesday we
get you know 1 second block times or
something but here we are um but uh you
know I I genuinely believe that we need
both of these things because to your
point if we if we just you know kind of
uh let the L1 aify and turn into Bitcoin
where it's like a five-year debate about
opcat like that's a really really bad
place to be and I think that it's almost
definite that ethereum will lose
relevance at that point I also feel like
Bitcoin can afford to take 5 years those
affordances do not exist for fium right
like if you were number one you can do
this but not if you're number two also
like no one is pretending to build a new
network I mean you know Litecoin gave up
on that right like you know there's not
even Digital Silver I think it's like
now a sloth chain or something as of
today right so um you know there's
there's no credible threat to bitcoin
from that perspective of you know store
value digital gold whatever whatever it
is um but there are many many many
credible threats to ethereum including
the l2s arguably right right um so you
know there is a responsibility to
continue to improve the L1 um in order
to make sure that you know it has a
defensible mode what do you guys think
how do we make d500 Xpat on the
[Music]
ferarum um in 2018 2019 um when we just
I think when before defi summer right so
I think one of the things that we did
really um and and I think we're still
proud of that uh now is um we started
that b DC right with uh bito and a
couple of other project um so back then
when we realized that okay the TV or the
the asset on ethereum that that there W
that too many asset for people to trade
right for like defy like if you do defy
and and the whole like TV of everything
is like 100 Millions right US dollars
what else can you do um so we did um
near withc and I think recently we
started like seeing more and more people
like bringing other asset to ethereum
right via real asset and different ways
as well I think that and and also like
if you look into like stable coin right
like usdc and usdt I think most of it is
on ethereum now um I think that's one
way for us to secure like you know the
the number one position for ethereum
right like we need to bring more asset
in we need like to bring like you know a
decentralized version of rap BTC into
ethereum for example or like we need to
unlock defy sorry Bitcoin liquidity in
ethereum and eum layer tools
um yeah um I mean you know the
Counterpoint to that though is like Tron
and usdt right like this crazy scam
chain and it's doing you know huge
volumes of stable coins right um you
know
there's reasonable concerns about both
of those things usdt and Tron right but
from a practical standpoint there's a
lot of happening on Tron and a lot
of people are using it um and even the
argument of like oh yeah high value
transfers people will only do it on
ethereum like people do big usdt
transfers on Tron all the time yeah
actually in Turkey you go to the uh you
go to the Grand Bazaar and you go to the
OTC desks they don't do AUM they only do
Tron because they know what it is yeah
it's actually kind of sad but it's true
they only use
Tron I mean I think most people I mean I
think as talk earlier right I mean L1
ethereum will fit for some certain use
cases right like for the asset that are
less volatile that like you know that
you don't need like require like
subsecond kind of like finality um then
you can still rely on it layer one right
hopefully you know in a couple of years
or in a few years from now on the next
depc people will start like using usdt
or usdc payment on Mega E on base on you
know all the layer tools right awesome
so let's move to questions we have 9
minutes and 30 seconds allocated for Q&A
if you guys don't have questions I'm
just going to keep laring
so question for me oh geez from my point
of view I see megie as a direct
competitor to Salo let's go uh
assuming Tech performs as promised
inshallah how do you feel about this
comparison and also when testnet yeah I
mean I think that like there's a meme
that uh is said sometimes where we're
going to out salana Sal
I think like fundamentally the thesis
for Mega is performance and
decentralization don't really go hand in
hand and that's because consensus is
complicated the more decentralized you
are right like it takes longer to reach
consensus and on Mega E what we say is
okay you know what like it is tough
let's just kick that down to ethereum
the power of proofs be that fraud proofs
or ability proofs coupled with the force
exit slforce inclusion meaning even if
this sequencer is wilding out I can go
back to the L1 is unbelievably powerful
people haven't explored it enough and
when you take these guarantees and you
say you know what now let's go
performance first you're able to achieve
a level of performance that's never
really been seen before in crypto and
that's what like our thesis is and
that's what we're doing and yeah testet
very soon keep keep tuned uh all I'll
say is like yeah really really excited
to be completely honest uh with Unis V4
coming up probably early next year do
you think D5 will get even crazier with
hooks will we possibly see the stocks
going to D5 of amm uh you seem like you
you have some facial
reactions
um I mean obviously I think uh with V4
coming I think we will see like a lot
more like different strategy that people
would bring in like you know with amm
and different like strategy that every
hook will have you know their own way of
Market making right uh but I think the
the the reality that we are seeing now
because like I think kyber now runs one
of the biggest de cator on evm and we
see that um I think a lot more
liquidities are going offchain right via
like you know private market makers via
RFQ Network um and they have like
everyone of them have like different
strategy of like where to get liquidity
how to do pricing and things like that
of course they still use like onchain
for settlement right but I think we're
seeing more and more of that like going
up chain um and I think doing stock I
think like you don't need like uni V4 to
do that right like you know you like
other RFQ other like you know existing
infrastructure can already do that uh
I'm also like super excited to see like
what can what uni V4 can bring uh to the
table there's been like a lot of talk
lately but like I haven't seen like
concrete example I mean every single new
version of Unis swap manages to break
defi in some spectacular way right so
I'm looking forward to the unintended
consequences of uh V4 uh I can only
imagine what chaos is going to uh come
from this but I feel like a lot of the
hooks or pretty much you know strategies
that you can do are only a number of
them like you can do a lot with you know
hooks for sure with Unis but I feel like
the only ones that going to get adopted
would be like a handful um and I think a
lot of those use strategies or you know
trading strategies or you know so-called
hooks um are already like being used and
built by these whether's you know market
makers doing onchain things instead of
building it offchain and themselves and
just making it more onchain accessible
for for normal users to access those
hooks so I think um yeah the impact
would be more on like a lot of people
would be able to access what those use
strategies that market makers already
doing um and not just limited by the
ones that they build
themselves
Kane how will
infinex change the defi landscape good
question I thought that my uh meme coin
was going to maybe win that uh question
battle there for a second but uh looks
like no so sorry what about mcoin oh I
so I launched a meme coin um as a way of
like testing out salana I wanted to like
get my head around what salana was doing
uh so I launched this meme coin and aird
dropped it to all the uh snx holders and
they're just like the biggest jeets in
history and they all just like dumped it
to Oblivion and they were like they were
like I can't believe that you've done
this to us like you know they're
fighting with each other and they're
like what are you going to do like to
you know I was like guys like just don't
dump on each other right like your
friends aren't your excellent liquidity
but here we are um anyway infinex really
quick question yeah so it was a soul
meme coin to snx haers
right but snx was on ethereum so it was
a different walet address what was that
like yeah so so basically what I did is
I um aird dropped a token on Bas called
2192 um and then uh they were all just
like dumping it into Oblivion so I was
like all right like we have to burn it
so I made everyone burn the token so
they had to like all burn it to get
something and what I gave them was a
salana token and then they were
obviously all pissed about that um and
so you know it was this long like uh
weird you know airdrop game basically um
but yeah it it turned out poorly and
everyone's mad so classic uh meme coin
games um so so infinex though um infinex
is trying to uh bring uh binance on
chain right um we've had for the last
you know decade basically a little bit
longer uh centralized exchanges
dominating transactions right um most
crypto transactions happen inside of
someone's uh database and we've made
inroads against this at various times
you know Unis swaps competed with
coinbase on on a couple of days um in
history so you know good job um but we
haven't really been able to make much uh
Headway against centralized exchanges um
so we finally now I think have uh the um
infrastructure that we need to be able
toing bring everyone on chain um but the
way to do that you know as I kind of
alluded to earlier is to be pragmatic
right building defi we tried to build
defi in a way that was um both
non-custodial and censorship resistant
and we didn't even land the censorship
resistance but we just created the worst
ux and so infinex is basically saying
look we're going to Park Central we're
going to we're going to be non-custodial
right but we're going to park censorship
resistance and we're going to build the
ux possible and we're going to get
people using uh all of these onchain
protocols that we've made um and we're
going to create you know Mass adoption
and once we've got Mass adoption then
we'll go back and fix the the you know
the other
issues so next up is um what do you
think of the value cruel
mechanisms uh for l2s versus monetary
premium of Eve uh I'll start as someone
who's building an L2 I think like most
L2 tokens kind of suck um I think in
general like governance is a bit of a
meme we we've seen this of like major
dii protocols that are like governance
prod tokens and then the governance
happens and then they don't follow
governance um so yeah I think like part
of this is because the regulatory
landscape has been very scary so when
you look at like toonomic design uh the
just design space is very limited I do
think that is changing and I think there
are there'll be a Renaissance for uh
token design over the next few years and
we'll be able to catch up on lost time
and I'm excited to see what that looks
like uh in the future but at the moment
I definitely think like I think like l2s
are like you know Cur L tokens are kind
of cursed and the sad part is they don't
even provide value back to the E asset
class so it's like a lose lose and uh no
one's really that interested uh at least
in my opinion what do you guys think I
think the best L2 toen design that I've
seen recently was uni
chain um because they actually have you
know the ability to capture the value
from me from like all the different fees
that uni has been um or any like you
know Dex has been uh capturing and I
think people were joking around that you
know uni chain was a um Fe swist for uni
token that people have been waiting for
um yeah good to to say you're still
holding your un
drop yeah I agree I think uh a good
analogy though is like if if L2 tokens
only relying on you know transaction
fees capturing all those then as a
result you know you need to maximize
number of users which again comes back
to how many users are there on chain
right so I think um ultimately we we
have to kind of like really embed the
toomics of al2 especially for L2 as well
to really be a part of the product and
the chain and be more creative like what
else can you engineer what else can you
capture value along all the different
parts of the chain itself and I think
you know bar chain is one uh idea or
like one experimental way of like how
you can expand the number of ways to
capture that values um but definitely
like you know not limiting to to just
that um I haven't given this much
thought so this could be utterly insane
but um I I feel like L2 tokens were a
mistake um they've created this uh I
mean that that part I have thought about
and that that is true I do believe that
um they have created this fragmentation
of attention um within the ethereum
ecosystem um which is really problematic
now okay you want to launch an L2 it
needs a token like what do you do um I
feel like we should have tried something
like if you make the best L2 you get
some eth or something like that right
instead of like you know just uh mint
your own token out of thin air um I
think that would have uh been a much
more effective mechanism for
Distributing value like if you can scale
ethereum you know the if the EF had been
like all right we're going to put up you
know 100 million uh extra eth right
we're going to like increase the
inflation rate or something and whoever
captures the most transactions or
whatever in l2s you get this pile of eth
uh I think we've been in a much better
place today yeah I think we just need a
closer relationship between the asset
and epher right like the architecture of
these l2s should be beneficial both to
epher as an L1 if for as an L1 and epher
as an class and no one's really done it
vitalic should uh buy back all the l2s
and uh and ban L2
tokens no comment uh so when are you
going to fight David Hoffman again I
tried to I I wanted a rematch and he
won't fight me again um which I get I'm
still so injured I've still got like
three broken ribs and my fingers are all
messed up so I can understand why he
doesn't want to do it again um but also
like come on David like give me my
rematch please and you had the broken
ribs before you even had your fight of
David so you were kind yeah they were
broken before unfortunately I didn't
realize I thought they were bruised but
yeah so what is defi
Litas and like what's your vision for it
no that's the meme coin that's 2192 they
haven't given up on it like guys let it
go it's
over yeah I was just I was thinking I'm
really like not cool I have no idea what
this thing is um so yeah I guess you do
you want to talk about
synthetics yeah I can I could talk about
synthetics um so uh synthetics got to a
point um last year where I think we
tried several different times uh to uh
find ways to coordinate it right um you
know a lot of the OG Dows um struggle
with this uh kind of power vacuum issue
right um I've talked to run about this a
little bit I joke I joked with him he
didn't think it was funny I said we
should stop creating power vacuums and
maybe that would uh would uh make the
governance problems go away but um we
we've been trying to work out how to
inject some agency back into the Dow um
and uh luckily one of the OG holders
stepped up about six months ago and said
okay you know I'm happy to to kind of
take on this role try and coordinate
people try and drive it Forward um and
rethink how uh the token mechanism um is
is made and you know I think the
interesting thing about um building in
defi is we're still very early like we
still haven't figured it out right like
just because the thing's been around for
six years doesn't mean that it's working
right it doesn't you know there's
aspects that are working um but there's
always optimizations that could be made
and if you don't have someone with
agency to kind of do some YOLO things
and try things uh then you will just
kind of stagnate right um and so I think
within the snx community there's a lot
of demand for like finding um and trying
some new things it's been a while since
there you know we've tried anything new
tried something different tried
something a bit aggressive um and so I'm
really excited because I think there's
this uh kind of new uh push you know
we've launched our own chain um you know
so more l2s um but there's also a push
to redesign the token bring it to this
new L2 and find new ways to kind of
capture value into the token and private
option again um and the final thing that
I'll say is like one of the mistakes
that defi made a few years ago um and I
contributed to this was trying to meme
into existence this real yield narrative
right it's just the I mean you know it's
the dumbest most boring narrative you
could possibly have and uh I think
everyone like fell asleep and stopped
caring about defi um we need to bring
back the fun a little bit um you know
stany was saying he's going to launch
something with 10,000% apy so I'm
looking forward to that um maybe he
announced it before on on uh his talk
but um we need to inject some excitement
back in right we need to make D5 fun
again um it's it's not trafi it's still
it's still early if it's not oh I don't
want it uh so how can defi amplify
adoption
overall versus deploying on new l2s new
chains so much Tech that building up
with that um does anyone understand what
this means yeah I think it's more of
like how can we have more types of dii
as opposed of the same type of Def
applications on just like more more l2s
um I think comes down to the types of
assets right so like defi applications
it's like a product so a product for
what assets right if it's if it's for
you know eth or let's say governance
token there can only be a certain thing
you can do with it but now that we have
more let's say types of assets like LST
LRT different kinds of rdb way then each
type of asset will require or like will
expand
the you know Innovative area of like
what you can do with it so I think uh
with the rise of new adets already being
on chain it already gives rise to more
types of defi products already um so I
think to amplify that even more then we
need um you know more types of assets on
chain and that would you know
consistently lead to more types of
products building around those assets I
think people need to understand like
what where to do what right like uh I
think the issue of having like 50,000
new l2s and new chains which are all the
same is uh there's actually like nothing
new right it might be an asset which
kind of looks like this other asset
which exists on that other chain and
like there's some variation of the same
decks but like it's a tiny bit different
doesn't really matter it's not new
experience um so I think like part of it
is study what sana's like execution
environment enabled and that enabled a
new kind of
Defi and uh ultimately you know shill
link Mega E I guess but like I think
until you have like an execution
environment which facilitates new kinds
of activity uh maybe we should stop just
like replicating the same thing and not
fragment users and just like focus on
defi on the L1 like there's def like E1
is kind of cheap now cuz like no one's
using
it it's not as cheap when you're
subsidizing people's gas trust me it
feels more
expensive what do you guys you have any
thoughts
ly um I think eventually like I think I
think there are few things that will
have like user life better right one is
on the worldist St I think wallet should
abtract away like all the different
chain for users and secondly on the
aggregation aggregator stack that will
basically like user don't need to know
that they're trading on like Unis swap
or curve or like whatever it next right
they just need like to call the API and
does it and everything will be done for
them they get they will get the best
rate they get like you know the best
execution ever right I think these two
thing will will matter a lot for defy in
general that you know user don't need to
care which chain they are on which Deck
with protocol that they interacting with
and you know this a couple of clicks
they are done
what do you think about like reaking
dii um it creates a lot of new adet and
that's good for defi so they're more
like activities more asset for people to
consider um yeah I think General is good
whether they are useful um no
commment I still don't know what reaking
is and this to afraid to
ask final words everyone go
on recking no just like any funny little
comment to say goodbye to our beautiful
audience I think we have all been
building so much infrastructure so much
applications we need to do more you know
onboarding uses um he's doing it we
should all you know do more of it and
yeah I think that would be net positive
for even infra Builders as well we have
four years to get to mass adoption and
we can basically do whatever the we
want so start doing some crazy
it's time to build yeah make your F
great again let's
go awesome thank you very much okay we
got a we transition for our last
session in back in about 3 minutes
[Music]
m
h
[Music]
yes okay bye
okay last session of the day well done I
think you guys should all give yourself
a round of applause for making it to the
day three last session well done awesome
my name is Mark Englishman living in New
Zealand we got any kiwis here no kiwis
no they all gone home okay last session
we've got we're going to talk about
corruption kyc and the cost of
compliance
so Jared hope co-founder of status and
logos welcome
[Applause]
[Music]
Jared cool all right well yeah thanks
for making it to the end I'm sure you're
hungry I'm sure you're tired I am too um
so I'm here to talk to you about
corruption kyc and the cost of
compliance um and I mean I think a lot
of people intuitively don't don't like
kyc when it's applied to them um but
don't really have never really kind of
looked into it or maybe some other
alternate narratives uh so I'm here to
give you another narrative
form so uh let's R back the clock back
to September the 10th 2001 pay attention
to this date it might look familiar to
you right Donald Rumsfeld the defense
secretary of um the United States uh had
held a press conference in which he
admitted that $2.3
trillion um of like of the uh uh
pentagon's budget was completely
unaccounted for had no idea what it was
spent on right in fact in that press
conference he went to say that the the
the adversary wasn't terrorists in fact
it was closer to home it was the
Pentagon
bureaucracy now the following year Jim
miny uh took it on himself uh to track
down just $300 million of this right he
traveled all over the United States um
and
unfortunately couldn't find it uh he
said his own quote saying we know it's
gone but we don't know what they spent
it on kind of a problem
right now fast forward to
2015 right Katherine Austin Fitz who is
the assistant secretary for the Housing
Department of Housing and Urban
Development um looked into her own
Department as well as uh the Department
of Defense and found for the year of
2015 $6.5
trillion was uh known as unsupported
adjustments right this was 54 times the
actual approved spend for the the dod um
authorized by Congress which was 122
billion dollars um now uh okay Mark
Skidmore not sure why he's not appearing
there but he's he has a face um thought
that this might have been some kind of
typo right uh surely at count point6 and
uh half trillion surely Katherine meant
62 billion so he got together um with uh
with Katherine and uh they really dove
into it um what they found is uh through
through their research is that there was
actually $21 trillion unaccounted for uh
between the period of 1998 and
right oh okay there he
is um now none this would have been this
is old new old news uh for Franklin
spinny right he was a 1983 military
whistleblower um who had already come
out in Time Magazine trying to alert the
public of this kind of spending right
he's on quote saying the books are
cooked routinely year after year so this
isn't something that happened just that
that period it's been happening for a
long
time in fact it's still happening right
so here is something that's from this
year where 8.2 billion of improperly
valued material went to Ukraine right
again no idea what that material was it
just the money got
spent um and here is uh Senator Chuck
Grassley of 2024 on quote saying that
when it comes to catching fraud the
Department of Defense internal controls
are a complete failure we've known it
for decades and he's looking quite
grumpy about it and the reason for that
is because he's basically made uh most
of his term uh tracking down this kind
of spending uh so he's found a gas
station that was created in Afghanistan
that should have cost half a million
doar actually went for $43 million right
he's found soap dishes that cost
$117 right hammers
$400 pliers
$1,000 right forks and spoons $57 each I
hope they were plated in gold right but
the most comical one is probably toilet
seat lid covers and maybe you remember
this maybe you heard about it it's
happened a few times um once in the
military where they were going for
roughly $640 per toilet seat just the
the lid right like not the entire thing
just the top part right in the Air Force
recently it's gone for $10,000 for each
lid it's a hell of a
lid so how does this happen how on Earth
can you spend 54 times your allocated
budget for in a single year right well
it's actually because of the oldest
living program that's still in operation
today this is called mocus right it's
written in cobal um I think it was
deployed uh in
19558 right um now what its purpos is
for is for uh tendering right
procurement and so on uh but what it
also happens to do is it finds unspent
money or funds in other programs that
have kind of gone stale right this is
completely illegal to do um for any
other govern department but uh here
apparently everyone seems to look the
other
way now just to give you a sense of
proportion going into this right on the
on the left hand side here we've got the
the unaccounted adjustments I've just
been talking about right this $1.2
trillion on average uh for that's being
spent per year according to that time
span of 6 and a half trillion right
adjusted for inflation that might be
around two and uh two and a half
trillion let's say right on the the
other side we've got the United Nations
estimates for illicit Financial flows on
a given year right it's somewhere
between uh two to uh they estimate two
and 2% to 5% of uh Global GDP um so
that's the 1.6 trillion and the 4
trillion bounds now the 3.1 trillion
that's on on there this sort of middle
bracket is the um an estimate of elicit
Financial flows for last year according
to nasdaq's Global crime uh Financial
crime report that came out this year
right just to give you a sense of
proportion right this is just one
government
agency the entire planet's elicit
Financial flows
okay so going back to that press
conference if you recall at the
beginning of this right the day after
911 happened right tragedy absolute
tragedy uh and as those Towers fell and
hit the ground um the world changed
right not only in terms of the
surveillance uh in terms of like uh our
Communications uh but also the
deployment of financial surveillance
around the entire planet right in just
one month uh the financial action task
force issued out the eight of their nine
special
recommendations uh and actually the uh
with the installment of the Patriot Act
uh they have basically a whole bunch of
Provisions for kyc and AML uh
specifically around sections uh 311 326
351 and 352 um so the 311 is about uh
giving the Secretary of Treasury
authority to Target specific uh money
laundering and terrorist financing risks
um 326 is about establishing uh minimum
standards for financial institutions so
like this is why you have to like hold
your passport up and take a photo of
yourself whenever you sign up for an
exchange or so on um 351 is immunity for
anyone who likes to squeal right so
reporting and if there's any issues
around reporting they're kind of immune
if it's in the name of this particular
goal and uh 352 is basically the mandate
to uh for financial institutions to
implement the program
right now I say this goes around the
globe because uh it was felt in Asian
Banks right so uh according to the Lexus
nus resolutions the true cost of uh
anti-money laundering compliance survey
in 2015
um even though local regulations were
cited the most frequently as having the
greatest impact it was known that the US
regulation embodied by the Patriot Act
which was actually what enforced the
these particular uh implementations of
policy
now we've
established agency elicit Financial
flows just to give you a sense of
proportion right now we've also seen
that it was implemented in the name of
terrorism can you see on here the amount
that has gone to
terrorism
yet maybe
oh there we go right 11.5 billion dollar
have gone to terrorism financing
according to the latest NASDAQ Global
Financial crime report um that's what we
sold out our civil liberties for just to
give you just to give you an idea of
that right now of course you might look
at that and go well you know it's been 2
and a half decades since then surely
we've solved
terrorism well actually if you roll back
the clock and look at some of the the
estimates of what that terrorism
financing looks like uh the World Bank
and the IMF basically viewed the uh
terrorism financing organizations for
the entire year of 2001 to be less than
half a billion dollar right just to give
you a sense of proportion here um in
2005 Rand found that al-qaeda's annual
budget was between $30 to $50 million in
2015 uh the Department of Treasury
estimated that Isis generated roughly a
billion dollar and in 2016 europol
estimated that that was doubled to to $2
billion now in contrast to to that um we
have this great report from the Simpson
study group on counterterrorism spending
right uh and they believe that uh
according to that report that between
the period of 2002 and
2017 uh this came to a total spend of
$2.8 trillion or $186 billion on average
per year so this this spending on
counterterrorism is 16 times larger than
what the our estimates are for ter
expending that goes towards terrorism
right that's a pretty good margin if
you're playing both sides um
anyway so I mentioned this notion of
ilicit financial flows right what are
they well there isn't really an agreed s
um consensus on on the definition but
generally speaking uh it comprises of
tax evasion multinational tax avoidance
the theft of State assets the laundering
appro states of crime uh and they Co
they cover a broad range of market and
Regulatory abuses such as corruption
drug smuggling and and human trafficking
right
um and it is important like I'm not
trying to to dismiss this at all right
so don't get that from me I'm just
trying to give you a sense of proportion
uh on on this right I it is important
because Donato uh believes that
um for every dollar that's spent on uh
invest uh that goes towards crime gets
reinvested in crime and therefore you
get more crime right um perhaps a better
analysis of this is actually bjor
lomberg who got some of the top
economists in the world uh together and
um tried to rank the United Nations
sustainable development goals on a
dollar for dooll spend right um
and they found that you know addressing
illicit Financial flows is a top
priority so why is this important why is
addressing uh ifs important well they're
basically associated with ineffective
State functioning uh timate use of state
power and uh they're kind of an
international problem because even
though you might solve it within your
own state or within your own country
that Capital will probably flow to other
countries that uh that um that's
supported in some way right um at the
end of the day it results in Lost GDP
which means there's lost tax revenue and
the argumentation is that that leads to
poor governance right and you know
higher quality governance is is is
obviously well is
desirable so what exactly are ifs and
well that depends just like the
definition so there's a myor of
different methodologies um and it's
unclear exactly uh um what comprises ifs
and this is kind of part of the problem
because it's actually hard to understand
what they are by due to their nature um
so Raymond Baker here basically view uh
views that uh 65% goes towards trade
misinvoicing trade misinvoicing is like
when a multinational corporation will do
say for example natural resource
extraction in in like one country um but
Mi
misprice the cost of extraction and the
value of uh uh resource that's extracted
and then when moving it to another
country uh changes those numbers right
um 30% towards criminal activity and 5%
towards in corruption uh the cardamone
uh view is that 80% goes towards trade
misinvoicing so this same problem and
20% towards corruption and uh the NASDAQ
Global Financial crime report uh focuses
more on the humanitarian aspects of
listed Financial flows so 25% towards
drug drug trafficking and 12 to human
trafficking with 63% just towards other
which is corruption crime and so
on
um
so even though you uh we had uh the
financial action task force and the
Patriot Act implementing these
regulations it wasn't really until uh
2015 uh sorry 2005 that elicit Financial
flows as an argumentation came onto the
scene as a pol public policy issue right
and this is actually uh through Raymond
Baker's book capitalism's Achilles heel
right um the issue is is
that um he was he's pushing a model and
uh this idea
that isn't really well substantiated and
uh Peter rudo is quite a critical of it
in
2015 where we didn't really know much
more about the issue 10 years Beyond
right
um and in fact uh there's more people
who also feel the same way right even
though we use different measures and
models uh to use to estimate money
laundering there is actually no model
that can be used to quantify uh and
accept it
globally even the financial action task
force own methodology for assessing
compliance with the uh the FTF
recommendations and effectiveness of AML
systems is completely vague right it
relies on um on the general use of crime
statistics anecdotal evidence and
subjective conclusions and this is part
of the nature of like what makes ifs so
difficult to to deal
with um now to the to their credit there
was a uh there is an ongoing pilot
program by the United Nations that is
trying to provide the highest quality
data around iffs um but uh yeah I mean
it's it's largely focused on drug
trafficking in developing countries and
you know it's you know roughly $1
billion we're talking about as some of
the bigger
ones so our follow the money methods
effective well according to the
financial actions covered right uh
Ronald F Paul believes that less than
0.1% of um of uh criminal finances is
impacted by follow the money methods uh
and according to the UN this is roughly
0.2% in other words
99.8% of criminal proceeds are
completely unaffected by all of the kyc
that we've
implemented so what can we measure we
can measure the cost of implementing
compliance right uh and according to the
Lexus Nexus resolutions reports um for
the uh United States Banks alone this is
roughly
26.4 billion annually that's double the
amount that's got going towards
terrorism financing in the us
alone uh in fact Ronald Li Paul believes
that compliance costs exceed recovered
criminal funds more than a 100 times
over uh and the banks and the taxpayers
and ordinary citizens are penalized more
than criminal Enterprises that's you and
that's
me in fact this has been known at the
occd uh and B20 uh for several years in
fact the all of those costs get past on
to us and in in particular when it comes
to traditional trade Finance uh 50 to
60% of the uh um sorry of the the these
cost uh or more than half the price of
your trade is charged to
clients and a large portion of that is
associated with
compliance now so why why am I talking
about this
well there's another inverse way to
think about this and there's a great uh
that we understand in institutional
economics that if we can reduce
transaction costs in the abstract uh
sense by
0.1% this enables a country to be able
to quadruple its wealth that's the
difference between Argentina and
Switzerland right so we can actually
create better and more efficient
institutions that lower transactions and
and I mean like you know when you like
line up in the DMV or if you're filling
out a form that's like associated with
transaction costs in this in an
Institutional sense right if you can
reduce that by using like say smart
contracts or smart paper or whatever um
we can enable more wealth and which will
probably lift a lot more people out of
uh or just make a higher quality of
life in fact Michael Levy basically says
that no one could rationally think that
AML controls in general or financial
investigation in particular will solve
organized crime completely or eliminate
high level offending right for there
even to be a chance to achieve that
there would need to be a step in change
and trans Arcy and effective action
against high level corruption along all
possible Supply chains right it's a huge
problem why is that a huge problem well
before I get into
that Amnesty International uh created a
report called weaponizing
counterterrorism I highly recommend you
read it um but they basically showed how
the Indian uh government has been
exploiting uh the 2010 uh and 2013 ftfs
assessments um to Target you know human
rights activists journalists students um
uh academics and so on right and so this
is one of the issues with these kinds of
recommendations what happens is that if
you don't Implement them on time uh you
can be excluded from the economic system
right you can be excluded from member
states and so this leads to rushing bad
law through their parliaments and when
they're in are in place politicians can
then use them for political gain um
they've been used to uh suppress
political
opponents um it's not just Amnesty
International talking about that it's
also the Royal United Services Institute
in the in the UK this is a 100-year-old
Think Tank very well prestigious and
well respected uh they focus on uh
authoritarian regimes but as we just
seen it doesn't apply just Toth
authoritarian
regimes so who is perpetrating it like
are we really ones to blame uh Alex
copham doesn't believe so in fact he
says that ifss are likely to be by and
large an elite phenomenon right so the
the the financial and political Elite um
and the reason for this is because
that's where the systems of abuse are
likely to be strongest and where the
capital is concentrated um they're the
ones who make the rules uh and therefore
they're the ones who can break
them uh and to give an example of this
you know you might recall Jamie Diamond
uh CEO of JP Morgan Trac is on record
basically saying crypto is a tool for
criminal drug traffickers and money
laundering and tax avoidance and if he
was the government he would shut us
down there's a certain irony in that
that uh basically uh the following year
no following weeks I think after that
statement um he was hit for a oh not him
but JP Morgan Chase uh was hit for fines
totaling roughly $39 billion for doing
exactly those
things uh this was part of the send
files which basically shows it's not
just exclusively JP Morgan Chase but
many major
Banks now when it comes to financial
secrecy you might think of like uh tax
Havens in like nice Lush exotic
Caribbean islands you might think of
even Switzerland but I wanted to point
out the financial secrecy index and
particularly look at the global scale
weight here the United States stands out
at roughly
25% in contrast to the second position
of Switzerland which is has less than 4%
right their policies are literally uh as
rold said closer to
home ptoa goes on to say asking a
kleptocratic state to create an
effective AML system is like asking the
fox to create a better handh housee it
is the governing political Elite that
benefits the most substantially from the
weakness of existing systems and
controls and this is a problem because
this ktoy issue is real um according to
this blue ber report trust in most us
institutions has been withering uh
across the board it doesn't matter where
you look public you know Civil Society
the public has is losing confidence this
is not just happening in the US but it's
happening globally whether you look at
the United uh the United Kingdom or in
France um you'll see that uh trust is
declining in fact if you look at the OCD
reports the average public trust in
governments hovers around just
41% we can do a lot better in terms of
providing quality of
governance in fact to coroporate the
same the point Transparency
International came out in 2023 saying
that over two-thirds of countries score
below 50 out of 100 strongly indicating
that they have serious corruption
problems now why is this
important uh well another way to to view
this klepto uh problem of kleptocracy is
that government debt is growing in fact
reached unsustainable levels um in many
of the advanced emerging economies um
and this is from the Peterson Institute
and intern uh International economics in
2011 um even though those talking about
two uh 25 years we're kind of already
quite into that um and this is also
evidenced by Foreign um foreign
sovereigns not buying US
debt um in fact uh since the 1800s uh 52
countries saw a debt to GDP ratio above
30% 51 of those have defaulted and today
the United States is at
120% by 2033 they're going to be above
130 uh and that's according to the
Congressional budget office uh in
2018 now the those challenges are also
not unique to the United States
according to the national International
uh Council um they've projected many uh
governments of the OC many governments
of the OC countries uh are likely to
experience this same economic
difficulties um a little bit over time
but uh so the financial action task
force is also quite interesting in of
itself right because it has a unique
form of sovereignty as a
non-governmental organization it has no
legal basis um it enjoys this Sovereign
me uh uh sovereign immunity granted to
it by its member states right um it has
no oversight uh even though it is based
in Paris in the OCD building it is not
the jurisdiction of the the French
government neither um uh neither the OCD
countries um so they they kind of can do
whatever they want and have no real
pressure to to reform unless all member
states start participating in that um as
I mentioned if you don't follow them you
results in uh economic lockout of the
the Global Financial system and there's
no way to opt
out so why does this matter
because if we can start solving
governing
institutions um we can start unlocking
trillions of dollars worth of value
rather than just disappearing Into The
Ether there's this great report called
the uh from the World Bank called where
is The Wealth of Nations uh and what
they found is that human capital and the
value of Institutions as measured by the
rule of law actually constitutes the
largest share of wealth in virtually all
countries this is beyond natural
resource extraction
so at the end of the day what I'm trying
to convey to you is that we should stop
thinking from a scarcity mindset or when
it comes to follow the money methods and
instead what we can actually do is
improve our institutions if we can make
them faster more efficient uh and maybe
even develop them in parallel then we
can actually create a much better and
thriving world and a higher quality of
life for for all thank you
[Applause]
thank you Jared that was awesome and uh
that is concludes the day so uh we wish
you a safe travels back and thank you
very much for coming
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
m n
o
[Music]
t
o
[Music]
h